hey everyone
welcome to another video by simply learn
in this video python data visualization
tutorial we will teach you everything
that you need to know about data
visualization in python
data visualization is the field
of representing data that you already
have in a visual form which makes it
easier for both you
and the user to understand it
python has mainly three main libraries
which help in data visualization
in this tutorial we will teach you
everything that you need to know about
these three different libraries and how
you can use them to visualize your data
better
to begin
we will start with the matplotlib
library
we will explain matplotlib to you
teach you about the different types of
plots
and how to plot different graphs and sub
graphs in matplotlib
we will also look at how you can include
graph parameters like titles legends and
labels into your matplotlib graphs
then
we will move on to seaborn
we will explain what is c bond to you
and then understand python c bond better
with the help of a hands-on demo
feel free to follow along with it
and finally we will take a look at the
bokeh library offered by python which is
used to make interactive graphs in
python
we will explain different graphs like
scatter charts line charts pie charts
histograms bar plots etc in bokeh and
how you can implement them and make them
user friendly and interactive
and finally we will take a look at the
layout function in python which is used
to make
interactive web interfaces
so
let's get started
we're going to study the matplot library
and the python code so what's in it for
you what is matplot library types of
plots plotting graphs and sub graphs
adding a graph inside a graph graph
parameters title label legend line
graphs line types color and transparency
canvas grid and axis range 2d plots
scatter step bar fill between radar
chart histogram contour image 3d surface
image and then we'll hit a practice
example pie chart
so let's start with what is matte plot
library map plot library is an open
source drawing library which supports
rich drawing types it is used to draw 2d
and 3d graphics
and there are so many packages in the
matplot library we're going to cover the
basics and there are so many packages
that sit on top of the maplight library
that we can't even cover them all today
but we'll hit the main one so you have a
good understanding of what the matplot
library is and what the basics can do
you can understand your data easily by
visualizing it with the help of matplot
library you can generate plots
histograms bar charts and many other
charts with just a few lines of code and
here we have some basic types of plots
you can see here that we'll go into we
have the bar chart the histogram boy i
use a lot of histograms in my stuff
scatter plot line chart pie chart and
area graph
let's start plotting them and to do this
i'm going to be using jupiter notebook
you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the jupiter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual and in our jupyter notebook
which opens up in this case i'm using
google chrome you can go up here to new
and we'll create a new python 3 and set
that up
if you're not familiar with jupyter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that you'll
look at any of our tutorials i usually
cover a number of them showing how to
set up jupiter and anaconda i myself use
jupiter through anaconda in fact let's
go ahead and open that up and just take
a look at see what that looks like you
can see your anaconda navigator if you
install it it will automatically install
the jupyter notebook and that also
installs a lot of other things i know
some people like the qt console for
doing python or spider i've never used
them i actually use notepad plus plus as
one of my editors and then i use the
jupiter notebook a lot because it's so
easy to have a visual while i'm
programming and even simple script in
python i'll take it from the jupyter
notebook and then do a save as you
always go under file and you can
download as a python program so that
will download it as an actual python
versus the ipython that this saves it as
so let's go ahead and dive in and see we
got going here and let's go ahead and
put matplot library tutorial and i'm
going to turn this cell into a mark down
so it doesn't actually run it you can
see it has a nice little title there
that's all jupiter notebook
and then from mat plot library
let's import
pi lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print
we'll go pi lab
and the version let's go ahead and run
this so we're going to import our pi lab
module from the matplot library and we
find out the word version 1.15.1
always important to note the version
you're in probably i was reading an
article that said the number one thing
that python programmers struggle with is
remembering what version they're working
in and making sure that they're going
from one platform to the other with the
same version and if we're going to graph
things i think we need some data to
graph so we're going to import numpy as
np now if you're not familiar with numpy
definitely go back and check out our
numpy tutorial there's so many different
things you can do with it dealing with
reshaping the data and creating the data
we're just going to use it to create
some data for us and there is a lot of
ways to create data but we're going to
use the np.line space
so we're going to create a numpy array
and the way you read this is we're going
to create numbers between 0 and 10 and
we're going to create 25 of these
numbers we're just going to divide that
equally up between 0 and 10. and if we
have x coordinates we should probably
have some y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times x
plus 2. and let's just take a look we're
going to print x
and print
y
let me go ahead and run this
and let's see what we got going on here
so we have our x coordinates which is 0
0.4 0.83 etc and you can look at this as
an xy plot so we have zero we have two
we have point four one six we have two
point one seven and just as a quick
reminder we're gonna do print np array x
comma y dot reshape 25 comma 2. and the
reason i want to do this is i want to
show you something here
a lot of times a program returns x comma
y and it's an array of x comma y x comma
y x comma y
and so when you're working with the pie
plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if i start off with pairs like
this i can reshape them if i know
there's 25 pairs in there i can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
i'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25
and if i run that you'll see i end up
with the same output as the x y the two
different arrays in here and this is
important that we want x and y separate
again that's all numpy stuff but it's
important to understand that this is a
format that matplot library works with
it works with an array of x's and they
should match your array of y's so each
one has 25 different entities in it
and then for our basic plotting of this
data it only takes one command to draw
graph of this data and so we use our
from up here we imported pi lab we take
our pi lab and the key net under there
is plot for plotting a line and then we
want our x coordinates and our y
coordinates and we'll throw in r and the
r simply means red so we're going to
draw the line in red let me go and run
that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's b
for blue we have a lot of fun yellow
hard to see yellow there we go but we'll
go ahead and stick with red
run
and when you're doing presentations with
these try to be consistent you know if
the business and the shareholders send
you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but it's whatever
they're using whatever the company's
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around every time one
graph has red for loss and one graph has
blue for loss it gets really confusing
so make sure you're consistent in your
graphs and your coloring and something
to know because we're going to cover
this in a minute this is your canvas
size so we have a canvas here and what
we're going to do next is we're going to
look at sub graphs
okay
so let's take our pi lab and create a
sub
plot
and one of the things also to know when
we're working with the
matplot library i'm not setting when i
do this this is my drawing canvas the pi
lab so once i've imported the pi lab i'm
drawing my images on there very
important to know and with the subplot
we're going to give it some different
values
and we're going to represent by rows
columns and indexes and let's do one two
one so it's going to be the first row
second column and the index is like you
can stack your graphs and things like
that we don't worry too much about
indexes but rows and columns we want to
go ahead and use row one and column two
and if we're going to have one object we
should probably have two but before we
do that we have to
plot data onto the subplot so the order
is very important and we're going to
stick with their x comma y
and let's do this we're going to add in
a third parameter here remember we did
red we're going to add shorthand dash
dash for dashed lines so this plots the
data into row one column two
and if we're going to do that let's do
another one pi
lab.subplot and if we're gonna do row
one let's do
column two and index two
and this time we're gonna add g for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pi lab subplot
here we go by lab we've got to go ahead
and plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of x y we want y comma x
oops i messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells it the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switched them and the color and then the
style shorthand now let's go ahead and
run that
and you'll see it takes this canvas
splits it in two and now we have two
different graphs and we have the red one
with dashed lines and we have the green
one which is has a little stars going up
and if we take this and let's just um
just for fun let's change this and run
that with an index of one it puts them
both on the same index and also gives me
a warning because it's a strange way of
doing two subplots there's depreciated
there's another way to do it but most
people just ignore that warning because
it's not going to go away anytime soon
now that's using the same setup what
happens if we do
instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
it didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as 2 and let's change the row on
the second one to 2
and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together and causes some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where i made some changes i said row two
and look what happens when i change to
column two so i now have row two column
two index two i squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does and there's all kinds
of different things you really have to
just play with these numbers till you
get a handle on them because
you know we have to repeat it 164 times
according to cambridge university if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where we go three
run there we go but you can see it takes
a little bit sometimes to play with
these and get the numbers right i hope
they hit the wrong one that's why let's
go three there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so i
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the
where we have column and row two and the
two different indexes so they appear
nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
gives us that warning and you can see we
now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's
next look at operator description and
we'll go ahead and turn this cell into a
down and run that so it looks nice so
fig and you remember i talked about the
canvas earlier i briefly mentioned it
we're going to look a little bit more at
the canvas later on but that's what the
figure is fit we're going to add axes so
we're going to initialize the subplot
add the subplot
in rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this you can do
let's look at that code and see exactly
what's going on and i want you to notice
that there's fig which is the actual
canvas in the matplot library and ax is
commonly used to refer to the subplots
so we're creating subplots you'll see ax
equals plt subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as plt
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
plt just like pandas is pd and numpy
array is np certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but i would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above
with the pi lab but with the plt so if
it looks familiar there's reason we're
doing this because we want to show you
how the figure part works and working
with the canvas goes but we're going to
do the same plot as we did before and
we'll call it fig and we're going to set
that equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
left right the width the height of the
canvas from 0 to 1.
so we can go ahead and i'm just going to
put some stuff in there i got 0.5 0.1
0.8.8 so when you're looking at this
this is a zero to one or you could say
50 percent 10
80 80 percent but it's a control it's
going to control your left and your
right along with the width and the
height so the width and the height we're
going to use 80 percent and we're going
to have like a little indent on the left
and the right and this should look
familiar from above x's dot plot
x comma y
and then let's give it a color how about
red since we're recreating the same
graph let's keep it uniform oops and it
helps if i use a ax i s instead of ax es
i don't know where that came from but
this looks identical to the one we had
up above so here's our axis plot x comma
y of red
same graph same setup but this time
we've added a variable equal to the
figure dot add axes so our plot figures
our canvas our axes is what we're
working in and then our axis.plot x
comma y
and again we can draw sub graphs we put
that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different temptation here we have fig
comma
axes equal
plt.subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows
we're going to do one row
and columns equals 2. so if you remember
before that's what we did we had one row
with two different graphs on it we're
going to do the same thing but know how
we did this here's our figure our canvas
and our axes we're going to create
actually two different axes we're going
to create row one column two and so axis
is an array of information so we can
simply do
for
let's do x in axes
this will now look familiar x dot plot
we're going to do x comma y we'll go
ahead and make a red
keep everything looking the same
remember nice uniform graphs everything
looks the same and if we go ahead and
run this
you'll see we get two nice side-by-side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you'll
see we'll have three on there and let's
even make it a little bit more
interesting we'll do in rows equals to
two and you can see down here we're
going to get an attribute eric's is
trying to scrunch everything together
so it does have a limit how much stuff
you can put in one small space that's
important to know you can fix that by
changing the canvas size which we'll
look at in just a minute and there's
other ways to change it on here but here
we go we can do in rows two and columns
equals one you can see two nice images
right above each other we'll go back to
the original one row two columns side by
side left to right and
we can also
draw a picture or graph
inside another graph
that's kind of a fun thing to do it's
important to note that we can layer our
stuff on top of each other which makes
for a really nice presentation
so let's start by uh fig let's create
another figure so we're going to start
over again with our canvas we set that
equal to plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axis
one equals fig dot add axes remember
this from earlier
and this here similar numbers we used
before saying how big this axis is this
figure in the axes is so this is going
to be the big
axes and let's do axes 2 equals
another figure at axes
five
and
then
point three
and if we're going to do this they need
data on them so let's go ahead and plot
some data on our axes so axis one dot
plot
and we'll make this simply x comma y
comma make it red and then let's go axes
two dot plot
and let's reverse them y comma x comma
green there we go doing what i told you
not to do you shouldn't be swapping axes
around and plotting your data in five
different directions because it's
confusing let's go ahead and run this
and see what this looks like and then
let's talk a little bit about this we
talked about the 0.2.5.4.3
and let me just grab the annotation for
that that's left right width and height
so we have in here that this is going to
be left right so here's our left is
point one in point five and we you know
what let's just play with this a little
bit what happens when i change this to
point one moves it way over to the left
so there's our point one so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the the branches on here point two
point five is the
left so that's our right so see what
happens when we do point oh let's make
this point one that actually is they had
it down at left right i thought this was
wrong it's actually how far from the
bottom let me switch that on here bottom
there we go so we had here on this we
can go ahead and put that back to 0.5
and run that and this is 0.3 let's make
this 0.3 also and that is the width and
then of course there's the height we can
make that really tight actually let's do
0.2 and let's run that and you can see
it changes the height on there we make
it even smaller 0.2 by 8.2 and as you
can see you can get stuck playing with
this to make it look just right it can
sometimes take a little bit
certainly once you have the settings if
you're doing a presentation you try to
keep it uniform unless it doesn't make
sense for the graph you're working on
try to keep the same colors the same
position and the same look and feel
and i mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas size so this is from earlier
i just copied it down below we're going
to re-plot the same data we've been
looking at
and what we can do is we can change the
figure size to 16 by nine let me run
that and show you what that looks like
so it fills the whole screen and then if
you are normally when you're working on
the screen you don't worry too much
about this but we can set the dpi
to 300
run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality i would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever i'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there you can go a lot
higher too but keep in mind the higher
you get the more memory it takes the
more lag time and the more resources you
use so usually 300 is a good
solid number to use your dots per inch
and you can see it drills a nice it
draws a nice large canvas here which is
16 by nine and then the dpi is 300 on
here it's a little higher quality and
just out of curiosity i wonder how long
it takes to draw something double that
size 600 and you can see here where at
600 dpi it's going to take a while there
it goes just because it's utilizing a
lot more graphics on there and let me
just go back to the 300 now we'll
actually do let's do a 100 you're not
going to see a difference on this
because it is web based graphics are
pretty low
and up here you saw i did this with the
plot figure this works the same if i do
figure axes subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axes
dot plot
x comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our axis on the subplot on here
with the fixed size and the dpi let me
take this all out let me just remove all
that real quick run it again there we go
now we're back to our original figure
and let's look at some of the other
things you can do with this one things
we do is we can set a title for the axis
so axis set title you'll see right here
since they put this on the axis it's the
main title for the whole graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our x
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it x and y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
x label and y label whoops where'd they
go and it turns out in this environment
that you have to put it before the title
so let me go ahead and put it before the
title and there's our x y and then we
run that and of course we can also do up
our size a little bit and see what's
going on a little better so here we have
x label x if you come down here you'll
see our x label and our y label we can
of course change this to x
label you can change this to y
maybe whatever you want on here of
course and our title graph there we go
run so here we have our title graph our
y label and our x label all set up on
our nice little plot and then before we
move on to the next section let's do one
more thing on here we have a thing
called the legend and we're going to do
we're going to set our ax legend label 1
label 2 up here it's a format for it but
let's go down here and actually use it
i'm going to do two different plots
we're going to have axes plot x by x
times x squared and x cubed and if i run
this you'll see it puts two nice graphs
on the setup on there but it's nice to
have a legend telling you what's going
on so for the legend we can actually do
axes since we have the two plots legend
and on here we've created an array
and we have y equals x squared y equals
x cubed you can actually put this as
whatever you want those are just strings
and then location two and let's go ahead
and run this and see what that looks
like and you can see it puts a nice
legend on the upper left hand corner
location two we can do location three
and run it and it drops it down to the
bottom
location one i can't remember where
that's at there we go upper right so
each one of these is a number that
refers to the different locations on the
screen zero kinda have to play with them
or look them up to remember where
they're at but they do work it just kind
of moves around depending on where you
want your legend out on there so on this
section we cover the title the graph the
y labels and legends this is we're
getting into some starting to look
really fancy here so we now have
something we can actually put out you'll
see the title of the graph looks a
little fuzzy so i might in a web setup
put the dpi up a couple notches maybe
put it at 200 100 might work fine just
so you know something to notice on here
when you're playing with these different
things we had our subplots dpi equals oh
let's do 200 to see what that looks like
so you can see now it's a lot clearer
it's also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
dpi dots per inch
so the next section is let's look at
some graph features we're going to look
at line color transparency size and a
few more things on here and oops i
forgot the main title so we have our
figure and our axes equals our plot and
subplots and i'm going to do a dpi
equals 150 so the graph comes out nice
and large and easy for you to see
and let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do x by x plus once which is
going to be a straight line plot
x plus x plus two
and axis.plot
x x plus three this looks like we're
doing nearest neighbor setup we're
showing how it uh located data and
putting your lines on there between the
nearest neighbors there we go so it
draws a nice little graph with three
lines on it one of the things we can do
is we can control the alpha on this oops
and you can actually see the um when
they did these lines it automatically
pulls in different colors for your setup
so there's some automatic automatic
things going on in there and a lot of
times we do that comma r but we're going
to do color equals red another notation
on here let's go ahead and run this now
we have a bright red line down there and
with the map plot library you're not
limited to red you can also use the one
of many different color references as
you see here with the pound sign one one
five five dd which just is just blue and
we can do the same thing with another
color on here which it turns out to be
green i can just as easily do this green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what i want to do is i want to
make this we're going to set what's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5
so this is halfway see-through when i
run this and it's almost going to look
pink because you can see through it and
let's change this just a little bit just
to make this kind of fun let's square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because i plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha halfway through so let's go ahead
and do this alpha equals 0.5 and oh you
know what instead of squaring it let's
take it to the 0.5 power that'll be kind
of interesting to see what that does
we'll just go to keep it squared there
we go and run that and let's go back and
look at this where it crosses over and
the first thing you see right here is on
the blue it's kind of light blue now you
can see how the two colors add together
you get almost a purple on there so i
can clearly see where the red cross is
the blue line and then the green just
blanks it over because i didn't do any
opaqueness no alpha on there
so this is great if you have lots of
data that crosses over and you need to
be able to track those lines better and
we'll go ahead and do this 0.5 and we'll
run that oops i did
equals 0.5 let me go ahead and run that
and so you can see right here now you
can easily see the red line how it
crosses the green and the blue down here
and if we want to we can do this as uh
the default is one solid so we can
change this all to point eight let me
just do that
oops 58 there we go run
up so must have hit a wrong button there
let me try that again i actually get rid
of a bracket and let's go ahead and run
that
and we come down here and look at this
you can still see where it passes behind
them but the green dominates and the
blue dominates because we're now at
eighty percent instead of fifty percent
when you can do less that's kind of fun
although at some point the lanes kind of
fade
so point five is usually the best
setting on there we have a nice pastel
here at point three and you can easily
see where they cross over and just like
you can play with the colors we can play
with line width and you know let's do
let's try dpi 100 and see what that
looks like on my screen equals 100 and
we'll go ahead and just take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just you
can see how they look next to each other
real quick here there we go
and if i run this they should all appear
the same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
i forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what i want to do
is i want to do the line width
width
equals
0.25 and let's just copy and paste that
down here
let's do equals one
about 1.5 and let's do one let's make
this equal to two let's see what that
looks like and we do that you can see it
goes from a very thin line a point five
a one are one point five and two which
is twice the width of the one and if
we're going to do different sizes we had
different colors we had our alpha scheme
let's take this whole thing here
let's paste it down here and do another
one
but instead of line width let's look at
styles something to know here you can
actually abbreviate this with lw so line
width can also be point let's just do
everything point two and let's set up a
line style we'll do the first one dashes
let me just paste that down here
so i'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
take this out so we have our dashed
we can do a dash dot let's do the dash
dot here and a colon here there we go
and there's a lot of different options
we'll look at a few more as we go down
for different ways of highlighting data
but when you look at this we have
everything as a line width of two and
now we have a straight line we have a
dashed line or a dot dash and a dot dot
line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did x let's do x plus um 4.
so it goes right on the top and do color
black line width 1.5 so it's a smaller
line
and we're going to take the line and
we're going to set dashes so look i've
changed some of the notation here for my
line and my ax plot so i can set my line
comma equal to x plot and then i can
change the line settings this way and
when i run this let me run that on here
you'll see the 5 10 15 10 creates a
series of dashes that are buried in link
link in this case they alternate between
a short dash and a long dash we can play
with these numbers curiosity always has
me what happens when you play with the
numbers just to see what they look like
let's do this let's paste this down here
i'll do two of these just because
they're kind of fun to play with and
let's change this from 10 to
3 and we're going to change this one
from 15
to
4. and let's run that
and you can see the differences in the
lines oops very a little bit confusing
on there because i forgot to change the
lines are all on top of each other so
let me change that really quick here and
let's run that and now you can see
here's our original dashed line
alternating when i change these numbers
on the second one the very end value to
three you can see now we have the dashes
of five let's see i'm going to guess
this is a dash is a five skip ten dashes
of 15 skip three and then it goes back
to the beginning dash is five dashes
skip ten fifteen dashes skip three and
of course the last one we just switched
up a little bit it looks a lot more
uniform because i'm using two sets of
ten or if i did something like this and
change it to thirty it really becomes
pronounced as far as the distances
between them and instead of 4 let's go
oh let's put 30 here also 30 by 30.
there we go really pronounced on that
one now let's look at one more important
group for plotting our data and in this
we're going to here's our plot we
started with with the x plus one x plus
two x plus three and did it in blue on
this one's three or four different blue
lines
and this property we wanna add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this let's see it puts a dot for each of
these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero and each of the different values of
x y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
you can also do
plus sign that's another option dots is
most common i'll actually like the dots
the best if we do the plus sign you see
if it's a nice crosshairs or plus sign
on there and we can do a marker there's
a number of different markers you can
use
and i think this one was it s is another
one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one s for square o for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is uh number one so
if we run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks
and let's take oh let's just go with the
o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some stuff we're gonna do here on
just a second let's do marker
size equals two
and change that to five and run that and
you can see here it's a nice little tiny
dot versus a the size dot here this is
interesting because it said two i
thought it would be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it gets even smaller
and let's just do 10 to see what that
looks like run that looks huge so marker
size a lot of these are dependent on the
dpi and the setups there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers and then
let's take our square on here and we'll
do we have marker size so we also have
marker face we'll set that equal to red
of course we need to take change the so
it's up one notch we'll run that whoops
must have mistyped something on here and
i did it's marker face color equals red
and so when i run that you can now see i
have the squares on there with the
marker face color of course we can mix
and match these
come down here and we'll make this
instead of let's make this plus seven
and we'll make this
size 15
marker face color
equals
and we'll do what green just because
there we go run very hard to actually
see what's going on there still 25 dots
they kind of overlap as you can see they
print them over each other and of course
if we really wanted to make it look
horrible we could just make that really
huge generally though you want something
a little bit smaller and cuter we'll
just try doing it this way there we go
that's too small to even see the face so
four you can start to see the face on
there around four and maybe an eight
eight might be a good number for this
there we go eight again that all just
depends on what you're trying to show
and display
so we've covered a lot of stuff here as
far as our lines we've covered
opaque with our alpha setting on there
give us some nice pastels you can see
how they overlap and how they cross over
we covered the line with different size
on there different formats for the line
itself and these are all you can combine
all these so we can have our line width
equals two line style equals dash you
can bring this down here also to the
markers and then we added markers in
just entered a circle a
plus sign the square a little tick which
uses a one
then we had a marker size and a marker
color face and we combined those you see
we get a nice different series of
representations we also briefly
mentioned color where you didn't have to
use like in here we used color black
someplace up here and have to find it we
use the actual number for the color as
opposed to i changed them to red and
blue so you can get very precise on the
color if you have a very specific color
set that you need to match your website
or whatever you're working on all those
are tools in the matplot library so we
have one more piece to formatting the
graph so we want to show you and then we
have two big sections we're going to go
over the different graphs that they have
along with a challenge problem so let's
go to the last section we're going to
look at is limits we're going to limit
our data
so this first primer is going to paste
in there we're going to create our
subplots 1 two so one row two columns
we're gonna do a figure size of ten
comma five this should all look familiar
now since we've done a number of them
and we're gonna go ahead and plot and
this is an interesting notation you
should notice here our axis zero so one
we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of zero is still
the axes of the first axes out of two
and we're going to plot x
x squared
x
x cubed line with two so we're going to
go ahead and just plot two graphs right
on top of each other without doing
multiple plots on here and we'll set the
grid equal to true one here let's go
ahead and run that
and you can see here our two plots with
the x value going across
and i'm going to do something similar
and by the way as you can just if you
look at it you can see the grid on there
that's all that is easier to spot the
data going across we're going to take
the same data for axes 1. so we have our
plot of x x squared x and x cubed line
with two
and this time we're going to take our
axes one and do y limit
it's actually set underscore y limit
this is the y axis so it's going to be
an array of two two values and we'll do
0 comma 60 i'm just making these numbers
up the guys in the back actually made
them up i'm just using their numbers
we're going to set the x limit
and we'll set the x limit as um don't
forget our brackets there
two comma five
so it's the same data going in and but
we're setting a limit on it let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the y
limit zero to 60 so we're looking at
just the lower part of this curve here
up to here and we have the x limit 2 to
5. so that starts right here at 2 and
you can see very different graphs this
is kind of nice because you could
actually put one of these on top of the
other if you wanted to draw focus to one
part of a graph remember how we did that
earlier one inside the other but just a
quick note you can easily limit your
graph and re kind of reshape the way it
looks quite easily and we can also add
that grid down there if we want a grid
we'll run that and add the grid in there
oops i guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if i change it to one so in this case
might not be the order i wonder if we'll
go back here as one there we go so
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data
so let's start looking at some other 2d
graphs and make this cell a markdown so
we run it as a nice pretty title to it
and let's go ahead and create some data
with an np array we'll do
0 to 5 on here there we go and let's
look at uh four common graphs we'll put
them side by side so we'll do a figure
our axes equals plot subplots one four
columns and then figure size hopefully
it'll fit nicely on here it seems to do
a pretty good on here and i'll go and
just run that since we're in there run
you'll see i have no four blank plots on
here
and we'll start with axes of zero let's
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of
zero
dot scatter easy to remember scatter a
bunch of plots on there we'll do our
n or we can do x or n there we go and
let's go ahead and do axes set title
scatter i've already did that we're just
going to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scatter control and we'll do
let's do the variable x
x
plus let's throw some randomness in here
usually scatter plots are i have a lot
of random numbers connected to them
that's why they do them on there and so
the bigger the x gets the bigger the
randomness so 0.25 times the randomness
and what we should end up doing here is
with the scatter plot and you can see as
you go up it just kind of has some
random numbers and moves up and down the
line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker
this is plotting basically just the
marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
exes one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time we'll use our n value
instead of x we generated that n value
up here and so for this we have n n
times 2 r n squared n times 2 n squared
line width equals 2 and if we run that
it creates a nice step up
let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a steps
plot let's do a bar plot
and we'll use the same formula in n
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is
let's see what that looks like on there
so we have some nice you can see here a
nice bar plot it should look very
similar to the step plot but colored in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9 run and if we
take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so now you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center
and run that
everything you really can't see the
shift on here because that's actually
the default on this but these are common
settings for the bar graph let me just
put them back in there there we go
alignment center and alpha now i can't
say i have used the step craft very much
there's certain other certain i guess
domains of expertise require a step
graph but the scatter plot and the bar
graph very common especially the bar
graph and we'll look at histograms here
in just a minute so i use histograms a
lot especially in data science but this
is nice if you have very uh concrete
objects somebody how many people are
wearing yellow hats that kind of thing
but if we're going to do that let's go
ahead and do the last one which i see a
lot more in the sciences certainly using
the data science but more like for
mapping i saw publication on
solar flares and they were discussing
the energy and so filling in the graph
gives it a very different look so we're
going to do the fill between
and it's just like you think it'd be
it's fill between but with a underscore
between them and we'll do x and x
squared and x and x cubed and we'll do
color green and alpha again in case you
had other data you want to plot on there
you can see it forms a nice squared
coming up here and also if you look at
the bottom one is your squared value the
upper line is your cubed value and then
it fills in everything in between
if you remember from calculus this would
be if you had like a car a motor and
efficiency they would talk about the
efficiency going up and the loss and
you're looking for the space or the area
between the two lines so it gives you a
nice visual of that now let's look at a
few more basic two dimensionals so we
have our figure figure size on here
we're going to do a radar chart to be
honest i've never used a radar chart in
business or in data science i can't find
a reason to use one now so the first
line for doing a radar chart we have to
add axes into the figure and with this
this actually creates our
oh let's let's run it so you can see
what it creates it creates a nice looks
like you're on a submarine and you're
tracking the hunt for red october or
something like that and it needs all of
these the polar is the fact that we're
doing polar coordinates
zero zero point six point six has to do
with the size if you take out any of
these things and run them you get just a
box
if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had 0.6 on here i'll go ahead and
leave it as one because that's just kind
of fun that's all about the size on here
the height and the width and then let's
create some data t equals np line space
and this is 0 to 2 times np times pi so
if you remember that is the
distance across and we're going to
generate a hundred points so this is
just a thing of data we're putting
together then we can simply do an ax dot
plot and in this case let's do t comma t
which would be a diagonal line on a
regular chart and we'll give it a nice
color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of t
times 0.5 there we go
and you can see it slightly alters the
way it spirals out we could do t times
two spirals that a little quicker so
it's kind of just a fun i've like i said
i've never used a
radar chart it's a column but you can
always think of radar submarine kind of
looks like one of those or an airplane
and none of this would be completed if
we didn't discuss histograms oh my gosh
do i use a histogram so much and we'll
use our numpy that we have set as np to
generate oh looks like we have a hundred
thousand variables we're going to set
equal to n and of course we create our
figure and our axes subplots one two
figure size 12 14. so we're going to
look at two different variations of the
histogram and we'll set a title default
histogram set our title there
and then this is simply
hist for histogram and we'll just go
ahead and put in our n in there and let
me run this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here
so we generated an array here of data
1000 random arrays it looks like they're
mostly between -4 and 4
and then it adds up each one it says
zero you have 35 000 that are zero so
that's what's most common on here and we
have 20 000 that are somewhere in this
range right here between the minus two
and well it looks like one minus two and
somewhere between 0 and 1 there's 30 000
numbers so all this is saying is this is
how common these variables are and this
gives you this point in so many
directions when you're looking at data
science to go ahead and run your
histogram so you should always have your
histogram and you can always put limits
and all the other different things on
your array just like you did on the
other graphs on there and then we're
going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram
and all it is is a histogram let me just
do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bins equal 50. and i really want to
highlight the um the cumulative equals
true is important but we can now choose
how many bins we have in the first one
it kind of selected them for us in this
case let me go ahead and run this and
you'll see it has the prints the data
out for us and here's our whoops
must have missed oh there we go doesn't
help that i put it over the old one
there we go okay
so now you have your default histogram
and then we have a cumulative histogram
and we should have 50 steps in there and
let's just find out if that's true not
so much by counting them i'm not going
to count them if you want to you can
count them let's just change it to 10
and see what happens and we see here we
have now 10 counts of that
and we could set that for 5
and run that
and then we have our 5 on there and we
go ahead and take the cumulative equals
true out just so you can see what that
looks like and let me run that on here
too
that looks just like it did before i
think there's one two three four five
six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
put that back in there run
and so now it should look almost
identical and it does and then we can
put the cumulative back in see what that
looks like with the cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different look wait it shifts it all to
the right no it doesn't actually shift
it to the right it's cumulative so it's
the total of the different occurrences
and so what that means is like if you
consider this like for the year of
rainfall we have like day one you had a
little bit of rain day two we have more
rain and so if you look at the number
this is a hundred thousand thirty five
thousand so it's a cumulative detail the
histogram of the currents as it grows
and rainfall is a good one because that
would be a cumulative histogram of how
much rain occurred throughout the year
and we're going to look at two more
graphs we've already looked at a bunch
of them we looked at our radar graph
we've looked at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data you know we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps let's put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map
we need to go ahead and create data for
it and if you have contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your map
plot library your numpy so we have our
numbers array
we'll import matplot.cm
and that's your color maps so you have
all these different color maps you can
look at there's like hundreds of color
maps so if you don't want to do your own
color you can even do your own color map
they're pretty diverse and of course our
plt we're going to our pi plot and to
generate our different data we're going
to create a delta
0.025 and we'll start with x when we're
going to create an array between minus 3
and 3 and delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our xy
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential on here minus x squared
minus y squared for z1 we'll do a z2 so
we have two different areas and z equals
z of 1 minus z2 times 2.
so we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our x from our plt subplots we're
going to create the variable cs and this
is going to be our contour so right here
cs is our contour surface and we're
feeding it x y and z if you remember x y
we created as our x and y components
using our mesh grid and you know what
let's do this just because it's kind of
good to see this let's go ahead and
print
x
and let's print
y and i always like to do this when i'm
working with something that's either is
really complicated in this case is what
we're looking at or you don't understand
yet so we've created a mesh grid we have
x y and when we're done with this we end
up with here's our x
and this set of values and our y so
there's our x and y coordinates and then
we've also created z based on our x and
y so we have x capital x capital y and
capital z is our three components x and
y be in the coordinates while z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our x y and z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do one title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a
contour there we go contour map and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
that looks like and you'll see we
generated a nice little contour map
there's different settings you can play
with on this but you can picture this
being you're on a mountain climb and
here we have a line that's represent
zero maybe at sea level and then moving
on up you have your contours of 0.5 and
then -1 and different setups little
hills i guess if it's minus that's like
a pit so i guess you're going down into
a pit at -5 and -1 when on the other
side you can see you're going up in
levels so here's a mountaintop and
here's like a basin of some kind and in
data science this could represent a lot
of things this could also be
representing two different values and
maybe profits and loss i don't know if
i'd ever really do that as a contour map
but i'm sure you can be creative and
find something fun to do with a contour
map and then we're going to look at one
last map which is the 3d map and those
are can be really important as a final
product because they can show so much
additional information that you can't
fit on two-dimensional graphs
there we go draw a 3d image
and so we're going to import from our
mpl toolkits the implant 3d and the axis
3d we're going to import axis 3d this is
what's going to let us work with the 3d
image and this should look familiar
we're going to create another figure
just like we did before figure size 14x6
that's a good fit on the screen we'll go
ahead and run that
so we have our figure and let's go ahead
and take our x and we're going to set
that equal to fig dot add subplot that
should also be familiar from earlier and
we're going to work with this sets the
settings for the projection we're going
to use one two one projection 3d and
we'll see what that looks like in just a
minute and we just created some
three-dimensional data here before
where we had x y and z capital x y and z
so we're going to reuse that data we're
just going to use that since it's also
this is also a three-dimensional image
so let's use that for a
three-dimensional graph and we simply do
ax plot underscore
surface
and our capital x
capital y capital z so there's our data
coming in and we're going to add some
settings in here we're going to do r
stride four c stride four and line with
zero i'll show you what that is here in
just a minute let's go ahead and run
that so we can see our graph
and of course it helps if i don't add an
extra comma in there and you can see it
generates this really beautiful
three-dimensional graph
so let's take a little bit time to
explore some of these numbers we have
going in here
we have the r stride 4 the c stride 4
and the projection 3d projection 3d is
the important one because that's telling
us that this is a 3d graph here
so what are these first numbers 1 2 1
let's just change one of these i'm going
to change this to 5
and it's going to give me an error let's
change it to one
and that didn't work let's change this
middle one to three instead
and you're gonna see how it starts
reshaping the size and how it fits on
the screen
and we'll change the first one to two
we'll run that one
and again it's changed the dimensions
and the size and how it fits on here
play with these numbers to get a nice
look and feel for it part of it is the
tilt and the angle
i'll do seven on this one
there we go you can see it really
shifted it there
but again that changes the size now fits
on the canvas
but we'll leave it at the one
two
and just so you get a good look at what
we're talking about here this is column
width and index from before
if we do one one one you can see that it
now spreads it out all the way across
uses the whole set up on there so this
has to do with the size and how big you
want it to be now there's one term that
we didn't cover in this yet but we've
used it throughout the whole setup
and i'm just going to type that down
here even though we're not going to go
into detail and that's the term heat
map you might see that it's kind of
starting to lose ground as far as a
common reference but there sure are a
lot of people who still talk about heat
maps what is a heat map well it is
simply a color map that's all it is so
if you ever see the term heat map
that refers to the fact this is in
different colors representing different
heights
that one is in the heat map but you can
see up here we switched into
let me go back up here here we go this
one has different colors for the
different values
a lot of times you'll use like instead
of x and y you might do a heat map
where you have a fourth value and the
fourth value represents the color and so
you'll see this 3d image in the nice
colors represented by heat map that's
all it is so if you see the term heat
map that only means we're plotting some
of the data in color to make it stand
out or to give it a fourth dimension in
this case
so we've covered a lot of things on
matplot and that brings us cover all the
basics so that brings us to practice
example and this is going to be the
challenge for you and let me go ahead
and change our cell
cell type mark down and run that so it
looks pretty
practice example write a path python
program to create a pie chart of the
popularity of programming languages
okay excellent
and if you're going to have a challenge
we need some data and i'll just throw in
our import our map library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're going to have our languages
we're going to have python we're going
to have java php javascript c-sharp c
plus so those are six categories and
then we have our popularity oops
misspelling there popularity we'll give
the first one 22.2 percent java 17.6 and
i don't know if these are real numbers
they pulled my guess is that they might
have just been made up because i don't
know if python's really that much more
popular than the other ones maybe
specific to data science because python
is very popular in data science right
now because it has so many options the
only other program that's highly used
and exclusively for data science is r so
python's big and python also does a lot
more it's a full programming language
where r is primarily for data science
they didn't put r in here so we have
python we have java we have our php and
you can see the different values they've
given it or different percentages
and i did add these up does not add up
to 100 it adds up to 71 percent or
something like that
and then we're going to give colors and
we've chosen these guys in the back
brought in these colors i'm not sure
what these colors are we'll find out in
a minute so i'll be exciting but you can
see they're using the actual color
values you can pull off of a color wheel
or something like that you could have
just as easily done blue red green if
you're too lazy to pick the exact colors
and then let's go ahead and solve this
and see we got here we're going to do
something a little fancy just because we
can
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use a variable called
explode and you'll notice that there's
six variables in here so that matches
our six different categories and the
first one we've done is point one and
then zero zero zero zero zero point one
when we put this in here under the
explode in the plot it will actually
push that square out so it's a really
cool feature to highlight certain
information on a pie chart
and this is simply
plt dot pi and we're plotting
popularity there we go and before we add
in all the really cool settings for this
let's go ahead and run it and you'll see
we generate a nice flat pie not too
exciting there and then we'll go ahead
and put in all the extras i talked about
explode we can explode one of the values
out so here's our explode equals explode
labels as languages because we want to
know what the different colors mean
here's our colors equals colors our auto
picture and this is standard print
format so that's a python setup on there
and that's just going to put the value
on the pie slice and then we're going to
add shadow because it just looks cooler
with a shadow gives a little 3d look and
we'll do a start angle of 140. let's go
ahead and run this and take a look and
see what comes out of that
and look how that changes the whole
setup so here's our labels there's our
value we put on there there's our slices
pushed out there's our shadow a 3d
effect
and then we started at 140. we could
also rotate this let's just do this
angle
90
and if we run it
you'll see the blue pi slice has moved
up a little bit we could actually do
actually let's just take the whole
starting triangle out and run he'll
default to zero
this is what it looks like if it
defaulted to zero so depending on where
you want the highlighted slice to appear
usually you want that appear on the left
because people read left to right and so
it draws a focus onto in this case
python and how great python is i'm a
little biased we're teaching a python
tutorial so it should be understandable
that we're looking at python and one
last reference before we close you can
go over to the matplot library dot pi
plot set up and if you go underneath
there the different functions on there
you can look this up on their website
you'll see a full list and this is why
it's so important to go through a
tutorial like this because this list is
just so massive trying to figure out
like here's our bar plot there's a bar h
you can add barbs there's a box plot we
didn't cover
c labels a totally different kind of for
your contour plot you can set up in
there if you go down here we have our
figures we used on there we showed you
the basics how to do the figure you'll
see some
closer references on those
there's a histogram down here hist
there's also the his 2d makes a 2d
histogram plot h lines all of this these
are all the different commands that are
underneath of here and you can see it's
pretty extensive we've covered all the
basic ones so that you know have a solid
ground to look at these different
options so when you come to these
functions some of them are going to look
a little off or not off will look
unfamiliar but you'll still have the
availability to probably understand most
of this and have a basic understanding
of your matplot library we will learn
how to visualize data and draw insights
with different charts and graphs using
the c bond library
these visualizations are often referred
to as plots in python
so what is c bond in python the c bond
library in python is a widely popular
data visualization library that is
commonly used for data science and
machine learning tasks
it is built on top of the matplotlib
data visualization library
and allows you to perform exploratory
data analysis
using cbon you can create interactive
plots to answer specific questions about
your data it helps you find trends in
your data that you can't notice just by
looking at the data
now to understand the c-bond library in
detail and how to create different plots
and know the data better we'll be using
two data sets in our demo
the first one is the empty cache data
set and the second is the popular iris
flower data set
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and start with our
demonstration
so i am on my jupyter notebook let me go
ahead and
rename the notebook i'll say
cbon
demo
will rename it
all right
you can see i have
the first two cells already filled in
so while working on an exploratory data
analysis project using python you will
need numpy pandas matplotlib and cbon
libraries for data manipulation and
visualization
so let's import these libraries first so
i've already written import numpy as np
pandas pd matplotlib.pi plot as plt c
bond sns
all right so i'll hit shift enter to run
this
first cell
all right
now using the read underscore csv
function that is present in the
pandas library i am importing my data
set that is empty cars i'll tell you
what empty cars is about this is a csv
data set and here i have given the
location where my data set is present
let's run it
all right
now
let me go ahead and print the first
five rows
of my empty cars
data frame
for that i am using the head function
if i run it
okay you can see here
it has given me the first five rows the
index starts from zero till four so
total five rows of information
and
you can see these are the columns that
are present in the empty cast data set
the first is the
model of the car
now just let me give you a background
about this data set
so the data is taken from the 1974
motor trend us magazine
it has information about fuel
consumption and 11 different aspects of
automobile design and performance of 32
cars
all right
so here we have the first column as the
model of the car and then we have mpg
which is
miles per
gallon then we have
cyl which stands for the number of
cylinders in the vehicle or the car
then we have disp which is displacement
in
cubic inches so these all values are in
cubic inches
after that we have hp which is cross
horsepower
then we have something called as
dr80 which is basically the rear axle
ratio
then we have wt which is the
weight of the
car in pounds
so think of it as
weight multiplied by
thousand pounds
all right and then we have q sec which
is
1 4 mile time this is a measure for
acceleration
then we have something called as vs this
is
the type of
engine for each of the vehicles so 0
stands for
v-shaped engine and one stands for
straight engine
then we have am which is basically
the mode of transmission so
zero is for automatic transmission and
one is for manual transmission
then we have the number of
forward gears present in the vehicle and
then we have something called as carb or
carb
this stands for the number of
carburetors so carburetors is a device
for supplying a spark ignition engine
with a mixture of fuel and air
alright
now
we'll use the info function to print the
summary of the data frame so the info
function returns information regarding
the index
data type column data types then we
have the information about normal values
and memory usage
so i'll write my data frame name which
is empty cars
dot i'm going to use the info function
let's run it
and here you can see we have
all the columns
there are total 32
entries from 0 to 31 so
data about 32 cars
then here you can see the date types
and the memory usage
now moving ahead
let me
just print the
shape of the data frame that will give
you the number of rows and columns
present
i'll use the shape attribute
you can see here there are total
32 rows and 12 columns in my data set
now the c bond library provides a range
of plotting functions that makes the
visualization and analysis of data
easier
so we will cover some of the crucial
plots that are available in cbon
so let's start with a bar plot
i'll give a
comment as
bar plot
now
first understand
what a bar plot is so a bar plot gives
an estimate of the central tendency of a
numeric variable
with the height of each rectangle it
provides some indication of the
uncertainty around the estimate using
error bars
now to build this plot you usually
choose a categorical column in the
x-axis and a numeric column on the
y-axis
so we'll create a bar plot between the
number of cylinders and the miles per
gallon
so let's start
i'll
declare a variable called res which
essentially stands for result
then i'll use sns
which is for the cbon library
i'll say sns dot
followed by my bar plot function
and inside the function
i'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
and then
for x axis within the bracket using
quotation i'll give my column name
as cylinder so this is going to be my
x-axis
and for y-axis i'll say
my data frame name empty cars
then the square bracket followed by my
y-axis column that is miles per gallon
now to display i'm going to use the
matplotlib function i'll say plt dot
show
let's run it and we'll see the result
there you go
so here you can see on the
x-axis we have the number of cylinders
so in our data we have vehicles with 4 6
or 8 cylinders
and on the y axis you can see the miles
per gallon
now what essentially this graph tells us
is that
when the number of cylinders in the
vehicle increases my miles per gallon on
mpg for the vehicles decreases
and you can see these
black lines
so these lines
indicate
the uncertainty around
the estimate using error bars
all right
now you can create the
same bar plot using another way
now we will exclusively define the x and
y axis columns and also pass the name of
the data frame using the
data argument
let me show you how to do it
i'll use the same variable name res
which stands for result i'll say sns dot
bar plot
now inside the
bar plot function
i'm going to exclusively define my x
axis i'll say x equal to
i'll pass in my column as
cylinder
then i'll say
y-axis
which is miles per gallon
and then using the data attribute
i'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars
and finally we'll write plt dot show
let me run it
you see here we have the exact
same bar plot as the above one so this
is another way to create a bar plot now
python c bond allows the users to assign
colors to the bars
so the bar chart that we are going to
create will convert all the bars to a
particular color
so for that i am going to use the color
argument
so i'll say res
equal to
sns dot my function that is bar plot
i'll say x
equal to
cylinder
my y axis
will have
mpg
and then i'll say data
is empty cars
give a comma and my final attribute i'll
say
color
equal to i'll say yellow
close the bracket
and then
i'm going to write plt dot show
if i run it you can see here
all the bars have been converted to
yellow color now
you can change the
color
argument let's see i'll make it to red
if i print it you can see here all the
bars have been changed to red color now
all right
now c bond library also has the
palette argument
which you can use to give different
colors to the bars
so if you go to
google and search for
seaborn palette
you have a nice link here
so here you have there are different
palettes provided by
seaborn you can see here
sns.color palette
and these are the
names of the palette
you can use whichever palette you want
all right
so
i'll say res
equal to
sns dot
bar plot
we'll use our
first method of
assigning
a bar plot so i'm using my data frame
empty cars this time we are going to
change the x and
y labels let's say i'm using
my x label as
transmission whether
automatic or manual transmission
and then in my y-axis i'll have
miles per gallon
then
i'm going to say
palette
equal to
i made a spelling mistake here
let's say our palette is
set to this is the name of the palette
i'll write plt dot show
if i run it you can see here
we have the
two modes of transmission zero is for
automatic transmission of the vehicle
one is for manual transmission
and you can see the miles per gallon for
each of the modes of transmission if you
want you can change the pallet colors
let me just copy this
i'll paste it in my new cell
and instead of set to let's say we'll
use
another palette
called as rocket
and i'm also going to alter
my x and y labels let's see in my x
label i'll have gear
and my y label will be horse bar
if i run it
you see here we now have a different
palette and the bars are of different
colors
on the x axis you have the gears
three gear four gear or five gear
vehicle
and on the
y axis you have the horse bar
so from the graph you can see
the horsepower is low for vehicles that
have four gears
while it is high
for the vehicles that have five gears
now let's understand how to create a
count plot
so the count plot function in the python
c bond library returns the count of
total values for each category using
bars we will create a count plot that
returns the total number of vehicles for
each category of cylinders
i'll just give a comment here as
count plot
all right
so i'll start
sns dot
i'll use the count plot function
and i'll define my x axis as
cylinders
my y axis
won't have any label or any column
because y axis will only show the
count
then i'm going to
use my
data parameter or the argument and pass
in my data frame name that is empty cars
let's say i'll set the
palette
to
set one
let me run it
okay there is some error let's debug the
error
says str
object has no attribute get
okay so this should be
without the single quotes make sure the
data frame name is without the
single quotes let's run it again
there you go
so you can see here this is a nice count
plot that
shows the number of cylinders on the
x-axis and on the y-axis you have the
count you can see here
there are more number of vehicles that
have eight cylinders and there are
less number of vehicles or cars that
have six cylinders and actually you can
count it as well so you can see here
there are 14 cars that have eight
cylinders there are
11 cars that have four cylinders and
there are seven cars that have
six cylinders
all right
now moving ahead
the next count plot will show the number
of cars for each carburetor
so for that i'm going to say
sns dot
count plot
my x-axis will now have
the variable
carburetor
i'll see data equal to empty cars
and my palette
i'll set it to
set one
let's say set two now let me run it
you can see it here
on the x-axis we have the different
number of carburetors one two three four
six and eight
and you can see we have
more number of cars that have two and
four carburetors
and there are very few vehicles that
have
six and eight carburetor
cool now moving ahead
so the python c-bond library allows you
to create horizontal count plots where
the feature column is on the y-axis and
the count is on the x-axis let me show
you how to create a horizontal count
plot
i'll say sns dot
count plot
i am going to define my
y label or the y axis as
gear
i'll say data equal to
empty cars
and set my
palette to
let's say rocket
let me run it
okay you see here this is a
horizontal count plot if you compare it
with the above one these were all
vertical
count plot as in the bars were
vertically aligned but here you can see
the bars are all horizontally aligned
and
on the y-axis you have the gear column
and on the x-axis you have the count
so if you mark here properly you can see
there are 15 vehicles with three gears
there are
12 vehicles that have four gears and
there are total five vehicles with five
gear
now you can also create a grouped count
plot using the hue parameter
so the hue parameter accepts the column
name for
color encoding
now let's
build
a count plot that shows the number of
cars for each category of gears grouped
by
the number of cylinders
so we are going to group based on the
number of cylinders let me show you how
to use the hue parameter for that
i'll say
sns.count plot
in the x axis i'll have my
gear column
then i am going to pass my hue parameter
that will have the
cylinder column or the number of
cylinders for each vehicle
i will pass my data frame
using the data
argument
as empty cars
and say pallet
i'll set my pallet to set one
let's run it
if i scroll down you see here we have a
count plot
on the x axis you have three four and
five gears of the different vehicles
and
for each gear you have the
bars
that represent the number of cylinders
so for
vehicles that have three gears we have
majority of the vehicles having eight
cylinders
similarly for
vehicles that have four gears we have
most of the vehicles with four cylinders
and if you compare for the
cars that have five
gears
so we have equal number of vehicles that
have
four and eight cylinders and then
we have
one vehicle that has
six cylinders
cool
now moving ahead
so the c bond library supports the
dist plot function that creates the
distribution of any continuous data
let's create the distribution of miles
per gallon of the different vehicles or
the cars
the mpg matrix measures the total
distance the car can travel per gallon
of fuel so here i'll give
a comment as dist plot which stands for
distribution plot
i'll say sns dot
dist plot
i'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
give a period and say
mpg which is my column name
then i am going to
define the number of bins that i want
let's say 10
and then i'll use the
color argument
and i'll say let's say g which is for
green
let's run it now
there you go
if i scroll down you can see we have a
nice
distribution plot
so these are all histograms and
you can see we have a smooth curve
and this shows the distribution of
miles per gallon that is present in our
data set all right
now moving ahead
you can also create heat maps using the
c bond library
so the heat maps will
let you visualize matrix like data
the values of the variables are
contained in a matrix and are
represented as colors
you can create a correlation heat map
which is a graphical representation of a
correlation matrix representing the
correlation between different variables
so in our example we will create a heat
map where you can find the correlation
between each variable in the empty cars
data set
just give a comment as heat map
i'll say sns
and
i'll use the heat map function
i'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars followed by
my function called corr which is for
correlation
then i'll say c bar
is equal to true
so the
c bar argument is used to draw the color
bar
then i'll say
line bits
i'll
pass it as 0.5
let's run it
there you go
here you can see we have a nice heat map
and on the right side you can see the
color bar that starts from
minus point eight and goes up to plus
point eight so this ranges between
minus 1 and plus 1
and
the bars or the
cube you can see that have
a lighter color
have a positive correlation
and the ones that are
dark have a negative correlation
so for example
you can see here
for cylinder and mpg
the color is really dark which is around
this region minus 0.8 this means
when the number of cylinders in the car
increases your miles per gallon
decreases
and this
we also
had seen in our first
bar plot this one
you can see here whenever
the number of
cylinders increased your miles per
gallon had decreased
and this is what
has been depicted
in our correlation map or the heat map
but if you see for
cylinder and displacement there is a
positive correlation
which comes around this
color bar range
similarly there are other features in
the data set for example if you compare
for the weight of the vehicle
and the number of cylinders
there is a positive correlation which
means when the
weight of the vehicle increases the
number of cylinders present in the
vehicle also increases
and the others you can also compare and
find out the correlation based on this
color bar choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 plus
hours of video content for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
okay now let's move ahead
the c bond scatter plot function helps
you create plots that can draw
relationships between two continuous
variables
so to understand about scatter plots and
other plotting functions henceforth we
are going to use
iris flat data set so let's go ahead and
load the iris flat data set i'll say
irish
equal to
sns dot
load underscore
data set
so this iris floor data set is already
inbuilt into the sns or the c bond
library
now we'll go ahead and
print the first five rows
from the data set
there you go
here you can see here
there are total
four feature variables you have the
sample length
supple width better length and petal
width of the
three species of flower
that is satosa
virginica and versicolor
so using this data set we are going to
see the rest of the c bond plotting
functions first let me go ahead and
print the different species of flower
and the
count for each of the species of flowers
that we have in our data set
i'll say irish
within square brackets i'll pass in the
output or the target variable that is
species and i'll use the function that
is
value underscore counts
let's run it
there you go so we have
50 flowers of satosa type
again 50 flowers of versicolor species
and then
we have another 50 flowers of type
virginica
so there are total 150 flowers present
in our data set
all right
i will create a scatter plot to show the
relationship between sepal length and
petal length for different species of
iris flaws
so i'll say sns
dot
followed by the
scatter plot function in the x axis i'll
say
sample length
column
give a comma
i'll pass in my
y-axis with
petal length
then i'll say
data
equal to
iris
now let's run it
you can see here
this is my
scatter plot between
sepal length and petal length
now
you can classify the different species
of flowers using the hue parameter as
species in the function so what i'll do
is
i'm going to copy my
above
code i'll just paste it here
and we are going to edit in this cell
itself
i'll add a last parameter called hue
and this will have my species column
let's run it and see the difference
there you go
here you can see
we have a nice scatter plot
the blue dots are for satosa
the orange dots are for
forci color and for virginica you have
the green dots
from this scatter plot you can see that
for virginica flowers the supple length
and the petal length are higher than
your versicolorant
satosa
and this region is completely
for satoshi flash
so you can see that the satosha flowers
have
lower supple length and petal length
all right
you can also
use another
parameter known as the size
that will
differentiate
the different pieces of flower in terms
of the size of the dots
i'll say size as species
let's run it you can see the result
there you go
so here you can see the
virginica
flowers are in green dots
the size is small
followed by versicolor with medium sized
dots and then
we have satosa
whose size
is large
okay
now the python c-bond library lets you
visualize data using pair plots that
produces a matrix of relationship
between each variable in the data set
so let me show you how to create a pair
plot i'll say sns dot
peer plot which is the function
then i'll pass in my data frame name
that is iris
i'll put this
iris data frame within
double quotes
and we'll run it
okay there is some error here let's
debug the error
data must be panned as data frame okay
what i'll do is i'll just remove
the double quotes and we'll run it
this might take some time to create the
pair plot so
just wait for a while
there you go
here you can see we have a nice pair
plot
on the
y-axis you have the
supple length supple width petal length
and petal width similarly on the x-axis
also you have the
same
feature columns
all the diagonal plots are histograms
and the rest of the plots are
scatter plots
now you can convert the diagonal visuals
to
kde or kernel density estimation plots
and the rest of the scatter plots using
the hue parameter this makes the pair
plot easier to classify each type of
flower
so
i'll just copy this
cell of code
paste it here
and
i'll say hue
equal to
species then
i'll say
palette
equal to set one
let's run it and we'll
see the new pair plot now
this might take some time
there you go so here you have the
pair plot ready
and on the
right side you can see the different
species the red color dots represent
satosa flash
the blue color dots represent versicolor
and
the
green color
dots represent virginia flowers
now if
you look at this graph
you will find that
your petal length is the best feature to
classify the three different species of
flowers
the reason being you can see here
they are very well
categorized and they are separated
all the red dots present here in the
petal length represents satosa flowers
around this range
all the
blue dots represent
versicolor flowers and the green dots
are all
virginica flowers so out of the four
features petal width petal length sepal
width and
supple length
you can take
petal length as the best feature to
differentiate between the three species
of flowers
all right
now
coming to
lm plot function
so the
lm plot function in the
c bond library draws a linear
relationship as determined through
regression for continuous variables
so let's create the plot to show the
relationship between petal length and
petal width of the different species of
iris flowers
i'll just give a comment here as
lm plot
i'll say sns dot
l m plot
in the x axis we'll have
petal length
give a comma
in the y axis
i'll pass in
petal width
and i'll pass in my data frame using the
data argument or parameter which is iris
let's run it
you can see it here
we have a nice
plot
the line you see here
is a linear regression line
now in this lm plot you can use the hue
parameter to differentiate between each
species of flowers and you can set
markers
for different
species let me show you how to do it
i'll say
sns.lm plot
will say x
as our
petal length
give a comma
i'll write y
as
petal
width
then i'm going to pass the hue parameter
in here i'll
say
my column as pcs
then i'll give data equal to
my data set name that is iris
and now you can pass in
markers argument
to differentiate the different
types of flaws
let's say i want to represent setosa
with
dot or o
then my next species which is
versicolor should be represented with a
star symbol
and the final
virginica species of flowers should be
represented with let's say
this arrow mark
now let me go ahead and run it
there you go
you have three different
linear regression lines
and
the circle dots in blue color represent
satosha
the orange color stars represent
versicolor flowers and
the triangles represent virginica
flowers so this is how you create
a linear relationship between the
different
types of flaws using the regression line
all right
now let's
take a look at the final plotting
function
where we will create a box plot
a box plot also known as a box and
whisker plot depicts the distribution of
quantitative data
the box represents the quartiles of the
data set the whiskers so the rest of the
distribution except for the outliers
now let's see the distribution of the
three species of flowers
based on their sepal width
i just give a comment as box plot
is the final plot that we are going to
see in our cbon
demo
i'll say
sns.box plot
in the x axis we'll have the species
column
in the y axis we'll have
supple
width
then i'll pass my
data
as iris
let's run it
there you go
we have this
box plot created
at the bottom in the x axis you can see
we have
the box plot for
satosa flowers
orange for
versatile flowers and green for
virginica flowers
now this line represents
median which is inside the box
so this is also the median for
versicolor flash you can compare the
median
sample width for each of the flowers
from the y axis
this line represents the
maximum
supple width value for satosa flower
and this line at the bottom represents
the minimum
length of the supple bit for satosa plus
now these dots that you see outside the
box plot are called as outliers
the extended lines that are outside the
box plot are known as whiskers
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on
cbon
library in python so first we
imported our empty cars data set then we
saw how to create a bar plot
we learnt how to use the color argument
or the parameter inside
bar plot
we also
saw how to use the palette attribute or
the palette
parameter
then we learnt about
creating count plots
then we saw how to create horizontal
count plot
now moving ahead
we saw how to create
distribution plot
then we saw
correlation heat map
after that
we analyzed the other functions
such as the scatter plot
then we had the pair plot
and we had the
lm plot for
finding the linear relationship and
later we saw the
box plot using the iris flower dataset
so first we will explain what exactly
the meaning of bokeh is
then we will take a look at scatter
charts and see how we can implement them
in bokeh
next we will understand what line charts
are the scenarios in which they are used
and how they can be coded in python
bokeh
then we'll move on to pie charts and
understand how data distribution can be
represented using them
next we will take a look at histograms
then we'll move on to bar plot and
understand the difference between
histograms and bar plots
we'll then take a look at area plot and
how to understand them
and then we will move on to the layout
function in bokeh which is used to make
interactive web pages
and finally we will use a data set to
understand how we can make interactive
charts in bokeh by using everything that
we've already learned in this video
so the first question that probably
comes to your mind is what exactly
is bokeh
bokeh is a python library which is used
to make highly interactive graphs and
visualizations
this is done in bokeh using html and
javascript
this makes bokeh a powerful tool for
creating projects custom charts and web
design based applications
now bokeh is a python library for
creating interactive visualizations for
modern web browsers
it helps you build beautiful graphics
ranging from simple plots to complex
dashboards with streaming data sets
with bokeh you can create javascript
power visualizations without writing any
javascript yourself
this makes it a very powerful tool for
data visualization
next let's take a look at scatter charts
and how you can plot them in bokeh
now scatter plots are a plot of each
individual data point in the data
two variables are plotted against one
another and each data point on the
x-axis has a corresponding individually
plotted value on the y-axis
as a result the plot looks like a bunch
of scattered points
these are some examples of scatter
charts
here each point on the chart
corresponds to a value on the x-axis and
its respective value on the y-axis
using scatter plots we can see how two
different variables correspond to each
other
now let's see how we can plot scatter
charts using bokeh
so the first thing that we're going to
be doing is importing all of the
necessary modules for our python project
the first module that we're going to
need is the pandas module which is used
to work on data frames
next we will also be importing the
pandas bokeh module which is used to
implement bokeh on pandas data frames
next we will import bokeh.io which we
will use to show the various graphs that
we are plotting
we will also import bokeh dot plotting
which will help us in plotting all of
the various graphs that we are going to
be looking at
we will also import glob a module which
will help us
merge our files and get them in the
required format
so the first line of code that we're
going to be writing is pandas underscore
bokeh dot output underscore notebook
this is basically just a line of code
which will help you see your output in
the same notebook itself
now let's see how we can plot scatter
plots in bokeh
we already have imported the figure
function from bokeh.plotting
the figure function contains most of the
plots that we want to plot such as line
plots scatter plots bar charts etc so
this is what we're going to be using
the first thing that you're going to
need to do is create a figure
so how do we do that
let's create a random variable p and
this we're going to be initializing to
the figure function
now within this figure function we're
just going to add a couple of
parameters for our figure itself so
let's say we want the plot width
to be equal to 400
and the plot
height to be equal to 402 we're gonna be
plotting a scatter plot in the form of a
square here next we know that a scatter
plot is nothing but various circles
which are plotted on top of our graph
so that's what we're going to do we're
going to be plotting
circles
at certain coordinates
which are going to be given by our lists
so the first coordinate is going to be
the x-axis and the next list that you're
passing in is going to represent the
y-axis coordinates so over here let's
just plot
this as 1 comma 2
3
four and five
and over here let's start with four
seven
these are just random points this is
just to show you how exactly you can
plot a graph in bokeh
and now let's just say that we want the
size of the circles to be equal to 10
and the color of every circle
to be navy
we're also going to give a random
parameter called alpha and equate that
to 0.5 this will just act as a
placeholder
now over here you've initialized your
figure function and given in certain
parameters
and using this figure function you're
calling the circle attribute of it
passing in other parameters such as the
x axis coordinates and the y axis
coordinates the size of the circle the
color of each circle and a random
parameter called alpha so now we've
imported all of our modules and this is
how you plot a scatter chart in bokeh
the same thing can be done when you look
at the line plot
all you have to do is initialize your
figure function
and call the line attribute of it pass
in your x-axis coordinates in your
y-axis coordinates
maybe pass in a couple of other
parameters that are required such as the
width that you want the line to be and
the color that you want the line to be
and finally all you have to do is show
the plot
this is a basic overview of how you can
use bokeh to plot graphs
and here we have a line plot
so the main difference between the
scatter plot here and the line plot here
is that the line plot has various
different
points which are connected to each other
with the help of a line
so again what exactly are line charts
a line chart is a chart that represents
data as a series of points which are
connected to each other with the help of
a line it is used to see trends in our
data and drag the way data changes over
a period of time
so this is the same chart that we just
plotted using bokeh right now so as you
can see
so the parameters that you know were
passed in were 1 2 3 4 and 5 on the x
axis
and 3 1 2
6 and 5 on the y axis so how exactly the
line chart is plotted is that you plot
each of these points and then you
connect them or join them using a line
next let's take a look at pie charts and
how they can be implemented in bokeh
but first what exactly is a pie chart
a pie chart is a circular chart which is
divided into slices to represent how
much of the data belongs to a certain
category
it is a quick and easy way to see the
categories in our data and the
percentage of the data set that they
represent
on the other hand you have another type
of chart called a donut chart
donut charts are like pie charts with a
hole in the center and in this hole you
can use it to represent extra data
or you can draw a pie chart within that
hole itself
so this is an example of a pie chart
using this you can easily get to know
the various categories that our data is
divided into and the percentage that
each of these categories contribute
towards our data
like over here we have a pie chart which
represents crewmates and imposters in a
game called among us
so using this we can just say that
around 75 percent
of our
data is crewmates and 25 percent of it
is imposters
on the other hand you have a donut chart
which is almost exactly the same as the
pie chart except the middle portion is
missing values
and in this middle portion you can do
other things such as plot a pie chart
or represent other data within it
so now let's see how we can plot our pi
plots using python bokeh
but first we need to import the data
that we're gonna be using to plot all of
this
so the data that we're gonna be looking
at is the among us data
among us as you might know is a game
that caused quite a frenzy in the past
two years so the data that we're gonna
be working at is the among us data set
that you can find on kaggle
among us was the new craze for people
playing mobile games that suddenly
exploded in popularity and became a hit
video game during the pandemic
now among us is basically a multiplayer
game where 4 to 10 players are dropped
in an alien spaceship
each player has their own role of
imposter or crewmate
the task of the crewmate is to run
around the spaceship to complete various
tasks which are assigned to them and
also to not get killed by an imposter
players can be voted off the ship so
each game becomes one of survival
so let's load this data set and create
more features
so now we've imported our data set as
you can see our data set has over 2000
rows and 14 columns
the first column that i want to show you
is the user id column
the user id column tells us which user
the game data was collected from
now there are 14 columns the game
completed data tells us the date and
time of
game completion
the team tells us if the player is an
imposter or a crew mate
the outcome
tells us if the game was won or lost
so over here this is each game that a
certain user has played user id is used
to represent the user who has played the
game and as you can see we've collected
data from 29 different people
and the number of games that these 29
people totally have played is over 2
000.
the outcome tells us whether the
user has won or lost in this game the
task completed tells us how many tasks
was completed by this user in this game
all tasks completed tells us when the
user was able to finish their tasks
murder tells us if the user was murdered
and imposter kills
tells us the number of kills by the
imposter
so if the user was not an impostor we do
not have data on how many kills was
committed by the impostor during that
particular game that's why this column
has a lot of missing values
gamelan tells us
the total duration of the game and
ejected tells us if the player was
ejected or thrown off of the spaceship
by their fellow players
sabotage is fixed is basically
the imposter within the game can create
sabotages and it's the crewmates duty to
fix them
so this tells us the number of sabotages
which was fixed by this particular
crewmate
time to complete all tasks tells us the
duration taken by the chromates to
complete all the tasks and the rank
change tells us the change in rank after
wins or losses of the game
the region
or the game code tells us the server and
the game code
now first let's just see how exactly the
data is distributed
so this tells us how many
counts each column has
so as you can see here most of them have
the same number of counts except rank
change which has a couple of missing
values
unique tells us how many unique values
exist in each column
so obviously team there will be two
because there are only two possible
outcomes you can either be a crewmate or
you can either be an imposter outcome
also has only two unique values because
you either win a game or you lose a game
task completed has 12 different values
and this is because the
number of tasks which have been
completed probably range from 1 to 12.
all task completed has 3 values which is
yes no and missing data and the same
goes for murdered you have yes no or
missing data
impostor kills tells us how many kills
the imposter has made
so
in this case
uh the most skills that the person has
made is probably nine
game length there are 988 different
values and eject it again there are only
two values because you can either be
ejected or you can either stay in the
game
now the top value tells us the most
frequently occurring value and the
frequency tells us the frequencies of
all of the top values
now let's create a feature called minute
and extract data from game length
so we're going to be splitting the game
length column which is this column and
we're going to be converting it into
minutes
and then we're going to be
using that data and creating a separate
feature column called minutes
out of it
so let's do this
so these are the first top two values of
our minutes call of our new minutes
column
uh the zeroth value is seven because the
first
game length that you see here was of
seven minutes so all that we're doing is
that we're going to be splitting this
value which is seven minutes four
seconds and we're gonna be keeping only
the first value which is out of the
minutes
the second minutes value is 16 minutes
and that corresponds to the second value
in our minutes feature
variable
now let's take a look at the murdered
column the murdered column has yes no
yes no values and missing data set and
missing values
so let's change those we're going to be
replacing no values with not murdered
yes values with murdered
and the simple dash with missing
and we're going to be doing this in
place which basically means that this is
going to make a change to our main data
frame
so this is done let's take a look at a
data frame now
this is what our data frame looks like
we have a game's length column we have a
minutes column
and we also have made changes to our
murdered column which is represented
here so now we don't have any missing
values or dashes in our murdered column
we have all of it represented as
categorical data
and this is one of the main columns that
we're going to be using to plot our pie
plots
so now let's see how we can plot a pie
chart
the first thing that we're going to be
doing is that we're going to be
getting the total value counts
in our team column here
so we're gonna be plotting a pie chart
with the help of this team column and
we're gonna be getting the value counts
of each unique
value in the team column
so let's
you can do this with the help of the
value counts function that pandas data
frames provides us with
announce that we have the value counts
of each unique value which is present in
our team column let's plot it in the
form of a pie chart
we're going to be doing this with the
help of the plot bokeh function
and the type of chart that we want to
plot is a pie chart
let's give it the title
as
ratio of
imposters
versus
chromates
and let's run this now
and this is what your pie plot looks
like after you've plotted it
so now the same thing can be done to
plot a donut plot
the first thing that we want to see is
if there are more crewmates or imposters
murdered or not in the game
to do this we will add two more features
angle and color which are
gonna be used in the chart
so to
get angle we're gonna be importing pi
from math
and we're gonna be converting our
angle in the form of radians
and as for the color feature we're gonna
be having three different shades of blue
so this is basically what our
murder data frame looks like
uh so over here you have not murdered
the total value counts of which
is 894 and the angle that this gives us
is two point five two two three zero and
this is the corresponding color the same
goes for murdered which is 867 values
and we've converted that into an angle
in radians and given it its own color
and finally we also have missing values
of which there are 466 the angle is
1.314756 and it has its own
corresponding color
so this is the data frame that we're
going to be using to plot our doughnut
chart
so from bouquet or transform we import
cumulative sum
and the cumulative sum is what we're
going to be using to find the start of
our angle or basically to find
or basically to find how much portion of
our donut chart is going to be occupied
by the angle
so the donut chart can be plotted using
the angular wedge function from figure
so the x-axis here is zero and the
y-axis is one the inner radius is the
radius that you are going to be giving
to the inner smaller circle and that
we've given us 0.15
the outer radius is the radius of the
bigger outer circle
and the direction in which our data is
going to be plotted is in the
anti-clockwise direction
so let's run this
and this is what our donut chart looks
like
so the not murdered
is this dark blue color portion of our
donut chart and when you hold
and when you hover over it you can see
how many values are present in the not
murdered column
the same goes for murdered and because
we've plotted our data in the
anti-clockwise function
this is how it's being plotted so
murdered not murdered and then finally
you have the missing values
the way that you can interpret this
graph is that you can say that most of
the people were murdered during the game
but most of the data is missing so we
can't say for certain whether the
majority of the people were murdered
during the game or not because the
number of missing values can make a huge
difference and the number of people who
are not murdered and the number of
people who are murdered are very close
to each other like their total values
are very close to each other
next we will create a data frame of
sabotages fixed and minutes and change
the column name and add t in them
so this is basically what we're doing
we've created a data frame which has a
number of sabotages fixed and the
minutes
now let's just take the three sabotages
which were fixed which is zero one and
two and create a data frame out of all
of these
so each of these individual data frames
just contains these individual columns
to make a simple scatter plot with only
one legend we can pass the data and use
scatter to make the charts
so basically we're just plotting the
scatter chart in bokeh here
and this is what our minutes
scatter chart looks like
now we're plotting this for one t we're
plotting the minute at which one
sabotage was fixed
and another cool thing about bokeh
charts is that you can always zoom into
them or zoom out of them to better see
where your data is plotted
so this is a scatter chart which has
only one variable which is one t and the
minute at which it was plotted
to make a scatter chart with more
variables
we are going to need to use circle
which is a method of figure object which
we've already seen before
the circle is one of the many plotting
styles which are provided by bokeh you
can also use triangles or many more you
don't have to make each point a circle
so we're gonna be plotting
so we're gonna be plotting the sabotage
is fixed and the minute at which they
were fixed
and we're gonna be plotting three
different circles of three different
colors
and each of them correspond to how many
sabotages were fixed at what time zero
sabotages at what time one sabotage at
what time and two at what time so let's
run this
so as you can see here
when zero sabotages were fixed these
were the times
when one was fixed this was the time at
which it was fixed and when two was
fixed this is the time that it was fixed
at
now the x axis is our minutes and the
y-axis is the sabotage
when you hover over it you can see
various information about where each
circle is plotted
so this has an index of 10
the data x y will tell you the
uh exact x coordinate and the y
coordinate and the screen x y will tell
you the screen pixels on which it is
plotted so now we've taken a look at pie
charts let's move on to histograms
so what exactly is a histogram
histograms are used to plot numerical
data according to the range that they
fall into the data is plotted in the
form of bins or rectangles and the
y-axis corresponds to the amount of data
present in a certain range or at a
certain point
so this is what a histogram looks like
this is a histogram
of the distribution of minutes
so the x-axis has the range
within which this data falls like over
here the first
range is from 0 to 2.9 and second one is
from 2.9 to 5.8
each range
has a
value of 2.9 and the corresponding
y-axis or the height of the bins
tells us how much data is present within
this range
so this is how you can read histograms
now let's see how we can plot them using
python bouquet
now let's see the distribution of
minutes in the among this game we will
use his to plot a histogram
so basically just going to be plotting
the minutes of our game
uh we're going to be using the df min
column for this and we're gonna be
converting it
into
an integer
so this is the column that we're going
to be plotting let's plot this
again we're going to be using the plot
bouquet
function here
because it makes plotting data frames
very easy
the kind of data frame that we're going
to be using is the histogram or hist
and the title of our
graph is going to be
distribution
of
minutes
so let's run this
now this is what our histogram looks
like
now this is when we've only plotted one
variable which is minutes
yeah so another thing that you can plot
is a stacked histogram
a stacked histogram is when you plot
various histograms on top of each other
so let's see how this works
for a start histogram we want to see if
the game length has a correlation with
the amount of imposters and crewmates in
our game
so to do this we're going to be creating
a small data frame which has the game
length and the team columns combined
so
let's do that
and this is what this looks like
so all you have to do to plot this in
the form of a stacked histogram is use
the hist function again
so
let's see how that is done
and let's give this figure a size of
say
[Music]
750
comma
350.
so so let's run this again and this is
the start histogram that you get we have
two different columns which are plotted
on top of each other
uh versus the game length
so basically this tells us that when
game length was between
0 to 0.9 minutes the
number of imposters
was way higher than the number of
crewmates
and
the longer the game went on the number
of imposters decreased and the number of
crewmates just kept getting longer and
longer
now obviously you can say that the
number of crewmates is decreasing as the
game goes on too but this is because the
imposters would have killed off most of
the crewmates
as you can see here towards the end
there are no imposters which means that
most of the imposters were rejected and
the crewmates won
so now we've taken a look at histograms
let's move on to bar plots and
understand how exactly they're different
from histograms
so
in histograms you have plotted numerical
data distributions as of yet
in buy plots you plot for categorical
data it also uses bins to plot the
amount of data when the bins are stored
stacked on top of each other it's called
a stack bar chart this is basically what
a bar chart looks like the difference is
this does not have its own range
each bar is used to represent a
categorical data and the height is used
to tell us how much of that categorical
data is present
so now let's see how we can plot a bar
plot
so again we're gonna be making a small
data frame of the task completed and the
value counts of how many tasks have been
completed
to plot a bar plot we're going to be
using plot bokeh again and the kind of
plot that we want to plot is bar
so let's run this and see what we get
so here is your bar plot
the task completed in this case is
categorical data
and the counts basically tells us how
many value counts fall into each
category
so zero does completed are 69
one task completed is 117
2 task completed is 10
and so on
from this bar chart you can say that the
most number of tasks completed is 7 and
the least task completed are 10.
now let's create a stack bar chart and
let's see who wins imposters or
crewmates
to create a start bar chart what we're
going to be doing is that we're going to
be creating a different smaller data
frame of team and outcome
to make sure that the bar chart is
stacked all you have to do is include a
stacked attribute in your bar function
and change its value to true
so let's run this and see and here you
can see that we have a stack bar chart
so you can see that crewmates who have a
lot more data
have
won
981 times and lost 780 times
while imposters have lost
205 times and one 216 times
so the chromates have won significantly
far more than the number of times
imposters have one
now let's take a look at stacked
vertical bar charts so so far the bar
charts that we've been looking at have
been horizontal which means
that the data
goes upwards
for a vertical bar chart we're going to
be seeing if all tasks have been
completed or not
so uh in the data frame column all tasks
completed we're gonna be replacing the
values of yes and no with task completed
and task not completed
we're also going to be creating
a smaller data frame of the outcome
column and the task completed column
to plot a start vertical bar chart you
are going to be using python bokeh dot
bar h function
and you are going to be crea uh changing
the stat
attribute to true
this is what you start horizontal bar
chart looks like
so over here we can see that the missing
values is represented by blue task
completed by orange and task not
completed by green
here you can see the total outcome you
can see how many wins how many tasks are
completed and how many tasks are not yet
completed
and the same goes for losses you can see
how many losses have occurred how many
tasks are completed and how many tasks
were not completed this is a very good
way of representing
a lot of data in a relatively smaller
area
now
the way we can interpret this graph is
that we can say that finishing the task
will automatically
ensure that the crewmates have one so
there's a higher number of people who
need to complete the task to win the
game
another very unique type of bar chart
that you can have is a bi-directional
bar chart
so let's plot a bi-directional
bar chart in which the bars will be
going both ways to the left and to the
right
we're gonna be plotting
a horizontal bar chart over here
to make it easier for you to see
to have
a bidirectional bar chart you need
positive values and negative values the
center
is going to be at zero
so here we're going to be making the
loss features negative by multiplying
the loss feature with the minus one
value
so here we go the losses are all
negatives and the wins are all positives
right now let's run this
and see
how many losses and wins have occurred
for each user
so user1
has 42 losses
and 58 wins but you can easily see
whether they have won more or less or
lost more by comparing the height of the
bars
for the wins and the losses
so we can easily say that in this
scenario user 1 has one more times than
they have lost
the same can be said for user 2 where
the
wins bar is significantly higher than
the losses bar
so this is how you can
plot and understand a bi-directional bar
chart
so we've taken a look at how we can plot
bar charts and the various types of bar
charts that are available to us in
python bouquet
now let's take a look at area plots
area plots is a combination of the line
and the bar chart when the area below a
line is shaded using an area chart we
can see how the values of different
groups change over a period of time
the area chart has different baselines
to show the vertical range of data
here we've
plotted the sabotage is fixed versus the
minutes at which they were fixed at
right so these are the minutes and the
sabotages fixed are of two types zero t
and one t
so the number of minutes that we're
considering here is somewhere around 28
ish right and zero t as you can see has
a way higher value
so one really good thing about area
plots especially in this case is that
they have two ranges
and they have another range on the
y-axis which is still which tells us how
the number of sabotages fixed is ranging
so zero sabotage is fixed you can see
how the value keeps fluctuating
and
how the value changes for different
minutes
and the same can be said for 1t
now 1t has a baseline which is over here
which is just above the zero d baseline
this doesn't necessarily mean that this
is where
one t starts and this is where it ends
this just means that it ranges
from zero all the way here and we can
compare
very easily how zero sabotage is fixed
and one sabotage is fixed range or
change with respect to each other
at
the same time
now the first thing that we're going to
be doing to plot our area chart is that
we're going to be creating
another data frame this is called df
minutes which is going to be comprising
of the minutes column of our data frame
and the sabotage's fixed column of the
same data frame
for df min we're going to be renaming
the columns to 0t and 1t
and the only columns that we're going to
be
considering out of the five different
columns that we have are the zero t and
the one t column
we're going to be combining all of these
together in a format which can be
plotted
by using bokeh and column data source
helps us do this it helps us convert
our various
data frame columns into lists
next we're going to be using the figure
function and we're going to give our
figure a width of 400 a height of 400
and the title of sabotage is fixed
versus the minutes at which they were
fixed at
to plot a stat area graph you are going
to be using v area underscore stack
function
from the figure module
you're going to be passing in your y
parameters which is y naught and y one
because we have two different y
parameters here and the x parameter
which is df minutes
the color that you're going to be using
is gray and light gray
the legend labels are the names that
you've already put here which is 0t and
1t and the source of your data is going
to be this column data source
now let's run this and see how our area
chart looks
so this is our area chart we've got in
two different sabotages here and two
different times
at which they occur which is 0t and 1t
the minutes tells us how many sabotages
were fixed at each time
basically how long it took to fix a
sabotage and the minute during the game
at which they occurred
now let's take a look at the layout
function of our bokeh library
the layout function will let us build a
grid of plots and wedges we can have as
many rows and columns or grids of plots
in one layout
using the layout function we can see
various graphs at the exact same time
mainly used for designing dashboards it
lets you build grids of plots
so this is basically what your layout
function will help you do
this is going to look very good in a
website because it's going to arrange
our plots in a way that we can easily
see all of them
and understand all of them without any
loss of data
this is also arranged very neatly which
is exactly what the layout functions
allow us to do
so now let's take a look at how the
layout function can be implemented in
python bokeh
now of the layout functions there are
many different layout options which are
available
you have the column function which
allows you to display
plots vertically
and you have the grid function which
lets you display plots in the form of
grids
now for example um
let's say that we want to make a
dashboard layout in bokeh
we are going to be considering
three different charts
the first one that we're gonna be
considering is a lollipop chart which is
done here
the next one that we're gonna be
considering are two pie charts
so this is how you plot a lollipop chart
and i'll show you what exactly a
lollipop chart is in just a minute the
first thing that you need to know is
that the first graph that we're going to
be plotting
is going to be a graph which has the
user id versus the outcome of the games
plotted
on it
so what we're going to be doing here is
that we're going to be creating a single
data frame which has
all of the
user ids
present in it along with the user
and the wins that the user has obtained
now using this we're going to be
plotting it in the form of
a plot in decreasing order where we have
the top 10 users who have one
which basically means that the users who
have won the most number of games out of
all the users in consideration
so figure one segment will basically
help you plot
a line which has a width of 2 and a
circle will be at the circle at the very
top of this segment so lollipop chart is
going to be a horizontal line with a
circle at the very top
so the next graph that we're going to be
plotting is going to be a murdered
and not murdered and missing values pie
chart
and the last thing that we're going to
be plotting is a donut chart of the
teams
and the values within them
so these are the three different graphs
that we are going to be plotting and
these are just us creating the graphs
and plotting them
the main logic is over here
the main logic is that you want to set a
layout in bokeh as to how you want to
see the charts
so the layout that we are going to be
looking at is that we're going to be
having a lollipop chart at the very top
and two smaller pie charts at the bottom
right
so
we have three figures here
and the first thing that we're going to
be doing is that we're going to be
giving these
figures
a line color of none
the axis is not going to be visible and
the axis labels are not present for
these figures
this is the main function that you're
going to be looking at this is your
layout using the grade layout function
that you've imported here from python
from bokeh dot layouts you're going to
be creating a grid and how does the grid
know where the figures are
so you've divided the grid into two this
is evident because you have two figures
two main figures here
which are separated by a comma so this
tells the grid that the page is going to
be divided into two
the first figure which is on top is
going to be figure 1
and the figure at the bottom are figure
2 and 3 this means that the bottom half
is going to be further split into
vertically
let's run this and see what our layout
looks like
so here you have it your entire page is
divided into two
the first one has one the figure one
which is the lollipop chart and the
bottom half of our page
has two figures which are the two donut
charts
the bottom half is divided exactly into
two as you can see here
this is because that is the grid layout
that we wanted
so this is how you can use the layout
function in
python bokeh it is extremely easy all
you have to do is create a layout by
using the grid function
or you can also use the column function
the column function will plot it
in the form of a single column
vertically
using the grid function you can plot
figures vertically as shown here
so when you separate them by commas with
respect to each other they will be plot
but they will be plotted vertically and
when you group them together
and separate them with commas internally
they will be plotted horizontally
so now we've taken a look at how we can
use the layout function
now let's see how we can make
interactive graphs with the help of
bokeh
over here we're going to be using bokeh
to design a dashboard which is used to
represent the horsepower in cars
we are also going to make our graphs
interactive and see how maximum
information can be conveyed with the
help of a single graph
so here we have multiple different cars
and along with the cars will also be
going to be given their horse bars
a little bit of other information about
them and their images and over here as
you can see
we have a very simple
vertical bar chart
but let's see how we can make it
interactive and convey all the
information that we have in our single
data set on this one bar graph
so the first thing that we're going to
be doing is importing all of our
important necessary modules we're
obviously going to have the pandas
modules which is going to be imported to
work with the data frame that we've
given
apart from this we're also going to be
importing
figures output file show save and column
data source from bokeh.plotting we
already know that the figure function is
used to plot different types of graphs
which are given
output file is just used to see our file
the show is used to display our graphs
and save will help you save your graph
now the column data source is the core
of most bokeh plots
it provides the data to the glyph of
your plot when you pass sequences like
python lists or numpy arrays to a bokeh
render bokeh automatically creates a
column data source with this data for
you so this is basically what you're
going to be using to pass data onto your
bokeh glyphs
apart from this we're also going to be
using a harvard tool function
and
a trans and from the transform function
we're going to be importing factor c map
we're going to be importing a palette
color
which is going to be various shades of
blue
and we're going to be importing
components from the embedded function of
bokeh
let's just see how we can use all of
these and the different things that they
do
the first thing that you're going to be
doing is reading in your car's data
frame and creating a column data source
so that you can easily pass this data
onto your bokeh glyphs
so let's run
and import all of our various required
functionalities and import the data as
well
so this is what your data set looks like
we have eight different values in our
data set
which are the names of different cars
their horsepower their price and a
hyperlink of an
image this is what our data set looks
like we have only eight columns
so using this data set we're going to be
plotting a horizontal bar graph
again we're gonna be
calling our figure function and we're
gonna be giving y range to our car list
the y range is basically just going to
have the different uh values which are
going to be present on the y-axis we've
given the blood a width of 800 and a
height of 600.
the title of the plot is cars with top
horsepower and the x-axis label is horse
bar
the tools that we're using here is pan
box select zoom in zoom out save and
reset so these are tools that you're
going to be getting on the right side of
your plot
now let's render our glyph or render our
graph
the graph that we are going to be using
here is the horizontal bar graph so the
y-axis is going to have cars
and the right or basically the height of
the entire bar is going to depend on the
horsepower
the left is going to start from 0 and
the height of each bar is going to be
0.4
the color that we are going to be giving
is going to be a palette of blue so each
different car will have a different
color of blue associated with it and
the
color of blue which is associated with
it will depend on the car list
now fill alpha 0.9 the source is your
source data that you have over here
which is the column data source of our
data frame
and the legend is going to be car which
basically means that your entire uh
uh plot is going to have the legend of
kar
now we're going to be adding the legend
this is
us giving the legend its orientation so
the legend is going to be vertically
oriented the location is going to be on
the top right and the font size of the
text car of a legend is going to be 10
px or 10 pixels
we're also going to be adding a hover
tool
inside this harvard tool
this hover tool tips will basically tell
you what you're going to be seeing
in the harvard tool box so we're going
to be creating this with the help of an
html format
the first thing that you are going to be
seeing is the name of the car
the next
column will have the price of the car
the horsepower of the car
and the image
now the image is in the form of a
hyperlink and this is going to be auto
populated in your hover tool
the width of the image is going to be
800
so
we are going to add all of these hover
tools to our p image and we are finally
going to be showing you the graph and
what it looks like
so this is your bouquet plot here the
name the title of the plot is cars with
top horsepower this is your
legend which is cars
the name of each car is given here along
with the color which is associated with
it here are the different tools that we
have
you can save this
you can reset it you can zoom out you
can zoom in
you can select the boxes
and you can pan your image
so here we're zooming in here we're
zooming out
if we save this the plot automatically
gets
downloaded in your system and if you
reset it the image goes back to exactly
what it looked like when it was first
opened
now
here you have the names of the different
cars on the y-axis and you have the
various horse bars on the x-axis
let's take a look at a harvard tool
so here you have the name of the car
which is on top you have the price and
you have the horsepower and as you can
see you have the image which is hyperpop
which is populated instantly from the
hyperlink that was available to us
now the color palette associated with
each car
gets darker the more the horsepower of
the car increases
so here we have cars with top
horsepowers
which are arranged in an
ascending order from the top and a
descending order from the bottom
so this is another way that you can use
bokeh to create extremely interactive
and informational graphs here in just
half a page
and this is us making a huge plot right
we can also decrease the size of the
plot if you want to
but basically in half a page we've
conveyed all the
information ranging from the name of the
car to its model to the horsepower that
is ha that it has its price and also its
image
and this is also very good way to
compare it
so these are just some functionalities
which are provided in bokeh itself no
other
data visualization library will let you
work
so well
with graphs and will let you customize
your graphs to this extent visual data
helps you perform exploratory data
analysis and find hidden patterns in the
data it lets you analyze trends in the
data and draw meaningful conclusions
today we will learn how to visualize
data using tableau power bi and excel
and create interesting charts and graphs
reports as well as dashboards using
leading bi tools
so let's dive in and learn data
visualization for data science hello and
welcome to tableau training for
beginners my name is michelle covine and
i'm with the simplyland team so what is
business intelligence
companies use business intelligence
technologies to collect analyze and
present data in order to create
actionable information
today's businesses are always seeking
insights about their customers products
and services
so businesses are faced with many
questions such as how do i know my
customers are happy what would make my
customers stay and how can i increase
awareness of my products and services
business intelligence can help you
answer those questions when you have a
question about what your customers are
feeling what your customers are doing
who the customers are and what's the
best channel to target them business
intelligence is a method of transforming
your data into these insights and
measurable metrics business intelligence
tools are designed to make the data flow
manageable in the age of information
tableau is one of many tools to help
manage the data flow and turn data into
actionable information but we also have
click and sap and oracle you may have
heard of some of these let's take a look
at some of the benefits of tableau as
your business intelligence tool so why
would we use tableau it can be connected
to 40 different data sources the more
data sources it can connect to it means
that you are more likely to get direct
access to your data it can build
interactive dashboards with just a few
clicks which can help you quickly
understand your data and it lets you see
your outliers
there's also simple analytics built
right into tableau such as trends and
forecasting that can help you understand
your data on a deeper level
tableau has been a leader in the gartner
magic quadrant for the last six years
and that includes 2018. here we will
take a look at an overview of the
products offered by tableau so we have
tableau desktop which is where you do
all of your development this is where
you connect to and build visualizations
and dashboards today we'll be using
tableau public which is a free version
of tableau desktop but with some
limitations such as having no r
integration and it can only support up
to a million rows of data also any data
published here is made public so you
can't use this for private company
information then there's a new tool
called tableau prep where you can
prepare your data by seeing it visually
before you connect and build reports
there's also tableau online which is a
cloud-hosted version of tableau server a
place where you can publish your
dashboards and it enables you to share
your dashboards in a secure way tableau
server has an option to be on premises
so let's just do a quick comparison
between building a visualization in
excel and building one in tableau okay
so here we have an excel file full of
data that we will soon connect to and
use for some of our demonstration
purposes
and you can see that we have information
about orders if we wanted to find out
the
quantity sold and the sum of sales for
each region we could do that by creating
a pivot table so we'll make it i
selected my cells we'll make it in the
new worksheet
and here we have the beginnings of a
pivot chart and we can grab region and
pull it into our columns
and then we'll grab
sales
and put it into values
and then we also want to look at
quantity and put that into values and
it's automatically summing up sales and
quantity but you can choose if you want
it to be sum or not and then we'll take
our values and put it on rows so that we
can see
sales and quantity
one on top of the other and that's the
basics of a pivot chart now let's do a
similar thing in tableau
okay so we have our connection to the
data and tableau automatically splits
out the dimensions from the measures
we'll go into more depth on that later
but we can come and grab a region and
put it onto columns
and we get a similar thing maybe a
little nicer formatted and then we can
come and put quantity
there
and if we want to add sales to it we can
double click on sales and we'll have
quantity and sales one on top of the
other we can put sales on top by
dragging quantity
down in that box we also have this show
me dialog box which allows you to
see what visualizations you could build
using what's already on the screen or
the things that you have selected so
right now we could quickly switch it to
bar charts and now we can see quantity
and sales across our region with bar
charts or we could switch it to stacked
bars
and we can see a quantity across the
regions if you close that we can see our
legend over here
and then our sales across the region
so in tableau we have a lot of really
quick flexibility to turn just text into
a visualization
so in summary we can see a side by side
of what we made using pivot tables in
excel and what we made in a similar
amount of time in tableau let's get
started with the tableau installation as
for requirements you need windows 7 or
later or you need your mac operating
system to be 10.11 or later here are
some of the browsers you can use to
install tableau we will be installing
tableau public today and to do that you
just google tableau public download and
click on that first link and then you
put in your email address and click
download the app so
let's just
look up tableau public download
and it's this first one you can click
download now
it takes you to the tableau public page
where you can click sign in and create
an account free
this gives you a place to save the
visualizations you make but keep in mind
anything you save on tableau public is
public and then you come here and you
enter your email address and click
download the app and it should give you
executable file
that you will download
and once it's downloaded you should be
able to open tableau public so let's go
take a look at the tableau public
opening page
so this is what tableau public looks
like when you first open it on your left
you have the different things you can
connect to
this is more limited in tableau public
than it is in tableau desktop so if you
invest in tableau desktop you have
many many things you can connect to
you can also connect to data by clicking
this drop down connect data piece that's
especially useful when you've already
started your visualization
then we have this central portion called
open this is where anything that you
have opened up previously will show up
you can also click open from tableau
public and when you have
my connections timed out so i need to
log in
but when you log in
it says no workbook found try publishing
first this is where you'll see all of
your published tableau public dashboards
over here we have discover and it has
some how-to videos
visualization of the day
which is where people who have made
tableau public visualizations get
recognized for their skill and you get
some pretty cool ideas when you look
there
so let's get started by connecting to a
data source we'll click microsoft excel
and we'll choose our excel file and open
it up
and this is our data source pane this
shows you the sheets on the excel file
and allows you to drag them in so that
you can see the data show up this gives
you a preview of what your data will
look like
you can see the tableau is starting to
classify our fields so anything that has
abc on it
shows that that's a column that has
strings in it we also have a globe which
is where tableau has recognized these
values to be geographical
so we have
state and it's recognized that it
contains states it bases it on
the keywords that it stores to identify
if it's geographical and so it takes a
look and you've named it city and it
knows that city is geographical we also
have the calendar symbol where it's
recognized that it's a date field and we
also have row id that shows up with the
hashtag and i recognize it's a number so
now that we have our data source pulled
in we can come here and hit sheet which
is where you start to build your
visualization let's take a look at all
the different pieces of this before we
go any further we have the data that
we're connected to up here is our orders
sheet from the sample superstore excel
sheet we have dimensions on top and
measures on bottom these are where we're
going to get the fields to drag and drop
here we have our cards we'll look more
in depth at our cards in a moment and
these are our shelves the column shelf
and the row shelf where you can drag
things in to make changes happen in the
visualization center we have our show me
tabs where you can see we took a brief
look at this earlier but you can see all
the different visualizations you can
build here
a neat thing about show me is that when
you hover
it'll tell you what types of fields you
need to build it so for a symbol map try
one geographical field
zero or more dimensions or zero to two
measures and that's how you can build a
geographical symbol map
and when you're done with show me you
just close it
let's take a look here at our sheets so
we have sheet one and sheet two a sheet
is basically just one visualization at a
time
let's get rid of the extra sheet we have
a dashboard which is where you can pull
multiple sheets on to show multiple
visualizations at one time
and then we have what's called the story
which allows you to show
a sequence of visualizations so that you
can tell a story
perfect okay so we saw that tableau is
categorizing
our different fields
and it is also giving it a role
so we have dimensions on top and
measures on bottom
dimensions contain descriptive values
such as names dates and geographical
data you can use dimensions to reveal
details in your data that is qualitative
details we also have measures which
contain numeric quantitative values that
you can measure measures can be
aggregated and when you drag a measure
onto the view tableau will apply an
aggregation to that measure it's sum by
default
so let's show this by building what we
built before we'll grab region and we'll
see its four distinct
values as a dimension
and then we'll double click on quantity
and we can see the
numbers here the measures and you can
see here that it is the sum of quantity
and now we can also double click on
sales and we can see quantity and sales
to discuss a little bit more about
dimensions and measures you can see that
in general measures are numbers and
dimensions are not but sometimes like
row id it is a number now why would we
have a number up here instead of in the
measures so you can tell the difference
between number whether it should be in
measures or it should be in dimensions
based on whether you'll need to do any
calculations on it or if you would want
to be able to aggregate it at some time
so for
sales
if you have
several orders in a day
you might want to know what the sum of
those sales are
but if you have several orders in the
day
and they're on rows two three four and
five you might not want to know the sum
of the rows so tableau is smart enough
that when it sees id it knows that it
belongs up in the dimensions now you can
switch so if row id was actually
something you would want to aggregate
for some reason you can drag it down to
the measures and add it down there
but in our case row id isn't something
that you want to sum or average can you
think of any other numbers that might
not show up as a measure that should be
a dimension comment below with your
answers as we discussed before
dimensions are on top measures are on
bottom and you can see the blue is
associated with dimensions and green is
associated with measures but it's a
little bit more complicated than that so
dimensions are qualitative and measures
are quantitative but blue means we want
our label to be discrete and green means
we want our label to be continuous let's
make a new sheet and make a
visualization to kind of show this so we
can bring on quantity and we're going to
use it as a dimension but you can see
even when it's dimension you can choose
continuous or discrete so right now it's
a dimension but it's green a little bit
different than what you might expect and
then we'll do sales so now we can see
over the different quantities what our
sales was yeah has been for this last
this period of time that we're looking
at i believe it's four years so for when
people bought three items the total
sales was
that number and you can see that this is
an axis so it's from 1 to 15. now if we
change it from continuous to discrete
you can see that 1 is a label 2 is a
label and it's not an axis ranging from
one to it doesn't even have 15 because
there are no values under 15. these are
just individual labels so we go back
it's green again and you can see that
it's an axis so we have two greens on
here so we have two axes and change it
back to discrete and now we have one
axes and one set of individual labels so
let's go back to our sheet three
we have
all of these different
sales by the different quantity numbers
and up here we have our sorting when you
hover it tells you what kind of sorting
is going to happen so we could sort
quantity descending by sales so we can
see that when they buy three things we
have the highest sales
you can do the opposite
where it's the lowest
to the highest
number of sales you can also do sorting
more in depth by clicking on the
quantity and right clicking sort so we
could just sort
by
descending or ascending or by sales or
alphabetic
which is
not what we want
you can choose the field or you can
manually change your sorting here
and now we're back to what we had at the
beginning now that we've had an overview
of how tableau works let's go into a
little more detail tableau is very much
built on the premise of drag and drop
so
let's build a simple visualization
and talk about what each of these
shelves and marks cards specifically do
so we're going to make a simple chart
which is average sales by region
so we know we want
sales
on
let's do sales on
rows now for rows and for metrics since
this is continuous like we talked about
before it's making an axis
for our sales
we also can drag
region onto columns and it makes one
column
per region so that's how it works with
dimensions if you
pull a dimension onto columns you're
saying i want one
blank per column i want one region per
column so if you wanted to do it by
instead of region
if you want to remove something from a
visualization you just pull it back off
or you can hit undo or control z
tableau has the benefit of having
unlimited undos so let's say we wanted
to
bring on city let's say we want one
column per
city and that's what you get and there's
a lot of cities
so that's what it looks like let's take
city back off
i want one column per
region
and for
sales
i want my rose axes
to show me where sales are great now
let's say we want to adjust the color of
these bars you can click on color
and you can select any of them so let's
pick this nice blue or we can pick an
orange and that's how you can determine
the color
but if you want
something else to determine the color
you can take
region
and drag it onto color and now we have
one color per region
now with measures again since they're
continuous it's going to be more like a
scale
so
if i want them to be
a different color based on sales and i
pull sales onto color it's going to be
darker where there's higher sales and
lighter where there's lower sales so
it's continuous from light to dark
but for region it is one color per
region so they're distinct colors it's
not continuous
great
um
let's say we want to sort this
biggest the smallest
and we can look at size here so if we
want to adjust the size manually we can
click on it and drag it
but if we want the size to be based on
something else
you choose a measure for the size so if
we want it to be
wider
based on
sales we will drag sales onto size and
we can see that it gets bigger with
bigger sales you do the same thing
and replace the sales with profit and
now it's bigger if there is bigger
profit and drag that back off so you can
determine manually or you can do it with
your measures um for label let's say we
want the sales on to label now we can
see
the exact sales
number
for each
region
um what if we wanted the name of the
region there as well we can drag region
onto labels and we can see sales for the
west region
you can adjust which one goes on top
see how we have two t's here those are
both labels
great uh two tip
when we click on tool tip it'll show us
what's going to happen
when we hover so as i hover here on east
it says region east sales and that shows
the sales amount
now we talked about
i'll take my labels back off wanting to
make this visualization not for the sum
of sales but for the average
of sales so
we will right click on our sum of sales
here in the rows hover over measure
which right now is sum and change it to
average and we have a different
result here so let's sort again and we
can see that the south
region actually has the highest average
of sales which was not the case for the
sum now let's say we want our sum i mean
our sales to be on the label but look
it's giving us the sum of sales label so
we just do the same thing
and change it to average
now we can see our average on the label
uh the label has some interesting
options
like you can format this
and we could say maybe we want it to be
all of them to be blue
and that happens right there
you can also choose to only show the
minimum and the maximum
this becomes handy on
a line chart where you don't want all
marks labeled because it gets very messy
but you want the tallest and the
shortest part to be labeled and maybe
you just want the tallest so we'll click
label minimum value and remove that
checkbox and now we just have the
tallest value there
and one card that we haven't used yet is
the filters card so
we could allow people
to look at this
but from only
certain regions so what we can do is we
can come over to region and right click
on it and click show filter
and it will add it to that filters card
and now we can remove central from the
mix and just look at those ones you see
if we remove south the new highest east
now has the label but if we put it back
in south will have the label again if we
don't want to have these filters
we can pull it off there or if we wanted
to filter out
by country oh we just have united states
so let's not filter by country
but we could pull in
category
and we have these filters by category if
we select them all
they'll all be there
and we click show filter and it will
bring it over here and we can remove out
technology and the south still has the
highest for the other two but if we only
include technology you can see the
difference there
so that's the basics of filters
one another thing that i can mention
here
is that you can change the type of mark
manually so you saw when we pulled on
region and we pulled on sales it
automatically made us a bar chart but we
could change this to be a line chart
and you can see that the color changes
because we told it to based on region if
we pull that off
then it would be a line chart there
you can change it to be a lot of
different type of visualizations here
so when you're not using show me to help
determine your graphs you can choose it
manually right here
okay
now let's
look at building a scatter plot so
scatter plot is when you have a bunch of
shapes and points on a visualization
with two axes that are both measures
so if we take
sales
and put it on the
y-axis and we take
discount and put it on the x-axis we can
see
our point that represents all of our
data with the sum of sales and the sum
of discount
and if we wanted to see this per
order we'll take order id and put it on
to detail now what detail does is it
determines the level that we are
building our visualization at so
grabbing order id and putting onto
detail
gives us all of these little points so
for each order what was our sales
and what was our discount so we have out
here some outliers that you can find
very quickly
let's actually do product id instead so
i'll put it right over top of order id
and it will replace it
now we see all of our products anything
that has high sales is up here anything
that has high discount is over here you
can see that it sort of has a trend
where
things with high sales do not have high
discounts which makes sense if we wanted
to
know what
category these products i'll show up in
we could take category
and put it onto shape
and now we have three different shapes
that tell us the categories tableau has
a cool new highlight feature which
allows you to show
just the dimension that you want to see
but it leaves the other ones in place so
for example if we click on furniture
first we have to turn on the highlight
feature and then click on furniture
and now you can see all of the furniture
items popping up in our visualization
and how they're kind of clustered in
this area and the pattern for them when
we click on technology
we can see their pattern which is a
little bit different so we have them by
shape
with category let's drag category onto
color as well if you remember
category will determine the color
and the shape at this point and so we
can kind of see the patterns happening
there
so if we want to see our high discounted
items
they're all over here and most of the
things that are getting
high discounts are office supplies which
is interesting
and then our highest sales product up
here now we could take that product id
and find out what that product actually
is out of our oh look we have product
name let's replace product id with
product name
and we see that that is a canon image
class advanced copier so this copier is
our big sales person and office supplies
binders do not give us very many sales
and we're highly discounting them
so now you know a little bit more about
the details card and the shapes card and
about using highlighting
in tableau
so
let's say
we wanted to know by subcategory what
our profit is like we could grab
subcategory and pull it onto columns and
we would say we want one column per
subcategory
and then let's grab profit
and pull it onto rows
and you can quickly see
which categories are profitable and
which ones are not so we can also take
profit and put it onto color
so that you can see that even more
clearly
right now it is going from orange to
blue which is tableau's default if we
wanted to change
from what color to what color it was
going we have a lot of options in here
when you go to edit colors
so maybe you wanted to go from red to
blue
just to emphasize that the profit that's
negative is bad so we can hit apply and
now we can see red to blue we have our
categories here
our sub categories here but let's
separate it out by category so what i'm
going to do i'm going to take
subcategory off
i'm going to put on category and that's
my category and then i'm going to put
subcategory on after it so when we put
it in order like this the order matters
in tableau so first it breaks it up by
category and then inside of that it
breaks it up by subcategory
so furniture's all here and then there's
our subcategories under furniture if we
were to move subcategory to the front
it really doesn't group it appropriately
because first it's breaking it up by
subcategory and then by category and
that's not effective we end up with
furniture furniture furniture furniture
spread out across our visualization so
again let's put category to the front
and now we have our profit by category
by sub category
and we can
click
sort subcategory descending by profit
and now what it does is within the
highest group within each group
it then sorts it by profit so you can
tell it's not going to break this group
apart to move tables to the very end
it's going to keep tables inside of
furniture and then it doesn't move
furniture to the very end either
so
what we have here is a quick view by
category by subcategory how we're doing
on profit we can see that
tables is our biggest drain on profit
and so if we wanted to improve the
profitability of furniture
maybe we would
not sell tables anymore it's just not
working out for us another thing about
this visualization that we could do to
improve it
is you can see that there's some of
these words are getting cut off so
we can right click on this axis and
click rotate label
and now you can read the whole word and
so that's helpful also up here we have
our title which right now is the same
name as our sheet
so if we rename the sheet to
profit by
sub category
then it names the title up here so this
is making it look a little bit better
and then here we have profit
and it shows it but without any like
dollar signs so let's come up here to
profit and click format and you can see
that we can format the sum of profit
to be currency
and
we can do a currency by the thousands
now we can get rid of these decimal
places and now you can see it's just a
little bit nicer a little bit more clear
maybe we don't have to have the label
here that says
category subcategory so we can hide
field labels for columns
because it's pretty clear that these are
categories and these are subcategories
so those are some formatting tips for
you formatting in tableau is one of
those things where there are just a lot
of different ways you could change
things
so in more in-depth videos especially
from simply learn you'll learn more and
more about this
also as we are
building these visualizations if you
want to
have access to this data set so that you
can build along with me just make a
comment in the comments below and the
simply learn team will send you this
data set now we're going to take a look
at creating a hierarchy in tableau
so we'll make a new tab
and we're going to make a sheet
called
sales
by
product and so we will be looking at
sales as a number
and let's bring on product name
now there are a lot of products names so
it's going to make sure that you really
want to do this i'm going to click add
all members and now we can see all of
our products and their sales
overall time
so if we sort this we can see our
highest sale selling item which we
discovered earlier as the advanced
copier and we scroll down to the bottom
our lowest selling items
so we have our products and we can group
that by subcategory
and you can see i need to put it in the
front again
and by category
all right i'm going to take product name
back off and we're going to talk about
hierarchies so
a product rolls up into a subcategory
which rolls up into a category you can
create a hierarchy by
let's start with subcategory and
dragging it onto category and it's going
to create a hierarchy we'll call it our
product
hierarchy
and now it knows that category is the
parent to subcategory
let's do the same thing by grabbing
the product name and putting it
underneath subcategory so now it knows
categories the parent then there's
subcategory and then there's product
name this allows you to instead of
pulling this off or putting it back on
you can bring category on and then you
can expand it by pressing this plus
button and now we see but here's our
sales by category by sub
category and then here's our sales
by category by subcategory by product
name this is really useful when you're
creating a details section for your
users
and so when somebody wants to know
let's say you have
show filter for category and a filter
for subcategory
show filter for subcategory and they're
looking at category here and they're
just like i see technology has the
highest sales and i just want to see
technology so i'm going to unclick
furniture and office supplies
let's put category on top and then so i
just have technology will i want to see
what has the highest sales inside of
technology and let's sort it up phones
phones does so i just actually want to
look at phones so i'm going to remove
accessories copiers and machines and
what has the highest sales inside of
phones
and sort it and now i can see quickly
the detailed information
without having to change my
visualization let's give this
visualization a little more depth
first i'll add back in all of our
categories and subcategories
by showing across
region
so we know technology had the highest
but how does it look across region now
part of the point of tableau is to allow
the users to read the visualizations
very quickly and when you have big
blocks of text like this it's kind of
hard to see which one has the highest
because it doesn't quite stand out very
quickly
so what we can do
is take
sales and drag it onto color
let's change our marks to a square and
now it's going to color each of these it
colors every one of these cells based on
its darkness for sales this is a little
bit heavy of a color you can click color
here and change the opacity to give it a
little bit
of a lighter look
just makes it a little bit see-through
great so now it's a lot easier to see
that the west seems to have the highest
sales
and that technology in the east is the
very highest so now when we drill into
subcategory it keeps that coloring and
we can see more in depth and quicker
that phones has the highest across most
of them it's not quite the highest in
the west because chairs is the highest
in the west
there's one place in tableau where
hierarchies are built in and that's in
dates so dates in tableau can be very
complex because they allow
very complex visualizations so we will
not go into depth about dates at this
time but let's take a look at how they
work for hierarchies so we have order
date that we can pull onto columns here
and you can see that it's blue meaning
that it's discrete so each one of these
is a header instead of it being an axis
across the top
now let's drag profit
onto rows
so now we can see our profit
over time for each of these years
and tableau has some hierarchies built
into dates already so when i click this
plus on
columns it'll split it out into quarters
so this is a header and these are all
sub headers underneath that header
because it is distinct um and discrete
right now instead of continuous so it's
split out year year year year and
quarters quarters quarters quarters this
allows you to quickly compare quarter
one across all of the years and quarter
two across all the years and quarter
four across all the years
another way you could add some more
detail to this is by taking maybe
category and pulling out a color and now
we have one line for each category and
we can see
that a drop in technology
is a big part of the responsibility for
that drop we were seeing in quarter two
of 2016. so let's take that back off and
let's take quarter back off
and let's explore continuous dates so
here in dates we have our top section of
dates and then you see of repeats and we
have the bottom section of dates so
we've got year but we also have year
here quarter and quarter now the top
ones are all discrete and when i change
it to a bottom one
year same thing same here it changes it
to be green and now it's continuous
so now instead of this being a header
for 2013 and a header for 2014 it's an
axis so the difference here is when i
press the plus and then changes it to
quarter instead of adding quarter to
year now it's doing quarter four each
year and making one continuous line and
we can keep going
and drill down to month
you can go pretty far
now when we add category as color we get
our three lines for the three categories
and we also have highlighting turned on
here still so when we click on
technology we can highlight technology
with the others in the background so we
don't lose the context of the other
categories let's take that back off
next let us talk about calculated fields
so we'll make a new sheet and we're
going to create our first calculated
field we can create a calculated field
by clicking this arrow which gives us
some options and clicking create
calculated field or we can come and
click in the white space below
dimensions or below measures and we
right click and click create calculated
field let's name it
profit ratio so this is for if we wanted
to create a visualization that showed
the profit ratio but we don't have that
measure readily available to us to bring
in fields for our calculation you can do
it in one of two ways one is to start
typing it
and it will start auto prompting you for
the different measures or for different
calculations or
values you can use or you can come and
drag it in so if we want profit and we
want sales if we do profit divided by
sales that is
a profit ratio
unaggregated
okay and let's make a second calculated
field we could come here and click
duplicate
and that will duplicate our field but i
just want to start over again so i'll
click create calculated field
and i will call it profit
ratio
aggregated
and in this one we're gonna do sum
click
of profit
click divided by
sum of sales
okay so now what's the difference
between profit ratio
aggregated and profit ratio on
aggregated how will those behave
differently in tableau let's look at
this by looking at a single
order so first let's bring on all the
orders and all the products
under that order and let's look at this
order
so
i want to filter this whole dashboard to
only this order so i can right click on
it and click keep only that creates a
filter up here
that only has that box checked
and if i want to get rid of this later
i can just pull it right off of filters
and everything will come back but i want
it so
keep only
and now let's take a look at profit
ratio aggregated i double clicked on it
and i added it here and profit ratio
unaggregated again double clicking and
now they're side by side let's give us a
little bit more room
so when i dragged that out it gave us
more room so we could see them side by
side and the entire titles okay so i
chose to look at one order and these
product names because the combination of
order and product name is unique one per
row we know that tableau will aggregate
the data up to the lowest level in the
visualization and i brought it all the
way down to the lowest level of the data
source so we have no aggregation right
now
so when we're looking at it without any
aggregation these two calculations are
the same profit ratio aggregated let's
look at that again we'll click edit and
that's the one where we sum profit and
some sales before we divide
and then we've got profit ratio
unaggregated so let's also look at
profit and look at sales this is a
technique that i use when i'm trying to
understand how my calculated fields are
working try to break it down to the
lowest level possible and see if it's
doing what i expect
so we've got profit and we've got sales
now both of them are at
point five or fifty percent and that's
because profit is eight and sales is
sixteen for adam's telephone messaging
now
let's take off product name
when we take off product name we can see
that they start to vary we've got profit
ratio aggregated and profit ratio
unaggregated so here we have profit and
sales the profit ratio should be profit
divided by sales so let's open up a
calculator
and make it a little smaller
so if we take profit at 219.1
and divide it by sales at 508.6
we get
0.4 not 1.8 so where does this 1.8 come
from
well let's put product name back on here
what happens is with profit ratio
aggregated it sums up the profit and
then divides it by the sum of sales so
that's what we did when we took off
profit ratio and aggregated we had the
sum of profit and divided it by the sum
of sales which is what we want profit
ratio unaggregated however
does the calculation profit divided by
sales and then
sums it afterwards you can see it right
here it's the sum of profit ratio on
aggregated so it makes this calculation
and then
it adds up 0.5 plus 0.5 plus 0.3 plus
0.5
and that's where we get our 1.8 which is
what we see
when we pull off product name 1.8 so for
most calculations you want to do profit
ratio aggregated
where you determine how it's aggregated
before you do the calculation
so let's remove profit ratio on
aggregated
and
delete it let's go to profit ratio
aggregated
and just call it profit ratio
perfect now we no longer need anything
that we have on our visualization right
now so let me show you a quick trick to
clear the board tableau has this button
up here which is called clear sheet you
can also do on windows alt shift
backspace and you just click clear sheet
and it will start you over with that
sheet and that really helps when you've
dragged a bunch of things on and really
made a mess when you're trying things
out okay so we're going to build a
visualization and we're going to look at
region and we're going to look at it by
profit ratio and so now we have this bar
chart by profit ratio let's color this
by region we can also pull on profit and
sales and we can see all three of them
side by side split out by region
now let's say we also wanted to see
each region
by sales per customer so let's create
some calculated fields that will help us
do that let's create our first
calculated field
that's going to get us a count of
customers
let's call it total
number of customers
so we have customer name and customer id
let's do
count distinct
of customer id and that gives us the
total number of customers
apply so right now we could take total
number of customers and see which
categories have the highest number of
customers perfect but that's just one
part of our calculation we want to see
total sales divided by total number of
customers so let's make our second
calculated field and we're going to call
it
sales per
customer
we're going to do our sum
of sales
which we can drag in
and divide that by total number of
customers now you see that calculated
field we just made pops up inside of our
calculation
dialog box and we hit apply and it shows
up so we hit ok and let's replace
total number of customers
with sales per customer and now we can
see our sales per customer ratio and
which ones have the highest or for this
next part i'm going to make a couple of
visualizations in a row that all applied
to the same information using a couple
of different tactics so
first let's use show me so i want to
look at
region and sales for this visualization
so i'm going to control click
region
after i clicked sales so one more time
i'm going to
click on sales and i'm going to control
click region
and i'm going to click show me and it's
going to give me all of the different
visualizations i could make with region
and sales let's pick
tree map
great so now we have a tree map that
shows us our sales
by region
and we have the size and the color of
the box is both sales so let's say we
wanted the size to be sales but the
color to be profit so let's grab profit
and drag that on to sales so now we can
see our most profitable to our least
profitable let's
edit our colors and we're going to
change it from red to blue diverging red
to blue but let's go to advanced and
make the center number
zero
this means that it will never be red
unless it's less than zero so let's hit
apply so it's all blue and if anything
ever goes negative then it will be read
okay let's call this sheet
sales
profit by region
perfect
now we're going to start using our
geographical
fields so we have state city country and
postal code let's double click on state
and see what happens
awesome so it is
generated these two fields tableau has
generated longitude and latitude for us
and it's been able to recognize the
states in the united states and where
they're located and given it a longitude
and latitude
so next we will
look at sales
by state by double clicking on sales and
what it's done was change the size of
the dot based on sales now i think i'm
going to move sales from size to color
and it has automatically changed it to a
filled map instead of dots on a map
perfect so now we can see the states
with the
biggest amount of sales let's put it
back onto size and we have our circles
again
let's put sails onto size not stayed
onto size and we have our circles again
but let's make them a little bit bigger
these two marks on the tableau size line
are to give you an idea of how big and
how small you should go before it gets
too difficult to see so when we go
bigger than the bigger line it detects
that you're getting close to having
overlap
but it's up to you as the builder okay
so we have size for
sales again and for profit onto color
again so you can see
anything that is more profitable is
darker and anything that is less
profitable
or less than zero in this case is orange
let's do what we did with color before
change it to
red blue diverging and set our center
point to zero okay so now we know that
if anything is red it was negative in
profit perfect let's name this sheet
sales
profit
by state
great now let's look at sales and profit
by category so we have category and
we've made columns so
this is when we drag something to the
columns shelf just remember we want one
column per category
and let's double click on sales and it's
going to put it into text and that's not
what i want so let's take sales and drag
it onto rows and it automatically makes
a bar chart so now we have one bar with
the axis of sales for furniture office
supplies and technology
now let's
take profit and also put it on
rows so now we have two bar charts one
for sales and one for profit we can
change which one is a bar and which one
is maybe a bubble chart
by clicking on its appropriate marks
card so if we want to change them both
we can click on all
and change them both to maybe circles
and you can see how they go up and down
but if we want to just change
one of them let's put those back to
automatic we'll go to profit and change
that one to
the circles so now we can see
those profit numbers and if we want them
to be overlaid on the same area we would
right click on profit the second measure
on the rows and click dual access so now
let's put them onto the same axis you
can see that their axes are not lined up
let's go to sales and change it back to
a bar
so now we have two charts occupying the
same space
one of them is a bar chart and one of
them is a bubble chart and we can see
our sales versus our profit at least
they're not the same amount of dollars
obviously but we can see a higher
sales and a higher profit we also have
medium sales and a medium profit we have
a medium sales but a really low profit
and it's interesting to see that
contrast so let's rename this sheet
as
sales
profit
by category
and
finally we're going to make our details
sheet so we're going to go down to
subcategory level and bring it onto rows
and remember subcategory can expand out
to the actual products let's bring that
back in and we're going to bring sales
onto columns which makes us a sales bar
chart and profit onto columns which
makes us a profit bar chart now let's
color them by their appropriate
individual color so we'll go to the
sales marks card and drag sales onto
color
now sales is colored by sales we'll do
the same thing here we did before we'll
go red blue diverging
and make the center
zero we actually don't have to do that
for sales because sales will never be
negative but it's pretty important for
profit so we'll go to the profit marks
card and take profit onto color
and do the same thing there
we have
red blue diverging
advanced center is zero great so now if
it's negative it will be there so let's
sort this
by profit and so both of them have
sorted with profit in mind and we can
easily see our subcategories that have a
negative profit
rename this and we'll call it our
details sheet so now we have these four
visualizations that all have to do with
similar
information i think i want these bigger
on the states so we'll just keep making
that bigger perfect now we're going to
make our first dashboard so for our
dashboard we have
information over here that shows you
what sheets you can bring on these get a
little bit more complex so they'll be
covered in more in-depth type of videos
and then we have our size so
we could make a range of sizes based on
um maybe what you're viewing this on but
we're just going to change it to a fixed
size
and we're going to make it
1400
by
a thousand and this is our
dashboard size so let's bring on sales
profit by region
sales and profit by state now a map
needs a little bit more horizontal space
than region does let's bring sales and
profit by category underneath the region
and the detail underneath the state give
our map more space again perfect
now tableau has this neat feature called
uses filter so you can click use this
filter here and now if i click on any of
these it will filter the other
dashboards based on these features so if
i just want to look at the south and i
click on south it zooms into all my
south states now my categories have
updated to be just the south ones and my
details have updated as well so
we could see that central has pretty big
sales you know bigger than the south but
the profit is lower than the south so we
can click on central and focus on
central
let's use
that uses filter
on all three of these
dashboards that lead us up to the detail
so building a quick dashboard like this
let's make this taller would allow you
to do some sort of analysis such as
let's take a look at central because
they have relatively high profits but
low sales so we click on central and
then we see oh man texas is having a
really hard time so let's click on texas
and now we're seeing in texas that we
have
negative profit in these categories so
we can control click on furniture and
office supplies and we can see all of
our products that are really just
killing us in texas all of our
subcategories and if we want to go
deeper into products we'll just click
that plus sign and now we see all the
products and we'll sort again
and we can see all the products by
subcategory that are really just killing
us
and are maybe not worthwhile to make
anymore so we're gonna have to
reconsider making the 3.6 cubic foot
counter height office refrigerator at
least for texas it's not very helpful
there and then when you
back out of that subcategory section you
can also click
somewhere neutral in the dashboard or
click on each thing that you had
selected to unselect it and go back to
the main part of your visualization and
start it all over again now let's move
on and take a look on how to create
parameters and sets so new sheet
and let's make a quick visualization
that we'll apply our parameters and our
sets too
so let's take a look at all of our
customers
by their sales and let's sort customer
name descending by sales great so now
we're going to make a parameter that
will allow the user of the dashboard to
choose how many customers they want to
see how many of our top customers that
they want to see
so let's click this down arrow and click
create parameter
and we will name it
top and customers
great we're going to make it an integer
and we're going to give them the option
to choose the number of customers within
a range our low is going to be 5 so
we'll let them see 5
or up to 20
and we're going to let them skip with
step size of 5. let's start their
current value right in the middle with
10.
okay so now if you want to see how this
parameter looks you can come down to
parameters before we only had dimensions
and measures on the left side of our
tableau workspace but now we have
parameters that has appeared once we
create a parameter we can right click on
that parameter and click show parameter
control and we can see our top end
customers right now our parameter
control isn't built into any of our
visualizations but you can see how it
works we allowed them to go down to five
and
up to
20 with steps of five
great now we're going to create a set a
set is a custom field that defines a
subset of data based on some conditions
so the set we're going to build is going
to be based on customer name so when you
right click on customer name you can
come down and click create hover on
create and create a set with so far when
we created a parameter and a calculated
field you clicked here
with this down arrow and you saw create
calculated field and create parameter
but it's not there a set has to be based
on an existing field so you come and you
click on the field you want it to be
based on and then hover on create and
you see set
so here's how we can create a set let's
name it
top and
customers
by sales so we're going to allow them to
select the top end customers and have
that select our top customers by sales
so we want this set to include anything
that is in the top however many they
defined by the parameter
by sales so you can come over here to
top
and change it to by field we want it to
be top but not just top static 10 we're
going to click here and our parameter
shows up so it's going to be top top end
customers
and then you can choose
another field here
for it to be defined by and it's sales
and we want it to be by sum of sales
if we wanted it to be by
the average profit we can come here and
click profit and change this to average
and now we would see our top end
customers buy average profit
but we want sales and some
okay so we've created our set and we can
drag it onto rows to see how it works
and we can see these are our top 10
customers by their sales and we have
this in slash out
that's generated by our set so if we
take our set
first let's see how this line moves when
we change our number here so right now
it's ten when we move it up we see our
line moves down to include the top
fifteen
and now we can quickly see our top
twenty we'll go back to ten
and let's grab the set and drag it onto
our filters so now we have filtered the
data down to our top 10. if this were
applied to a dashboard this would allow
the end user to see the top 10 quickly
and then maybe expand it out to the top
20 if they're interested in that
information now let's move on to
creating a donut chart so a donut chart
is basically a pie chart with a white
center so um let's start by building a
pie chart which in tableau is pretty
easy especially if you use show me so
let's create a pie chart for each
category
by sales so you're going to click
category and then we're gonna control
click sales so we have them both
selected we'll come over to show me and
click
pie and there we have our pie chart
we'll close show me let's come up here
and click entire view so we see our pi
very clearly here if we wanted to have
one pi for each
region we can take region and drag that
onto columns
so we have one column for each region
and then one pie for each of them you
can see that the pie varies in size
based on sales as well as the angle is
for sales so east has more sales in
general than south
and this helps you to see that
technology has smaller sales in the
south than it does in the east so i
recommend keeping if you're going to
make pie charts allowing the size of the
pie chart to be affected as well as the
angle by whatever measure you're using
but for our purposes for donut charts
we're going to want them to all be the
same size so we took sales off of
size and now we have all of our pie
charts the same size now we're going to
make what's called a dual access chart
and to make a dual axis chart we have to
have two axes so let's grab
number of records and we'll grab it and
drag it to rows and we will change it
from sum to minimum and that's because
every record will have a minimum number
of rows of one and then they all end up
on the same axis great and now we're
going to make a second number of records
by minimum and we can do that by doing
those steps again by dragging number of
records up here and changing it to
minimum again or a quick trick that i
can show you is if you want to
duplicate anything you have on the chart
here you can just hit control and then
click and drag it and it will duplicate
it so if you wanted your number of
records to also be down here onto your
details or on your labels you can
control click it and then leave it there
great so now we have our two axes and we
have our two marks cards that each
affect their own
set of visualizations so let's go to
this top one affects these so let's show
that by changing the size
and it's made these bigger and this
bottom one affects these and we'll do
that by changing it to
circle so now each of these are a circle
let's take category off of color and we
can take some of sales off of detail and
let's change the color to white
and now we're going to put this white
circle on top of our pie chart by
clicking here on our second measure
and clicking dual axis and now it's got
them lined up one on top of the other
and we have our donut chart so we want
our donut
slices to be a little thinner we can
change the size of our inner circle and
make it bigger
perfect and so now we have one pie chart
for each region one donut chart for each
region and if we wanted to take
this header and put it inside of our pie
chart what we can do is take region and
put it on the label for the circle and
it's putting it down here
you can come and edit that by clicking
on label and changing its alignment so
let's put it in the middle
perfect so now we can see
our header here so we don't need it down
here anymore you can right click and
click
show header and it hides that header we
also don't want to see our labels for
our axes so we right click and click
show header there and now we just see
our pies
so to get how the number of sales here
for each of them let's go to
remember our pie marks card and let's
take our sales and add it to label so
now each of our slices of pie can tell
you how much sales they have if you take
the sales here that's on label right
click and click format we can change
that to currency
and let's get rid of our decimal places
perfect now close formatting and let's
say we want the total amount of sales to
be in the middle here with central so we
go back to affecting our circle grab
sales drag it to label
so now we have four doughnut charts
formatted to allow us to quickly see the
sales numbers
for each segment and also for the donut
as a whole you can also change the
colors the tableau selects for each
slice by coming to the marks card that
has color for the pie so category color
and clicking edit colors you could
change it to
any of these automatic ones
where if you double click on one it
gives you all of the options for colors
that you could possibly want there's
also several different palettes you
could choose from so let's say we like
this one and you can just click assign
palette and it will grab those off of
there those look very similar to what we
have already so i'm going to pick a
different one
and click assign palette click apply
and this allows you to make some color
changes and you fit your business a
little bit more
specifically
perfect let's say we make our
pies bigger
crease that size
and we'll also increase the center size
oh not that much perfect
now we'll use a similar technique to
create the two-dimensional pie chart
a two-dimensional pie chart can be used
so that you can show
two pie charts at the same time or a pie
chart that's kind of split up by
different categories this has been
available in some other tools and
tableau can do it too so let's just
demonstrate that we're going to start
again by creating our
generic
category by sales so we'll control click
sales we come over to show me and click
pie and it makes our pie for us it
remembers the colors that you have
determined in other pages so that's a
nice feature again let's make it entire
view so we can see our pie nice and big
and now we're going to
create our dual axis again so we grab
number of records put it on rows and see
how it adds an axis but each one of
these categories has a different value
for the number of records however they
have the same minimum
value for number of records and it puts
them all back onto the same spot great
and then we will control click and drag
to make our two axes
let's come to our top one
and make it bigger
that affected both of them because we
still have sales on size
for both of them
so sales is affecting the size of the
pie chart as well as the size of the
angles so let's take sales off of size
for both of them
and make the second pie chart a little
smaller perfect now let's also affect
our second pie chart by having the color
defined by region instead of defined by
sales let's talk about how i'm replacing
it with region so you could change the
color by dragging region onto color and
that replaces it or let's go back and we
can drag region right on top of the
thing we're trying to replace and it
will replace it there
great so now we have the smaller circle
that's going to go on top split up by
region with the angle defined by sales
and the category is on the top one with
the angle defined by sales let's pick
some nicer colors
maybe we'll use the same palette we used
for
category
this one this one seems right but we'll
pick different ones than those three so
we click on the one we want to change
and click on the color we want to change
it to i'm just going to keep following
this right down
click apply great and then we
put it on top of the other one by
clicking dual axes now sometimes it's
easier to see these when they have a
border so we can come to color we click
border and add maybe some black lines
to allow you to see the inner pie
separate from the outer pie
maybe
our border could have white lines how
does that look
and we can make them both bigger
like we did before
well not that big
and you can also add labels like we did
before
we'll take sales onto our labels here
and you can see that hovering allows you
to see all the information you need now
one more thing so while we like to hide
this axis
we'd also like to maybe hide this grid
line that's occurring so you can click
right click and format and let's go to
our lines
that change that zero line to none
perfect get rid of some of the clutter
on this visualization i still feel like
this outer pie should be a little bigger
and we want to clean up our tool tip so
it doesn't have min number of records in
it this piece should be 100 behind the
scenes so we can come to tooltip right
as you click on it it'll pop up with
everything that's in your tool tip and
we're just going to erase
min number of records i erased too much
you need to leave your angle brackets
okay and now this piece of the pie no
longer has that the inner one let's do
that there too
min number of records remove that right
out
and there you have it a two-dimensional
pie chart and here are our donut charts
this demonstration goes to show you that
even when tableau doesn't have
visualization you're looking for in
their basic show me options you can
still get to it so donut charts aren't
included up here and neither is a
two-dimensional pie chart but without
too much extra work we can make it
happen
these visualizations are a little bit
more complex than your everyday
visualizations and so i recommend going
through this tutorial with the data set
and following along if you want access
to the data set just comment below and
the simply learned team will get back to
you also comment below with any
questions you have
at this point in the presentation we're
going to put together some dashboards so
first let's build our worksheets for
this dashboard we're going to build a
worksheet
called
sales by
year which adds the name up here and
we're going to
take our order date and drag it onto
columns and now we want this to be a
continuous axis so we're going to change
it to our continuous year and now we
have an axis and we're going to look at
sales
so now we have our sales by year if we
want labels on each of these dots we can
drag sales onto
labels and if we want to have different
color lines for each region for example
we can drag region onto color
and that splits our lines up
into the different regions and gives us
a legend over here perfect now we're
going to duplicate this sheet by right
clicking down here and clicking
duplicate now we have sales by year two
let's rename it to
profit
by year
and then let's drag profit right over
top of sum of sales
so that it replaces it with profit now
it's been replaced with profit and all
these different data points are here
however it's still showing the title of
some of sales and that could be very
confusing so always make sure that your
labels are consistent with your data so
let's take profit and drag it over top
of the type labels as well that's more
consistent with our axis
so now we have sales by year and we have
profit by year
let's do a couple of things to clean
these up
like
right click here
go format and we'll change our numbers
to
currency
custom
and now it's marked as dollars
one thing you can do in tableau is let's
undo that
since
sales is going to be dollars pretty much
everywhere we use it we can define our
default property for these numbers so
when we right click on the measure here
you can go to default properties and you
have the options to change the defaults
for any of these things and we're going
to change our number format
change it to
currency custom
no decimal places hit okay and that also
has updated this sheet now that only
works on places where you haven't
specifically defined it to be formatted
differently so we could still define it
to be different here on this sheet than
it is on any other sheet let's do the
same thing for profit
change our default properties
to
the same thing great now let's build our
dashboard
we're going to call this
our
overall dashboard
change our
size
this size is a personal preference of
mine i think it fits nicely on the
laptops that i use and that is used by
most of our customers now let's drag
sales by year now watch what happens
when i drag it on here it brings sales
by year but it also brings the legend
for the region that was created the same
thing should happen with profit by year
it's detected that the same legend is
being used so it didn't bring over a
second legend and we have highlighting
turned on let's see if this works for
both charts we click on central and you
see it highlights central in both charts
that's great so now we have a dashboard
showing us profit by year and sales by
year but let's say we want to be able to
filter this dashboard to just maybe one
category so let's go back to our sales
by year sheet
and let's drag category
onto filters
and now it's going to let us select
we're going to select all
and hit ok and then right click on
category and click show filter so now it
is over here
and we're going to do
a similar thing on profit by year but
we'll do the shortcut where you come
over here to category you right click on
it and you just click show filter and it
puts it here and it puts it here
so now we have
a filter here for category
and a filter here for category
and so when we go to overall
we can come to our
drop down here more options
hover over filters
and you can see category now here's an
interesting thing that we'll see
even though we have a category filter on
both charts when i take furniture out
you can see only sales by year changed
and profit by year stayed the same now
why would that be that's because we have
two different filters for category one
on the sales worksheet and one on the
profit by year worksheet i'll show that
by clicking here
going to filters
and grab category now we have category
that will affect
profit by year and not sales by year
that's not what we want we want one
filter to affect them both so
let's back it up a bit
take these back off let's go to profit
by year now we're going to take off
category let's go to sales by year and
we're going to say we want this same
filter to affect both worksheets so
we're going to right click here hover
over apply to worksheets and click
selected worksheets now we select sales
by year is selected and we select profit
by year okay so when we go to
the profit by year sheet
you can see that it now has category on
there let's go to overall let's come
here
filters category and now we have a
filter
that affects both worksheets
there we go let's format this filter a
little bit we'll come to more options
and we're going to select we want them
to be able to select multiple values
still but let's do it in a drop down
so now
you still have those options but it is a
little bit more compact
let's do
a couple more filters so we can do by
category
let them filter out regions
let's do it the the shorter way right
click show filter there it is
apply to worksheets
selected worksheets
both of these
okay
dashboard
filters and by region
multiple values drop down
and let's let them
change their
time selection so this one's a little
bit different since we've already
determined that we wanted year and we
wanted it to be continuous filters for
continuous
fields are a little bit different than
filters for
these discrete fields and that's because
continuous fields are a range instead of
just a list so we don't list out a
continuous field we make a range for it
so we've already defined that we want it
to be continuous year and if i come over
here
and click on right-click order date and
click show filter it's doing discrete
year by default
so
remove filter if you drag order date
onto filters
it lets you pick what you want it to
look at
let's come up here to year that's
already marked as continuous and click
show filter and now it is year but it's
based on a range and we have this slider
and you can see how that slider affects
our visualization
let me show you a trick to make this
apply to both not a trick but just if
you have not applied it to both
worksheets but you already added it to
the visualization see it's here but it's
only affecting one worksheet you can
change
the worksheets
settings right on the filter instead of
having to go to the worksheet where the
filter exists
and it will only give you the options of
the worksheets that are on the dashboard
so there we have it
now it affects both and now we have our
overall dashboard
now let's say you want to be able to see
the total sales on this chart as well as
the sales split up by
each of the regions we can do that as
well so let's go back to our sales sheet
as a quick tip you can go to the sheet
by clicking this go to sheet button here
or here
in the event that you want to go to a
sheet but you don't want to scroll back
and forth to find where it is so go to
sheet now we're going to do a dual
access chart again like we showed
earlier and i'm going to control
click and drag
so now we have sum of sales twice
this marks card affects the top one so
we can see that by
if i change the opacity
how it changes the color right here this
is the top one
and this marks card is the bottom one
and we're going to remove region
off of color and that makes our combined
one line again perfect now if we want
this to be on the same space as this we
right click here the second measure in
the row section and click dual axis so
let's put it right on top i can see this
versus this now if we wanted to on hover
show that this is overall sales we can
click on tool tip region is missing
because we don't have it with the color
by region anymore so we'll erase that
and put
oh we don't want it to be orange let's
make it black
overall sales okay so when you hover
here it says overall sales so we can see
the difference easily let's make it um a
little bit more of a color that'll stand
out just a little darker than the others
perhaps
so when we go back to our work all right
dashboard we can see sales and we can
see our overall sales let's do the same
thing for profit by year
go to sheet and
control
drag
release
we'll go to our marks card for this
second sheet and pull off region
make it
darker change our tool tip
not orange
overall
profit
okay
and right click
dual axis
there we go now i forgot to do one thing
on the last dashboard when you make a
dual access dashboard it doesn't
necessarily
um sync up these axes and so this axis
over here is for the overall line and
this axis over here is for the region
line
so if we want it to stay that way we
should
edit our axes
and instead of calling it just profit
over here
we will change it to overall profit
and over here
profit
by region
just so that it's clear which access
goes to the which one
or you can come here and click
synchronize axes so it's very clear that
this is much bigger than these
and if you synchronize the axes
let's go back before we named him
okay synchronize the axis then we don't
need both of these headers so we can
come here and click show header and we
just have the one let's do the same
thing on sales by year
synchronize
always good to make sure that your axes
are either synchronized or well labeled
and let's hide it let's see what it
looks like now
great
okay one thing to keep in mind
when we do
filter
to just one region
the lines are going to end up at the
same spot
if we filter to two
then it's only the sum of those two
so
perhaps the header overall sales and
overall profit isn't quite accurate
because it isn't overall necessarily
when we have it filtered um why does
this happen
why doesn't this line always show the
total no matter what you select here
well that's because this filter applies
to the whole dashboard so it filters
this line to those regions just as much
as it filters these lines
so i'm going to remove out that tooltip
line because it could be a little
misleading
let's continue on and make a dashboard
that digs a little bit more into sales
specifically great so we'll make our
first sheet we'll call it
sales by region and we're going to make
another pie chart so
let's do it using show me we'll click on
region
and then we will control click on sales
open up show me click pie
close it again great so now we have the
sales by region pi we'll make it the
entire view and when you hover you can
see that it's showing us sales
in dollar amounts now it would be
more like a pie for it to be percentages
so a lot of pies each of these slices is
shown as a percentage of the whole
at one hundred percent so let's come
here to our slice size we'll right click
on it and we're going to use what's
called a quick table calculation
and change it to percent of total so now
when you hover you can see that the west
is 31
of the pi
great
let's also label each of these slices so
i'm going to control click and drag
region onto label
and add region to the labels i'm going
to undo that and show you what would
happen if i just dragged region onto
labels without copying it without
holding control it will move it
and get rid of our colors and we don't
want that so we're going to control and
drag another way to do this go back is
by taking region and dragging it onto
label just straight from over here but
in this case for the sum of sales where
we've applied the quick table
calculation we want that quick table
calculation to also show up in our label
so i'm going to ctrl and drag and it
brings that quick table calculation
along with it if i were to
undo just drag sales on it's going to go
back to that dollar amount and i'm going
to have to add another quick table
calculation so instead ctrl and drag
that's probably one of my very favorite
tableau tricks great now let's add a
filter for region so i'm going to right
click here and click show filter and we
will make sure that this gets added to
all of our sheets once we've made them
all
okay next sheet we're going to call this
sheet
sales by state
let's do a map great so um one way to
get your map started is to double click
on any of these dimensions that have a
globe next to them so since we want to
go with state we can double click on
state and it starts mapping out state so
what it does is it adds latitude and
longitude to our rows and columns that
are generated here and another way to
get going so let's go back is to click
on the geographic part you want and then
control click on sales like we did for
map sorry for our pie chart come over to
show me and choose one of our maps we
could do it with the circles but we're
gonna do a field map
click on that so now we have our field
map based on state
we can choose one of these different
palettes if we'd like let's try this one
or blue teal
or we could do green so that darker
green means more money
great so now we have all of our states
colored by sales let's also control and
drag sales onto label
and you can see we have the dollar sign
and the money formatting that we made
earlier and let's control and drag state
onto label now maybe we want the state
to be on top so we can click on label
and it pops up with all these different
options and if we want to edit the text
you can click here
on the ellipses
and edit it there so let's cut state
and paste it
at the top there i think i lost my
center alignment so we'll do that again
hit apply see what we think
great okay so now you can see that it
puts the state on top you can also see
in some of these places where they're
super close together that you can't see
all of the state's labels and that's
because um this option here in labels is
unchecked allow labels to overlap other
marks so tableau senses when the marks
are too close together and it's going to
become too hard to read and will hide
anything
that overlaps with each other if we
click this option now you see everything
but it gets a little crowded over here
so let's unselect that and you'll be
able to see what the sales are upon
hover
great now we have our sales by state
for filters for this one let's no let's
right click on sales here and click show
filter so basically wherever you're
using your metrics your dimensions are
your measures you can right click on
them
and create your filters um so now we
could
the lowest amount for a state is 920
for sales for this time period and we
could filter out ones that have sales
lower than that but
i think this isn't what i want let's
remove that filter let's do it for the
state show filter great so now we could
filter out
a state we could just show
arizona
or show them all
excellent let's move on to our next
visualization
new sheet
rename it to be called sales by
sub category
great so we're going to drag on category
onto columns and subcategories of our
hierarchy press plus now we have
subcategory and category and let's bring
on sales it's defaulting to this bar
chart which is perfect that's what i
want and now we could color it by
subcategory and this is a discrete
coloring we could also color it by
sales
and this is a continuous coloring so
the darkest corresponds with the height
now we don't need to do this there is
already an indicator of who has the most
sales and that's based on the bar height
so if we wanted to color it by
subcategory then each one of them gets
their own color we could color it by
category to
add to
the distinction between the different
categories so that's very clear
where they start and stop let's do
by subcategory excellent so now we have
three different dashboards oh let's add
some filters for subcategory so let's
bring on
category as our filter so we'll right
click here click show filter
there's category and let's do a filter
for
our date so we're going to come here to
order date let's drag it onto filters
and let's click years
now these are all the years options
we'll click all and hit ok right click
here and click show filter
so now instead of doing a range where we
could drag that line now we have
discrete filter and so we can check and
uncheck boxes to choose what years we
want to see
awesome let's start with our dashboard
let's call this dashboard
our sales dashboard and
change our size
if you have any questions about
different sizes what's available here be
sure to ask that in the comments below
and let's start with pulling on our
sales by region so last time we pulled
on a chart we saw that it added the
legend for us
but this time you can see it added both
the legends
and the filter so last time we created
the filters after we built the dashboard
but this time you can see that the
filter
gets brought in when we brought in the
dashboard let's do our sales by state
side by side here and let's do sales by
subcategory underneath so i dragged it
you can see how i pull it towards the
bottom of the dashboard and it kind of
fills in the space where it's going to
be
and then brings it in so now it's
brought in all our filters and all of
our legends it defaults to putting the
filters and legends over here we're
going to click select layout layout
container it's going to select what's
what they're all inside of and we're
going to make it take up this whole side
but it doesn't need that much space
so you can see in tableau there's a lot
of dragging there's a lot of dropping
and
a lot of resizing
to get things the way you want them to
be give our map more room
and we have a mixture over here of
legends and
filters let's move our legends out of
there so we can grab this legend and
come and put it on this side
and this legend come and put it over
here
so that we're getting a little bit more
near the visualizations they belong to
this legend goes up here with this one
i'm going to actually click here and
change it from a tiled so right here it
says tiled object to a floating object
that lets it sit on top of a
visualization i'm going to put it on top
of this visualization right up here
excellent and then we have this one
that's showing us the size of sales
that's because on this dashboard it says
that size is determined by sales but
since it's just one
circle there's no size comparison so
it's not like we have several circles
and we have to look and see which one's
the biggest so that we can tell that the
amount of sales so we don't need this
legend and we can just remove it from
the dashboard let's clean up
some of these we have several different
versions of what your filters could look
like so my personal favorite is multiple
values drop down it gives you some of
the most flexibility but if you wanted
them to only be able to select a single
value you could turn it into a radio
button list so that it's a selected all
or it's one at a time
you could also do a drop down or a
slider and make that happen
a slider is a little bit different from
a range on the range you can see that we
could edit either side and it's picking
everything in between but with discrete
values if you say everything in between
it doesn't make a lot of sense because
what's everything between furniture and
technology we don't know that office
supplies goes between those there's no
order so
let's do
multiple value drop downs
for big ones like state there is the
option
of searching so i know i want utah and i
search and there's utah
instead of having to scroll through the
list this could be really helpful for if
you had a filter for by products and
that would allow somebody to look at
just one product at a time if they know
their name of the product but also not
have to just open up the product list
and scroll and scroll and scroll since
there are very a lot of products so we
can filter by region by doing this oh
this is a great reminder you saw that
this did not change all the
visualizations we have yet to apply
these filters to all the worksheets so
let's do that right now apply to
worksheets selected worksheets and we
will click all on dashboard hit ok
we'll do this again
until we have selected them all
right so it's really nice you get to
choose what worksheets you wanted to
apply to because in the event that you
had maybe um a total number up here at
the top that you just wanted to stay the
same all the time no matter what they
selected you could make that happen by
not selecting that worksheet to be
changed by these filters okay great so
we can change what region we're looking
at by selecting central here and then
we're just looking at central throughout
all the visualizations i love looking at
it on a map and seeing just one at a
time it just really makes the region
name just stand out to you but if we
wanted to use this as our filter to
filter the rest of the dashboards we can
click this uses filter button and now
when we click on central here it stays
in context here but the other two
dashboards change
one thing you may notice is that texas
is not the darkest on this chart because
of the scale the scale goes up to half a
million there but then when we click on
central the scale updates just for
what's selected so everything else is
filtered out and now the darkest of the
dark is only a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars and texas becomes the
darkest on the visualization there are
some ways you can change that but if
you're wondering why do my colors look a
little differently when i filter that's
why
great we could also click use this
filter here so if we just wanted to look
at texas we click this this updates to
just central this updates to just texas
down here and unselect
by
clicking on maybe another state or when
you click on the state again it should
unselect and we could do the same thing
here or if we just want to look at one
subcategory and say
let me scroll down a bit storage now
everything updates to the storage it's
interesting i wouldn't have known very
quickly that there are some states that
didn't have any storage sales but now
when we click on storage we can tell i
showed you before that you can control
click and look at binders and storage
and it puts those two together also in
tableau you can drag
and we could select all of these so we
have art binders envelopes fasteners
labels paper and storage and none of
those are getting sold here i don't know
what's up with wyoming
excellent so now we have our sales
dashboard and
let's get started on our next one our
next dashboard is going to be the profit
version of this dashboard so some of
these visualizations we can use again so
let's go to sales by region right click
and click duplicate
rename it to
profit by region
now you have to be careful whenever you
go to reuse a visualization because like
i mentioned before you got to make sure
everywhere
that sales is used you have to replace
it with profit i'm also going to drag
this sheet to be
more at the end here after the sales
dashboard just to keep them separate so
that we have the sheets that lead up to
overall then the sheets that lead up to
sales and then we'll have the sheets
that lead up to profit great so we'll
grab profit and drag it onto angle size
and that updates the angle size drag it
on to the size of the circle shouldn't
make a difference since we only have one
circle and onto the text now when i
dragged it on it didn't do the percent
of total anymore so let's change that to
the quick table calculation of percent
of total for there and for
the label
percent of total there we go now we have
our percent total again by region region
okay here's another thing since we
duplicated that filter it's going to be
using that exact same filter
you see it's using region from sales by
region all the sales dashboards we don't
want that so let's remove out all the
filters here
and these action filters that are
generated by our filtering that those
come from
this
these are called action filters
and it's generated when we click this
uses filter button okay back to profit
by region great we're clear of filters
and let's add back in a region filter
and this one no longer has the icon
that shows you that it affects multiple
sheets which is what we want for now so
you might want perhaps there would be a
situation where you would have two
dashboards and you would want these
filters that you put on here to affect
both dashboards and in this case that's
not what i want great so another one we
can use the basics for is sales by
subcategory so let's duplicate that
great profit by subcategory already
exists we made this earlier
tableau will not allow you to make
worksheet that has the same name as
another worksheet you can
call it number one or since it does put
the title up here you can put an extra
space at the end or it does detect that
space it counts it as a different title
even though it's the same title just
with a space that does cause some issues
so like when we're looking here and
we're saying oh profit by subcategory i
want that oh this is when we made it but
you don't want this one you want this
one and it gets a little confusing the
nice thing is when you're dragging
things onto your dashboard when you
hover you should get a little picture
here of what dashboard what
visualization you're looking at it
really helps you to make your decisions
and not just have to do it by name if
you're a little bit disorganized and you
have all these called sheet 5 sheet 7
you won't know exactly what that is
right away so that little preview is
very helpful great profit by subcategory
we'll do the same thing by removing out
all our filters so i just click on it
and hit delete
you can also control click
and then hit delete or you can drag them
off into a space that's not the
visualization space great and we only
have some of sales right there so we'll
change that to profit
and we have some negative profits there
we'll keep the colors the same for
consistency between the two dashboards
and let's bring on
category as a filter okay
show filter there we are and let's do
our order date filter right now order
date we'll do years okay
all the years so it gives you this
option here because it assumes that
you're making a filter because you want
this dashboard to just be filtered to
your selection you can do that you can
make a filter that isn't exposed to the
end user so let's say you were making a
big dashboard and it was just focused on
furniture then and you don't want them
to be able to select a different
category for because of your analysis
you can make that happen
you can just click furniture and not
show this by clicking hide card here but
in this case we want to be able to make
this interactive
in a lot of different ways great profit
by subcategory exists now instead of our
map we're going to make an area chart
so i'll rename this and call it
profit
over time
by category
so we're going to
bring on our order date into columns and
it goes to our discrete value let's
change it to our continuous value so we
get the axis let's grab our profit onto
rows and it makes this a line chart
we're going to change that to an area
chart an area chart is nice because when
you split it up by category by dragging
category onto color you can now see
what category is responsible for how
much profit like you do with a line
chart however its area is what defines
that so you can see that area over time
and do comparisons and also it stacks
them on top of each other so that you
can tell that for 2013 our profit was
around fifty thousand dollars really
quickly otherwise we have to add that
line this line here and it makes these
lines smaller and lower um more
difficult to see so
back to our profit over time by category
so that's some of the benefits of having
an area chart and if we wanted to go a
little more detailed than here you hit
this plus and now we have over quarter
we have some negative profits that's
interesting but let's go back to over
the year great and for this one we're
gonna make one more pie chart so we
could start from scratch or we could
duplicate our profit by region pie chart
which i'm going to do
we're going to do this for the
comparison between a pie chart and an
area chart so it's going to be profit by
category
but not over time
so right now it's
profit by region let's drag category
right on top of colors there
and now it's split up
it's having some trouble because it's
splitting it by category but because of
we brought region onto text it's also
splitting it by region so we have region
region region region inside of this
category and we don't want that so we're
going to drag category right on top of
region here as well and now it's just
the three segments so whatever you have
in this marks card unless it's on
tooltips will affect your level of
detail in the visualization here when
it's on tool tips sometimes it won't
change the level of detail but it could
have an effect on like so if we brought
oh let's do this right now so right now
the level of detail of this chart does
not go to the category by
region like it did before you can bring
it onto detail here and it won't affect
color and it won't affect labels but it
will change the detail and you see how
it splits it out again this is what it
would look like if it's by region by
category and you have much more slices
to this pie we'll go back but if we take
region and put it onto tool tip it's not
at a low enough level for that tool tip
to make any sense so it's going to put
that star you see region is star that's
because this section of the pie covers
multiple regions if we filtered the
region to just central now it populates
so there are sometimes benefits to
having it in there even when
at all levels it doesn't make any sense
but we won't leave it there
excellent so you can see
how the color is what determines
is a big part of what determines how
many slices you get the level of detail
for the whole chart is a big factor as
well on how many slices you get great
profit by region profit by category by
subcategory and by
profit over time and we have
our category filter we don't have our
subcategory filter yet we grabbed
category but let's right click on
subcategory and click show filter there
we go now we have a filter for category
and subcategory
here's our region one
we have region in two places and we
don't want that
we wanted to apply to all of them we'll
do that when we get to the dashboard
and
we have category your border date and
sub category great those are all the
filters i wanted so let's build our
dashboard
we'll call this our profit dashboard
once i get it set
to the size i want
profit we'll start with profit by
region
and we'll have our profit by category
over time next to it great
we'll give that
some different space have this at the
bottom
have this underneath there
now it's bunched all these up
next to it so let's again drag it over
to the side it's always good to pay
attention to the highlighted section and
it gives you kind of an idea oh you see
i accidentally dragged an individual
filter instead of this whole section so
when i grabbed this i didn't grab all of
these so if you want to grab all of
these and they happen to be inside the
same section you can come and click
select a layout container and now i'm
grabbing all of them there we go
we'll do the same thing as before you
know what i'm going to make these
floating
because then it kind of sits inside of
that same area i'll make that one
floating
and this one too
this category
legend applies to both this chart and
this chart so that's very nice and this
subcategory legend i won't make floating
i'll just put here by subcategory
and this profit by category doesn't need
quite that much space
let's give
our bar charts some room
excellent we don't need the size of the
circles
make these
drop downs now
because i didn't have to on
this chart and this chart change profit
to dollars because we set that as the
default it definitely saved us some time
so
i recommend setting default number
formatting
at the beginning of your visualizations
really nice
excellent now you can rearrange the
order of these so i like to have the
date at the top it's sometimes hard to
get it to the top so i take it the
second to the top and i drag the top one
down and then um category above
subcategory just for logical sense
excellent and we have our profit
dashboard let's see there is this check
box down here called show dashboard
title so if we wanted to have the title
at the top here you can click that
button any floating objects
don't shift down
like everything else did
there we go
so we could have that title we could not
have that title
that's up to you excellent so at this
point we have our overall dashboard that
looks at sales and profit we have our
sales dashboard and we have our profit
dashboard our profit dashboard isn't 100
complete because i forgot to make sure
all of these filters apply to all of
these worksheets so let's go ahead and
do that right now
applied worksheets selected worksheets
all on dashboard
one thing that is nice from this view
it's really nice to click on dashboard
and you only see the ones on the
dashboard but you can click here and say
show all worksheets in workbook
and you can see the rest here so if you
wanted all on the dashboard and you
wanted this one or something like that
then you have the option to see them all
great perfect so before you ever publish
a dashboard it's always good to double
check that your filters work
when you filter to just one
year this area chart becomes a lot less
useful but if you're looking at two or
more
you start to see the shape of it
great
now we're going to take a look at
linking from our overall dashboard
to our sales dashboard
great so we'll go to our overall
dashboard and we'll be creating what's
called an action
so you can make an action
on
a worksheet
you can see right here
actions or on a dashboard actions so
since we're linking between two
dashboards this is going to be a
dashboard action
sorry just trying to unhighlight there
but if you're ever looking for an action
you made and you can't find it look in
the other one great this is our actions
dialog box here we can see the highlight
that has been generated when it says
generated next to it that means that you
didn't come in and define an action it
was made by
clicking this highlight button here
that'll generate an action
or when we look on our sales dashboard
we clicked on this uses filter button so
we should have several actions here that
were all
generated we have a couple different
kinds of actions
when you go to make an action
there's a filter action that we see when
we click use filter a highlight action
that we can see from here in region and
go to url action that we haven't used if
you have any questions about go to url
please post them in the comments below
it basically allows you to be able to
select a url here and so
if you had a dashboard that had to do
with
maybe stocks you could put in a url here
and then put your stock ticker symbol
there so that you could have a url that
would then take you to a finance website
that shows you your stock information it
can get pretty cool okay but we want to
link from this dashboard to one of our
other dashboards and you actually do
that using a filter action so we're
going to name that action go
to
sales dashboard
and we want it to happen when we click
on our sales sheet so you see right here
it shows us the two sheets that are on
this dashboard when we click on the
profits dashboard we don't want this
action to occur this is our go to sales
dashboard now you can have an action
occur on hover
or select you've seen select happen
that's what our filter uses filter
actions use and on menu so we're going
to do it on menu
and the targeted sheets it defaults to
this dashboard saying when i click on
this i want the rest of this dashboard
to update but instead it's going to take
us to our sales dashboard
so when we click on this i want these
sheets to update
now we're going to define what filters
it's going to apply by default it's
going to apply all of the filters based
on what we click so if we click here it
will filter to just 2013 let's say we
click here it'll filter to just 2013 and
it will filter to the region we selected
so
let's see what happens when we do that
okay it's just going to default okay now
when i click on this it's going to
filter to 2013 and west go to sales
dashboard this is where it pops up when
you have it on menu
it's taken us to our sales dashboard it
is filtered 2013 and west
just so you know actions will not affect
these filters here you see that it
thinks all of them are selected because
it creates a separate filter there is
such thing as show only relevant values
for these filters so if we click this it
will filter this to only the ones that
are relevant so we can see that it's
only 2013 that this dashboard is
filtered down to but if we click all
values in the database this filter
doesn't have any only one particularly
selected it does have them all selected
right now
so
we can get here
for that information and to get back
we just need to navigate back to overall
great so it works there
but when we click on this up here
go to sales dashboard
we get a blank dashboard now
that happens because
it's trying to pass region information
to that dashboard
but this doesn't have any region detail
on this line it doesn't know what that
is so it's giving it a bad region value
so let's fix this
go to our actions we're going to edit
our go to sales dashboard and we're
going to select what fields
it'll filter on
we will filter on
our order date
year
and
let me go back to that
we click to order date year and it goes
to the target data source sometimes your
target data source will be a different
data source than the one that you are
using for your source data source now
that gets a little bit complicated right
now we're just using one data source so
that's not something you need to worry
about in a simple visualization like
this
okay and we're going to add one more
we're going to add region
and it automatically selects region over
here but you could select it yourself
let's see what happens here okay
if
one dashboard has region in it and the
other dashboard doesn't have region in
it or doesn't allow you to filter by
region then sometimes you'll get an
error here that will say it's missing
out of your target dashboards
so we don't have any errors so let's see
what happens
so we go to click here
go to sales dashboard what if
we
take out region
remove region and we're just doing it
based on year
okay okay click here go to sales
dashboard and there everything is
so now
it will filter back to the year that you
selected so this is all 2013 but it will
not filter to the region you selected
so even when we come here and we select
west
it takes you to the dashboard but it
doesn't filter it to west
you have to do that yourself
so now we have links
from sales to
sales
let's make one for profit to profit
go to sales dashboard add action
filter
we're going to call this go to profit
dashboard
and we're only going to come from the
profit table to make this happen
let's go to profit and let's select our
fields
we're going to do the same thing
where it's only going to filter it to
the year now you can see oh i started to
type in i didn't show you this before
but you can search text so i started
typing in year and it shows you that
under order date you have all these
different options in this dashboard
right now if you remember we're using
the continuous one that is marked by
the little calendar
so that's it knows it's a calendar date
instead of just
trading it like a discrete field
okay
excellent go to profit dashboard and
there we go this visualization like we
said when it's filtered to just one year
isn't quite as useful but one thing you
can do
is for west here we can select
both years i am i'm going to do it by
control clicking click
click
go to profit dashboard
and now we've got 2015 and 2016. so
that's how you do linking between the
two dashboards if you wanted to be able
to include region as well
you could
put a note in the tooltip for this
that this doesn't work for
region linking from this area it doesn't
work or perhaps you could not have this
total line on the same visualization you
could have a separate visualization that
shows the total or an area chart instead
and that will let you not have this
problem of go to sales dashboard not
linking appropriately so now we're going
to create our final dashboard our
segment dashboard and it's going to use
a parameter in it so we'll get to take a
look at parameters on dashboards
so let's rename this we're going to call
it
profit
and sales
by segment
you don't have to name all of your
dashboards a description of what they
are but it makes it really nice and easy
and it automatically puts it up here but
if you wanted to change this you can
just come in here and name this whatever
you like and then it will just show up
up here so
we could call this segment analysis
click apply or okay and there it goes
that means this and this does not have
to be the same
if we go forward again segment analysis
and profit and sales by segment that
allows you to have some more useful
names down here that make it easy when
you're looking at them side by side but
have a name to match your dashboard up
here great so we're going to
make
a profit in sales it's going to be a
bars and circles chart and we're going
to bring in our segment that we haven't
looked at yet consumer corporate and
home office and then we're going to look
at it segment and we're going to make a
matrix with category and we get to fill
in this space with our
visualizations so we're going to do
sales
and it's going to make these bar charts
so we can see for technology by consumer
by corporate by home office and that is
a matrix of bar charts but we also want
to be able to see profit
and right now it's making two sets of
visualizations but we want just one so
let's dual axis
and it's automatically changed it to
circles also it is not
synchronizing the axis now because
profit is blue and these profit is not
anywhere near the same amount as sales
which makes sense you shouldn't have
profit that's higher than sales so let's
synchronize our axis
and let's change our sales our marks
card over here is associated with sales
and it's nice and easy when the two
marks cards are based on a different
measure
to let you know which one you're
affecting and we'll change that to a bar
and now we have a circle on
a bar chart now if we had profit in
front of sales
you can see how it's behind and you can
fix that by taking it to the back of
sales another way you can fix it
say you wanted the profit axis here over
here for some reason you can right click
on the axis and put mark type or oh move
marks to front
another way to change it
we don't need both of these so let's not
show that header and we don't need this
to be labeled profit because it's for
both of them so the way you get rid of
that is actually you click edit axis
and then you just erase the title
oh and you don't hit reset you just
erase the title
and then you close it
so now no title here but we still have
the axes
and we have three sets of bar charts
across excellent the next chart we're
going to build oh so right now they are
it automatically added the colors based
on measure names measure names is a
dimension that is created by tableau and
it's just what it sounds like we're
coloring it based on the different
measure names one of them's named profit
one of them's name sales and we know
that you can come here click color and
hit edit colors and it will open this
dialog box but you can also come here
and double click on a color pops open
that dialog box let's
pick a palette
let's see
there's a lot of different ones of these
tableau 20
let's pick colors from this palette
profit can be
so you click here make sure it's
highlighted click the color you want
click here make sure it's highlighted
click the color you want hit apply
and then you can come to color and make
it a little more opaque
whatever when you make it more opaque
you start to be able to see through your
circles there are benefits but also
drawbacks to doing that
anyway
so stick with the tableau orange blue
great we have our first chart our next
chart is going to be called
top
customers
buy sales and this is where we're going
to use our parameter where we made our
top end customers so
let's bring in our sum of sales make a
bar chart for that and then we're also
going to we're bringing in our set now
so we have our in and our out we're
gonna break up our set
by our segment as it's part of our
segment analysis and we'll bring in our
customer names
and let's sort it excellent now you can
see that when we sorted it it didn't
take this big guy and put it all the way
at the top it just sorted it each within
its own section great and so here we
have our in and out and that's not a
super user-friendly title for
our users of this dashboard they're like
in and out of top end customers by sales
maybe we want this to say something a
little bit more user friendly so let's
make a calculated field and we're going
to call it the top and customers
label
and we're gonna go and say if
and we're gonna use our set top end
customers by sales and since it's an in
their outset it treats this like
if it's in top end customers by sales
then
top
we're going to
do a string so it's going to be top and
then we want to use the number that's in
our parameter so we have to convert it
from a number to a string and we have to
concatenate them together in tableau you
can use a plus sign top and always make
sure you have space between what you're
concatenating together that's something
that i tend to forget
top space customers so if they pick 20
it'll say top 20 customers
so if it's in this set then top blank
customers
else if it's not in the set we will just
call it other and in tableau you always
need to end your if statement with an
end here it tells us our calculation is
valid while we're here i want to show
you a little trick there's this arrow
button here
that can give you all of the different
functions that are available within
tableau
and it even sorts it out by different
categories so if we didn't know how to
make this into a string we could go to
type conversion we could click on string
and it gives you an example also when
you click on
function in here did you see how it's on
date and then i clicked on string and
i'm like what does this do click on it
and it tells me so this makes it really
useful inside of tableau also in tableau
you can make a comment in here so if
somebody's like what's going on here you
can press dash dash or
slash slash and type in
this is a more user-friendly
title hit okay and there we go we have
our more user-friendly title we drag it
here we see our top 20 customers and
other and we don't want to show this
anymore but we still want it in place
you can click right click on it up here
and click show header and it hides it so
that in out is still happening there and
let's drag it to our filters and there
we have it we have our top blank
customers and it tells you right there
how many and we need to come here to
parameter right click and click show
parameter control and that's how we can
control
these changes so let's set it to 10 at
first and we have it our top customers
by sales but it's interesting to know
profit as well so we have really big
sales but how is their profit doing so
let's draw profit on color and you can
see this person has a negative amount of
profit despite their big sales so that's
important for us to know and we can
change our color like we did previously
to go from
red to blue
and we can
change our center to zero
and now we can see the negatives really
quickly
now they're not the only one neither
have a negative profit but some of our
highest sales that's great to know
excellent those are our visualizations
for the segment dashboard so let's talk
about filters really quick we have this
filter we won't show the filter itself
we don't want to allow them to
show in or out we just are going to
allow them to show how many but we do
want to be able to have them filter by
category so let's show that filter and
by segment
show that filter and and then we'll have
our parameter great let's make our
dashboard
um automatic as you probably read right
there the dashboard will resize to fit
any screen it is displayed on that can
be really handy especially
if your visualization is really dynamic
and can change however some
visualizations like this visualization
for example if it gets too squished you
stop being able to read things very well
so automatic has its definite
pros and cons
so we're going to bring on our profit
and sales by segment and it already pops
up with its
legend
and total customers
by sale and it pops up with its legends
and filters and it pops up with its
parameter now i'm going to close that
and be like if you don't see your
parameter when you first bring it in the
parameter is affecting this sheet and
you can go to parameters and find it but
parameters are
workbook wide meaning that it's going to
exist over here too
it doesn't affect this sheet however
it's still going to show up there
because
it could affect it is available for any
sheet and it's the same there is no
determining what worksheets this affects
this will affect any sheet that it is on
so if i i've changed it to 10
and if i come down here and go back to
the other visualization that uses it
this is why i should name my sheets
let's see if i can find it
nope
here we are sheet 13. in sheet 13
we have our top 10. so i've got a 10 and
i've got a 10 over there and if i change
it to 20
and i go back to my segment dashboard
it is also changed to 20. so it will
affect all sheets always very important
to know great so here's our
visualization
here are some of the more useful legends
so
let's
make this floating and put it over by
the visualization it matters for we can
do the same thing here floating right up
here floating does not work very well
for if you were to make this an
automatic dashboard so that the size
changes all the time because floating
could end up right on top of your
visualization and keep you from being
able to see what you need to see
and let's make these affect
all the dashboards in the workbook
again we don't have to do this for our
parameter
it will already affect all the
dashboards in the whole
workbook
and
format these
another thing you should know is that
there are more formatting options for
these including edit title so it's
already named it category automatically
but if you had
like here oh this is a great example
edit title top end customers and you
could change it to
select
number of top customers
or something like that
give it a little more space
and yeah these floating ones do not
shift when you shift things so it's
always good to double check your
floating legends
and this is a little bit more user
friendly
than the title we made for the
developers
and that's using parameters in a
dashboard
today in this video we learned about an
overview of business intelligence on
tableau we talked about how to install
tableau public and how to connect to a
data source
we also talked about creating calculated
fields like this one
we talked about making sets and
parameters we learned how to make a
donut chart
and a 2d donut chart we learned about
making dashboards
and adding filters to those dashboards
and we also learned about connecting
between dashboards welcome to tableau
training part two we will be learning
about the topics we discussed in part
one live versus extract data sources
we'll talk about joins and unions and
we'll look at table calculations we'll
look at the rank functions and we'll
look at actions specifically url actions
we'll talk about reference lines and
bands we'll look into some insights in
the data such as delay analysis also
we'll learn how to build a waterfall
chart and then finally we will learn
about level of detail calculations while
making two different visualizations
in part one of this tableau training we
introduced tableau basics and we learned
how to create
donut charts and two-dimensional donut
charts and we learned about linking
between dashboards now let's discuss the
difference between a live connection and
an extract connection first it's
important to note that these different
types of connections are not available
in tableau public it's always a live
connection and a live connection is
where the data will update based on when
the source of the data updates so if any
if you're connected to a database and
something in the database changes then
you'll pick up those changes when you
open the report as it will query that
database when the report is opened
whereas an extract connection
is extracted into creates a subset of
the data that improves performance so
when you're looking at it locally on
your computer you have an extract of
that data set that subset of the data
right on your computer or up in tableau
server depending on where you're looking
at it and it does not update
when the database updates it only
updates when your refresh updates it so
without a refresh set for that extract
you won't get the new data as an example
of this let's say
that in our
sample superstore we have kelly williams
associated with the central region but
that's changed so let's go ahead and
change that
we will change it to
sarah smith
and
we'll save it
now let's go back to our tableau
workbooks
and you can see we can refresh it over
here and see sarah smith come in
over here in our extract
it sarah smith doesn't come in
if we click to refresh the extract it
doesn't refresh the extract until we
navigate to sheet 1
but when we go back to our data source
then we see sarah smith coming in so
that refresh can be scheduled and it
could run once a day
or once every several hours
but you would need to set up a refresh
or else you would never get sarah
smith's data coming in
next let's talk about joining data in
tableau so here we have the people table
but let's say we want to join it to our
orders information so i'm going to start
with our orders table
and then we're going to pull on people
and tableau is going to
create a join for us and it's going to
choose the column that we would like to
join on based on the names in the two
data sources so if these two data
sources didn't have a column that had
the same name then tableau wouldn't be
able to guess
what
two to join on
so we would have to come in and select
out of the order side
and the people side
what we'd like to join on and then we
have the options to do an inner join a
left join a right join and a full outer
join let's review quickly what these
look like so say we had two tables that
we wanted to join together one of them
was the student table that had the
student names and the key
to their grade
and which we could use to look up their
grade over here in the grade table which
had the key to their grade and the
actual grade a b c d f and incomplete
we can see here that somebody has made a
mistake and put in a letter grade
instead of the key to the letter grade
and we'll see how that affects what
we're looking at
so if we were to do an inner join
that would only take
the rows where the join could complete
so
we have one that could join to one just
fine but we don't have two and we don't
have three a doesn't join to anything so
this row would be
not included and then four
five and six would all join so that
would look something like this where we
would see adam
when we grab student from this table and
grade from this table we can see adam
had an a beverly had an a dale had a d
elizabeth had an f and frank is
incomplete and charles is missing also
you don't see
any b or c in this list of grades
for a left join
it's going to take everything
from the left table
and only the pieces from the right table
that apply to the left table so it looks
pretty similar to our inner join
only charles shows up so the join wasn't
able to complete since a doesn't exist
in grade but we include charles anyways
and grade becomes null
for charles it won't put in the grade
key because it's we're not asking for
the grade key we're asking for grade
from the grade table so we try to look
up a inside of the grade table we can't
find it and never tolerance no we look
up a inside the great key perfect right
join is like a left join only it takes
everything from the right table instead
of the left table
so it grabs all the grades a b
c d f and incomplete and only the rows
from the left table that
join appropriately
so since charles doesn't join
appropriately he doesn't show up we also
have b and c showing up
even though it doesn't exist in the
student table
and it won't be tied to a student
because that join wasn't able to
complete as it didn't exist over there
and the last one is a full outer join
where it takes everything from both
tables
whether or not the join is complete so
we have all of the people where the join
completes we also have charles where the
join doesn't complete from the left to
the right and we have b and c where the
join doesn't complete from the right to
the left
so those are our options in tableau
here
in our sample superstore data set
you could look and see if there are any
regions in the orders table that don't
exist in the people table and that's how
you can know what kind of join you want
and so if you want those orders to still
show up even though they don't have a
region
or their region is not in
the people table that's when you would
do a left join
for our purposes
we'll do an inner join
now let's say
we had a second
excel sheet here
that had more
orders and you can do a union
which is just adding more orders
by dragging that second orders table
right underneath the original orders
table you can see it says their drag
table to union and that's helpful for if
you have an excel sheet for maybe
different years so say you had a
separate excel sheet for the orders in
2015 and then another one for the orders
in 2016. you could pull on your 2015
orders and then drag your 2016 orders
right there to union and it would take
these orders and then
add the rows instead of the columns
for the 2016 orders
for example we've added people
but as a join and that will
first put in all of our orders
as columns and then add the columns for
our person
but if we were adding more data that
fell under the order
columns so it would have the same data
the same order id ship date but we
wanted to add more rows then that would
be when you union
now we're going to take a look at
calculations and which ones are
calculated on the database side versus
which are calculated on the table side
so here we have percentage of total
sales split up by subcategory and
category
we also have
percentage of total sales along table
down so the difference between these two
things are one of them is made using a
calculated field
which is where we do the sum of sales
divided by the sum of fixed sum of sales
this part is called a level of detail
calculation
and this calculation the sum of sales
and the sum of the level of detail of
sales
which basically makes
the database find the total
sum of sales regardless of
these dimensions we pulled on
so it gives us our total number so this
will be sum of sales for bookcases and
this will be sum of sales for everything
this calculation is done on the database
side whereas this one percentage of
total sales along table down is what's
called a table calculation
it's a quick table calculation of
percent of total and it is done
in tableau
it's processed locally right inside of
the table after the aggregations have
occurred
there are some pros and cons of doing it
this way
so
for
this percent of total sales
i had to create the table calculation
here and it does the fixed
sum of sales where it finds the sum of
sales for the entire database
and since it is fixed it will ignore
filters so for example
i took off both of the sales and i'm
just going to put on the percent sum of
sales and let's say we wanted to see
how office supplies and technology are
as percentages of sum of sales
and ignore furniture so we can grab
category and we'll control
click and drag
and we're going to unselect furniture
and hit ok
now it's still
taking it out of the total sum of sales
including furniture and so our grand
total down here is only 67 percent
instead of 100 percent
whereas
if we take
sales
and double click it and adds it over
here on the table then we right click
and do a quick table calculation
and click
percent of total
this one is doing it out of 100 and
these numbers don't match
and that's because it does take into
account the filter of category so let's
pull the filter category off and we can
see that they're both out of 100 now and
each of these take into account
um
the same amount of data since we have no
filters here
so if you wanted to take into account
the filters on the table
then you need to use a table calculation
however when you push the information
back to the database to do the
calculation it's doing it as part of the
query to the data source and it can save
you some time and so which one of these
is faster sort of depends on
what data is available already when the
original query comes back
next we're going to discuss ranking in
tableau
first let's add a second data source so
we can do that by coming up to data and
clicking new data source
or you can just click this plus data
source right here and click microsoft
excel
we're going to use this rank example
worksheet
perfect and it's already pulled in the
sheet we want because there's only one
sheet
and we'll go to sheet2
pull on store
pull on sales
and we will rename sheet2
as
rank example
great so now we have here's all of our
stores and here are our sales and if we
wanted to rank them
based on who had the highest sales to
the lowest sales we could create a
calculated field
called ranked by sales
and we're going to use our rank
function and we're going to put in sales
now we receive this error here so when
we hover
we see what that arrow says oh you can
click and it says all fields must be
aggregate or constant when using table
calculation functions or fields from
multiple data sources so we learn
something unique here
that you might not know is that a rank
is a table calculation
and it requires it to be aggregated
so
we can make sum
and put the parentheses around sales
and our error goes away so now we know
rank is a table calculation
and we have our box here that expands
out and can teach us about what we're
using here so when i click on rank it
will tell us that it returns the
standard competition rank for the
current row
and it says identical values are
assigned an identical rank so let's see
what that looks like we'll hit ok
we'll double click on rank by sales
and we can see our ranks so e had the
highest sales so it's one
d is next and c and b are tied
20 and 20
and so they both share the rank of three
and then because they are two of them
that share the same rank we skip four
and the next one gets fifth place
but now this isn't the only way to rank
so let's make another one of these we'll
click duplicate
and edit
let's erase copy
and we're going to call this rank dense
by sales double click on rank start
typing rank again and we're going to
click rank dense
now the difference here is that
rankdents returns the rank where
identical values are assigned an
identical rank but no gaps are inserted
in the numbers
so click ok double click rank dense and
you can see instead of going one two
three five
it goes one two three four
so it doesn't include that gap now let's
give them a little bit more space here
and maybe i want it to be in the order i
created it so these measure values are
defining what's going to happen up here
so we can take sales and put it at the
top
and that'll move sales to the front and
put ranked dents at the bottom so now we
can see sales we can see rank by sales
we rank dents by sales
now let's duplicate
and
look at the next one
we have rank
modified
next
and
change the name here you notice that i
receive an error
and that's because that name already
exists tableau won't allow you to use
the same name
and it will give you that error so those
errors can be pretty helpful in finding
out what's going on hit apply
and okay and then double click rank
modified by sales
and now we can see
the difference here
let's go back here and
look at what it says here click on rank
modified and it says it returns the
modified competition rank where
identical values are assigned an
identical rank
but
what happens instead
is instead of both receiving three
for third place they both receive four
which is the lower of the options so if
we were going by rank and we just
arbitrarily decided that this one's
third place and this one's fourth place
then they both receive the same rank
here but they receive the higher of the
two options whereas this one receives
the lower of the two options
and let's do one more
duplicate
edit
erase copy
and we're going to do
rank
unique
and let's change the name
to rank unique
perfect and now this is going to give it
a unique
ranking even when they share the same
number so we'll hit
okay double click rank unique
and we have one two
three four and five
so what it's doing is
let's quickly look here so
rank by sales
we haven't talked about this yet but you
can choose to rank it ascending or
descending that means that do we want to
rank it based on
whether you see here it says ascending
or descending and that's how you will
define so right it defaults to
descending and it's saying the biggest
is the best
so
in for sales that's accurate so what
it's doing is biggest down now here it
has to decide which one to give three
and which one to do for
and it's doing that based on the ascii
values
of the store
so it's looking at more information on
the row and since uppercase b comes
before lowercase c uppercase b is
getting the three
even though they both have 20 for sales
let's go back now to our orders data
and we'll make a new sheet
and now we're going to talk about
actions in tableau we've talked about
actions briefly before
in our tableau training video for
beginner so if you want to see the
introduction you can go and look there
also if you want to follow along with
our data sets you can comment below and
ask and the simply learn team will get
you that data set
so let's make a chart where we're going
to look at
category so we'll drag category onto
columns and then we're going to look at
sales so we'll drag sales onto rows and
it will create three bar charts for us
and we're going to
call this
sales by category
now let's make a second chart that we
will use together and we'll bring
category onto columns and we'll bring
subcategory onto columns
and let's bring sales
onto rows again
and let's
take
subcategory and bring it on to color and
that makes each subcategory its own
color and we'll call this sheet
sales by subcategory
so now back to sales by category here
you can make a worksheet
action where we're going to
move from the sales by category sheet to
the sales by subcategory sheet and also
filter down that sheet to only the
category we want to see
so click filter
and we can name this filter
go to subcategory
and we're going to do this filter on
select so this name won't be seen except
for in our actions list and what sheets
do we want to affect we're going to have
sales by category show up one thing to
note here it is only showing the sheets
for it to affect based on the ones that
are using this data source at this point
so you can see we have four sheets down
here but it's only showing three sheets
and that's because rank example if you
recall is using the rank example data
source so you can click here and you can
see all the sheets or you can see the
other
data source if we click rank example it
will show the rank example data source
so we just want sales by category to be
the source sheet
and the target sheet we want it to be
sales by subcategory
so on select we want it to be sales by
subcategory we're going to use all the
fields available
to create this filter and hit ok so now
we have our go to subcategory on select
we'll hit ok again and
let's
make this a little wider so we can see
and so when we click on furniture it
will take us to only furniture of
the sales by subcategory we go back to
category we click on office supplies now
we just see office supplies
and this is
a way to make tableau drill to a lower
level
great so we have those
now let's
duplicate this sales by category sheet
and let's see if we go to worksheet and
we go to
actions
you can see that we have the action here
go to subcategory that still exists on
our duplicated sheet as well so you can
see it's affecting both sheets
sales by category and sales by category
2. let's say we don't want that and we
can
unselect sales by category 2.
and hit ok
and hit ok
now when we go to worksheet actions
you can tell that it's not affecting
that sheet so if we come and click
technology nothing should happen but we
go to sales by category and click
technology it'll take you to the
technology subcategory
great so we have our sales by category
two let's bring it to the end
rename it
we're going to call it sales by category
stacked
because we're going to take subcategory
here and drag it onto color
and now we can see our different
subcategories
in the colors there
now we can take a look
here
and sort by
subcategory based on some of sales
and now you can see that
it is the biggest sales at the bottom
for each subcategory that's just
a way that i like to view it so
let's do a highlight action and we're
going to do it on a dashboard
so let's take
sales by
subcategory
and look at it over top of our sales by
category stacked over top of sales by
sap category so we want both of those
let's make our
dashboard automatic for
testing purposes
and we'll go to dashboard we'll click
create actions so we're going to add an
action it's going to be a highlight
action
highlight sales by subcategory
and we are going to have the
sales by category stacked be the source
sheet and the sales by subcategory be
the target sheet for all fields okay
okay and on select you can highlight
your chart there
and see where it falls inside of the
other visualization
a cool thing you can do is you could
select office supplies here and it will
highlight all of office supplies
or if you drag
and select a couple of them it will show
you those so you're just like i want to
see all these small ones or i want to
see
this one and these small ones or
whatever then it will highlight the ones
that you drag and select now this is
also true of our sales by subcategory
and sales by category so when we clicked
on technology it filtered to just
technology
and we'll undo that and when we drag and
click
office supplies and technology we get
office supplies and technology now if we
go back to the dashboard we can see that
this dashboard is now filtered also to
office supplies and technology and
that's because we're using the same
sheet
and when you navigate away from that
sheet it doesn't mean that your filter
goes away
so when i clicked undo that's when it
caused the filter to go away so
if you're going to have two
things affect that sheet just remember
that just because you navigated away
from what you selected doesn't mean that
what you selected goes away that filter
will stay there and it shows up right
here
and if we pull it off everything goes
back to normal however the action is
still there so when you click on it it
comes back
now let's take a look at the last kind
of action which is a url action
so we're going to make a map based on
state so i'm going to double click state
and it's going to build out my map let's
change it to a field
map
by clicking map up here
and we're going to take sales and put it
onto color so now it's colored based on
the darkest is the highest sales
we're going to put state onto label so
you can see the state name and we're
going to put sales onto label
so we can see the sales amount let's
quickly
change our default property for sales
so that it always shows up as currency
now we're gonna
lose the decimal places
so it'll by default show up with a
dollar sign and
so on
great so now we have our sales map and
we're going to create
a worksheet action now the difference
between a worksheet action and a
dashboard action is that a worksheet
will only affect the worksheet and
dashboard will only affect the dashboard
and so when we created our worksheet
action on sales by category if we were
to pull sales by category onto the
dashboard that action won't transfer
over you'll need to make a dashboard
action
so we're going to make a go to url
action we're going to have it on menu
we're going to call it wiki
and it's going to only affect
our new sheet
sheet 6 which we should rename and we're
going to have a url in here so this will
take us to wikipedia and then whatever
you put at the end of the wikipedia link
it will take you to that page on
wikipedia so
we're going to take state and add it to
the end of that link
and now to test the link you can just
click test link
and it will take a random value and show
you what it will look like
so now that's how we know that we have
our link set up
okay click okay let's rename our sheet
to
url
filter by state
and so when we click on texas
okay back to url filter by state let's
go to our worksheets and go to our
actions and on the go to sub category
it is also affecting this url filter by
state because we didn't unselect it now
to keep that from being a problem we're
going to just come here and sales by
category be the only sheet and that way
it won't auto select no sheets as you
create them
so we'll no longer have that problem you
click on text and nothing happens except
for it highlights that one only that's
how it should be but when we hover
around texas and wait long enough oh
yeah on click sometimes you just have to
hold still it'll come up with our little
link here and we click on wiki and it
will open up
our browser with the wikipedia page for
texas this can become really handy in
the event that you have data that maybe
has an order id and you can take that
order id and insert it into a url in
your system so that it can take you to
your web interface page for that order
here it's helpful for if we wanted to
learn more about the state of california
which
it can have information about the
languages spoken
and
population which can be helpful when
we're looking into our sales information
another way this can be useful is by
showing the web page right inside of
tableau so let's make a dashboard
change our size to automatic and let's
pull in url filter by state
if we go to dashboard actions you can
see there are no actions for this
dashboard yet so we're going to add a go
to url action on select
and since it's on select the name of
this url won't
show up
but it will show up in our list here so
it's nice to me with something unique
let's put in our wikipedia page and
it'll take us to state so we'll hit okay
okay and now when we click on oklahoma
it'll open up a page for oklahoma
but let's unselect oklahoma if we drag
on web page from the objects here
you don't even have to enter anything
for your url you just hit ok and now we
have the bottom half of the screen is a
web page and when we click on oklahoma
instead of taking us to oklahoma in a
separate thing it'll take us to oklahoma
right here
in the visualization so we'll change it
to texas and this will change to texas
if you unselect it leaves the page there
based on the one that you had just
selected
next we're going to take a look at
reference bands and lines so let's make
a new sheet
and we're going to call it
reference
lines
and so a reference line is found on the
analytics pane
and it is something that comes and draws
a line on your visualization based on
the data on the screen so
let's make
our visualization we'll do our category
and subcategory again
and we'll double click on sales
and it brings it onto text so that's not
what i want so let's do sales onto rows
and we have our bar charts
and
we'll talk about the difference between
a cell a pane and the table so when we
go to analytics
and we code to drag our reference line
onto
our visualization it says you can add
the reference line for the whole table
for a pain or for a cell
so
if we
take our subcategory and drag it onto
color
since the subcategory is our lowest
level it's going to define our cell
so each one of these if we drag our
reference line onto
so
each one of them gets a reference line
you see how it added those on this is
our dialog box we will look at that in
just a moment
so let's remove that if we take
reference line and put it onto pane
that's going to be similar to having
category on a color so each of these
different colors
is now a pane
reference line onto pane and you see how
we get reference lines
based on each pane
so let's undo that
and now if we take category off and
everything is all one color and we take
reference line and put it onto table
now we have our reference line for the
whole table
great so we're going to do
find out the average for each
section
so i'm going to take category and put it
back onto color and we'll take reference
line and put it onto pane
now we have our reference line it's
based on the computation of average
and it's using the value of sum of sales
so since it says sum of sales here you
might think that it is taking the cut
reference line and putting it at the sum
of the sales but that's not what's
happening it's just using our aggregated
version of sales to figure out the
average so instead of taking each
individual sale
that makes up the bookcase section it's
taking the sum of sales for the bookcase
section and comparing it to the sum of
sales for chairs
so it's taking an average across these
added up sections
we could also have it be
total
where it's adding all of these up and
that makes that total line
the sum line is the same as total in
this case a constant which is where you
get to define the value and so if we
wanted it to be 200
000 there it is
let's go back
there we are back to where we were
constant minimum which shows you the
minimum for each section
the maximum for each section
or the average
or the median
so let's stick with average and now you
can see it's labeling the line as
average we could also have it label the
line as the value so now we can see that
the average is this amount of dollars
or you can choose custom and then you
can put something in here
like maybe we wanted the computation a
colon
and then the value
average this amount
you can also have a show recalculated
line for highlighted or selected data
points that means when you click on a
section it will recalculate the average
just for what you've selected we'll hit
ok
and so in that case when we click on
tables
you can see our
recalculated average line
so the average for tables for just
tables
is the sum divided by the number so the
sum of tables is 206 966 divided by 1 is
still 2 6 96 so selecting just tables is
really helpful but if we wanted to know
the average of
tables and we'll control click
appliances and we'll control click
binders oh there we go all three of
those are selected we can see the
average of those three which is this
line
you could also select like this
and see your new average oh and it's
doing the average
independently so
select these guys and now we see the
average of just those
five categories and those are reference
lines now let's duplicate this sheet
and i'll show you how to delete a
reference line
so we'll rename this to reference
bands
click on this reference line
right click and click remove and it
takes it off we have the same thing for
reference bands we had with reference
lines where you can have it be for the
whole table per pane or purcell so let's
do a reference band for the whole table
so it's doing entire table
and it's taking from the minimum to the
maximum now we could change the minimum
to be the average to the maximum and now
that will highlight the whole table
everything that's above the average
becomes highlighted
and if you wanted to change it you could
do the minimum
to the average
but let's go to
average to
maximum and then you can change things
like you can add lines so we have a line
for the average the maximum you can make
it thinner you can make it dotted
you can change your fill so maybe if you
don't want it to be quite that dark you
can change it to be a little bit of a
lighter color of gray
and you can have show recalculated band
for highlighted or you can remove that
and that way when we highlight stuff
everything just stays where it belongs
for the entire table
and that's how you create a reference
band
reference bands and reference lines can
be really handy in making
several different kinds of
visualizations such as bullet charts
if you have any questions about that
please comment below and the simply
learn team will get back to you now
let's do another analysis on average
days to ship
and for this one we're going to
look at it by state
and we're going to look at it by
ship mode
and so we'll take average stasis ship
and put it on columns
and now we can see
the average days to ship by first class
same day second class or standard class
and you can see
how they differ so let's
change the order of these really quick
if we come up here to ship mode and we
click sort and we click manual we can
have same day above first class so that
it kind of goes in order of priority so
same day first class second class
standard class
there we go and now we have it in
order of what you might expect and
priority and now we're going to create a
calculated field that we will use to do
a sort of conditional formatting
and we will name it delay analysis
great so let's do
if
the
average days ship
is less than or equal to 2
then
we'll have it return the words
shipment early
so
if we want to press enter there that
won't cause any problems to our
calculation so you can press enter you
could have extra spaces and it won't uh
tableau will ignore those so this allows
us to format our calculated field in a
way that's easy to read so if it's less
than two then they're gonna call it an
early shipment
else if
average days to ship is greater than or
equal to five
then shipment
late
and else if let's get the rest of them
and
average days to ship is
not less than two
greater than two
and less than
five
then
on time
two words
on time
and now you can see we have an error
here
it says expected end to match if that
means that we don't have an end
at the end of our if statement
if statements always have to have an end
okay let's hit apply
and let's grab our delay analysis and
put it onto color
and it has on time as blue
early shipment as orange
and shipment linked as red
we can double click on the color and we
can change shipment early to green
and now we can see
the best ones the on time ones and the
ones that stand out as late
and standard class happens late a lot
it's interesting to see that on average
the district of columbia
has second class as a legit late
shipment
you can see that all of these
share
the same axis size so they all go from
zero to six
even though this one never gets that
close to six
if we click edit axis
you can choose if you want that to be
the case so it's like right now all of
them use uniform axis range for all rows
and columns and that's really nice
because it's easy to compare
colorado to colorado to colorado if you
change it to independent axis for each
rose you can see now this one only goes
from zero to not even one whereas this
one goes from zero to six and you can
compare it with color but you can no
longer compare it with size across all
of these different categories so uniform
access range is the default in this
case and we will keep it that way
so now we have a quick analysis of our
delays
we're now going to build a waterfall
chart
based on profit
so we'll call this our profit
waterfall
and we'll take a look at what a
waterfall
looks like at the end and talk about how
it works
so after we build it we'll talk about
some of the benefits of having a
waterfall chart so what we're going to
do is build it over time for this
visualization we're just going to look
at the year of 2014
so i'm going to filter it to the order
dates for 2014
and then we're going to take our order
date and bring it onto columns and we're
going to look at it by month but we're
going to look at it by
our discrete month
so you can see that i chose the one that
has month and year
and then i chose discrete
and then we're going to take profit and
put it onto rows
and we're going to change it from
profit
to
our
running total of profit
so you can see that it takes january and
then it adds february to it
and so it's always getting bigger when
we undid it sometimes there's up and
down
so
back to we only have our running total
where it will some january and february
for the february mark and then some
january february march for the march
mark
if i take profit
and put it here you can see january is
negative three thousand and february is
positive two thousand but here it's the
sum of those which is negative 467.
take that back off we're going to change
our marks to a gaunt bar
and now we're going to
duplicate profit
and edit what we have
we're going to call this negative
profit
and it's going to be just profit
with the negative sign in front
oh it looks like i've done this before
so
now we have a new name because i added a
space at the end so hit apply
and let's
delete the old one
okay so now we have our negative profit
just to look at it it's just minus
profit
and we're going to use that to determine
the size
of the gaunt bar
so
what it does
is it takes where the line was and it
adds the size of it to be the size of
profit but because the line was at the
top and we didn't want to build the
profit up we had to change it to
negative profit so it would build it
down
so here the line was down here because
it was so low negative and we added
negative profit and then let's take
profit and put it on color
and so you can see where profit is
negative it turns it orange
and when profit is positive it turns it
blue so what's happening here what we
can do now is we can see our total sales
at the end and how we got there so for
the first month we were at zero when we
started and we went down to negative
three thousand the next month we were at
negative three thousand when we started
and it grew up to be almost back to zero
and then we can see that from there on
out we grew up
each month and you can see how much each
month contributed
our biggest contributors are november
and march november being a little bit
bigger
and you can see where we started at the
beginning of that month and where we
ended and that's how a waterfall chart
works so it lets you go through over
time and see exactly where our problems
were
and exactly which months helped the most
where we started and where we ended for
each month
next we're going to talk about level of
detail calculation and we'll talk about
those first by showing an example
so i'm going to bring all my customers
on
by name and then i'm going to bring on
order id
and it's going to add all members but
then i'm going to change order id
from a dimension to
a measure and we have account distinct
so now we can see each customer and how
many
orders they have so let's sort it and we
can see one person has 17 orders
and we have
1 2
3 4
5 6 7
people have 13 orders
and it goes on from there
uh so what if we wanted to make a
visualization that would show
how many customers
had how many orders and what
number of orders was the most popular
we would need to do a level of detail
calculation so let's clear the workbook
a level of detail calculation allows you
to build a visualization
and bring on metrics that are at a level
that is different from what's shown on
the visualization
so
in order to do this
we need to
create a calculated field
that will show us
the number of orders per customer
even though we're not going to have our
visualization be per customer so let's
call this orders
per customer
and we'll come here and we're going to
use a level of detail calculation called
fixed
now there are
two other level of detail calculations
and they are called include
and exclude
and you can learn more about those
in
some of our simply learning classes and
if you have any questions please comment
below and we can answer them so we're
going to do it fixed
and you can choose
dimensions and it computes an
aggregation using only the specified
dimensions
so it will ignore all the other
dimensions and we're going to have it
based on customer name
so we're going to have fixed customer
name
and we're going to call
get account distinct
of order id
and make sure you close it with your
curly bracket and we have no errors and
we'll hit ok
and this allows us to see number of
orders per customer so
let's pull it out
first let's make it a dimension
and then pull it out onto our columns
and now we can see
1 two three four five six seven eight up
to 17. so that means we had
some customers just order one and some
customers ordered 17 and we had them
order everything in between so if we'd
never had a customer that had nine
orders then 9 wouldn't appear in this
list now we're going to take customer
id or name
let's do id because it should be unique
and we'll pull it onto rows and we're
going to change it to a measure
and it's going to be
account distinct and so now we can see
how many customers ordered
how many items
so
we have our number of orders per
customer which is at the per customer
level even though this visualization is
not at the per customer level
there's nowhere in this visualization
where we pull on the customer
item as a dimension
so let's sort it biggest smallest
and we can see that 134 of our customers
ordered five items or had five orders
and so it just five is the most popular
seven is the next most popular 17 is the
least popular one is relatively
unpopular which is interesting to know
and so you can use this to analyze how
many items your customers generally
order and maybe if they have four items
that they are going to order that
perhaps if you made good suggestions you
could get them to go up to five
and that's an introduction to level of
detail
so let's name this sheet
level of detail lod
orders per
customer
perfect now let's make a new sheet
and we are going to
do an analysis about new customers
so we'll call this level of detail
new customer
analysis
so this visualization is going to be
about customer acquisition over time so
when we do things over time we grab our
date and pull it up here and for a line
chart or anything over time
we're going to
use these
so that it makes an axis
instead of just
change to line
instead of dimensions or something that
is not continuous and then we're going
to take our customer id
pull it onto rows but let's change it to
kind of distinct customer id and now we
can see our count of customers on every
day i think day is too low of a level
let's go ahead and month
so now we can see how many customers
made an order during what month
let's take region
and split it out by region
we click on central we can see central
now this is including all customers
but say we only wanted to include a
customer when they're making their very
first order
so we're only going to include their
first order so we need to create a
calculated field
and we want to compare
we'll call it new or existing
and we want to compare their order date
per
customer to their first order date the
min
order date
nope
order date
and we're going to get this error it
says cannot mix aggregate which is min
and non-aggregate functions and what
it's saying here is that
this order date is at a per row level
since we don't have any aggregation on
it and this order date is at a per
visualization level so it's only going
to split up based on
the visualization and it won't let you
put those two things together so we're
going to
use our level of detail calculation
again
and we're going to make this fixed per
customer id
and then we'll do our min
order date
so now instead of
trying to return something different
based on the visualization it will
always return the min for each customer
id
so if the order date on the
visualization is equal to
this order date
if the order date on the visualization
is equal to the first order date for
that customer
then
new
else
existing
end
so
when the order date equals the very
first order date that means that it's a
new
customer making their first order
otherwise it's an existing customer
because it's no longer their earliest
date
apply
okay and now we can take our new field
which is new or existing drag it onto
filters
and we only want new
we'll hit apply
and we can see that we have new
customers
but
less over time
so
so now we're going to change this
count distinct
to be a running total and we can see
over time
how
our new customers are adding up so it's
taking the prior value and adding our
new customers and then at the end we get
our total customers for each
region and we can now make this a more
the lowest level which is day
and you can see
places where it like levels out so we
can see we have a lot of new customers
and it's increasing but then here for
the region of east there kind of is a
level spot where we're not getting new
orders and that seems to be the same for
each of them so for february of 2014 why
were we not getting any new orders and
how come the west region is getting new
customers how come the west region is
getting new customers faster here
while it's leveling out in the red
it looks like the west region
leveled out as well but picked up sooner
and started getting new customers
so this type of analysis will help you
view
new customers over time
and it's only possible because we were
able to do a level of detail calculation
here on new or existing
that would compare
this data at
only aggregating the data for the
specified dimension so we were able to
grab their minimum order date here so
those are a couple of ways that level of
detail calculations can be very helpful
in summary today we learned about
live versus extract tableau
data sources we learned about joins and
unions in the data sources we also
looked at table versus database
calculations
we looked at how the different ranks
compare
we built some actions into our
dashboards filter actions and
highlighting actions we also looked at
url actions we built dashboards that
used reference lines and ones that used
reference bands we did analyzing of
average days to ship
and delay analysis
we built a waterfall chart
and we also looked into some level of
detail calculations we will be building
dashboards from start to finish first
about world population then health next
we'll build a dashboard about economy
and finally we'll build a dashboard
about business ease i would recommend
getting access to the data set before
you start this tutorial so you can build
along with me if you would like access
to this data set please comment below
and we'll get you access so first we're
going to build a dashboard that revolves
around population so we're going to
build
a map based on country so i'm going to
double click on country and it's going
to map out all the countries and then on
our marks i'm going to change it to map
so it's a filled in map and we want this
to be colored by population total
and we can see
who contributes the most to population
we're going to label it with population
as well
but you can see that it's labeling it
the total population and what we want to
label it is
how much it contributes to population by
percentage so let's add a table
calculation and we're going to have it
do percent of total
based on country
okay so now we can see which countries
contribute what percent
let's also bring the country name onto
the label
and
let's put it on top so country names on
top now it's getting a little bit of
crowded in here so
we're going to unclick show marks label
and we're just going to show the ones
that
we want to see specifically so we can
right click on china here hover on mark
label and click always show
and on india
since these are our two biggest
contributors
we can see that this one's a little bit
darker than the others in that area
and here
here
and that's just a manual way to choose
which ones have indicators labels and
which ones do not
and we're going to put a note here so
we're going to annotate
an area
that explains that
china and india
contribute the most to world population
just calling out this section of the
visualization
and let's name this sheet
so here we have our visualization and
when you hover you can see both the
total population and its percent
contribution and the country name
our next visualization for this
dashboard is going to be
population over time
so
let's bring on our time element but one
trick for bringing on a time element if
we just drag it on so year with the
calendar mark here if we just drag it on
it'll default
to
a discrete version so let's take it back
off
and then we could edit it there but one
thing you could do is if you on
a windows machine you right click on it
and drag it on then it will pop up
with the dialog box that allows you to
select what kind of
date value you want to use in the first
place so we're going to use year here
and now we have instead of discrete we
have a continuous axis
and we're going to bring on population
total
and we can see that over time
one thing you can do when the value is
up so high
in your axis is you can uncheck this box
that says include zero and it will
not always include zero in your axis but
this can be misleading so you can see
that it looks like population growth is
something really dramatic by increasing
that slope of the line
whereas it really wasn't quite as
dramatic as it seems so as long as it's
communicated
well and you're not doing it to
mislead your users
you just need to keep in mind that this
includes zero can change what your graph
is saying so we're going to
not include the zero at this time
just so that we can focus in on our data
a little bit
now we're going to add our forecast so
we're gonna click on forecast and drag
it on
and it adds the forecast to our
visualization right there and now we can
right click here
and see forecast result is
actual and forecast
so you can see that the forecast picks
up
here in 2012 and pushes out what it
thinks it'll be in 2013 as well you can
change how far out that forecast goes by
right clicking on the line and clicking
forecast option
and we can change this is automatically
the next two years but we could change
it so that it's the next 10 years and it
will go out into the future
out to 2022
you can change prediction intervals or
if you don't want to show them you don't
have to show them and this is just kind
of
a visual guide for those prediction
intervals
okay and then you can also
have your trend lines show
[Applause]
where it shows your trend line following
out from where your population growth is
and also the trend line for your
forecast right there
and we'll call this
world population
trend excellent and we're going to make
one more visualization for this
and it's going to be a pie chart so the
pie chart is also going to be based off
of population
so we're going to click on population
and we're going to control click on
country and come over to show me
and click your pie chart
great so i'm going to make this
the entire view so we can see the pie
chart better
and this is getting really crazy in here
and so i have changed my mind and
instead of country i'm going to drag
region over top of country and now we
see something a little bit more
manageable so we can see that here's
asia
and it makes up
the biggest piece of the pie and then
here is everybody else so right now
each of these is population total
and we could keep it that way or we
could
do what we did last time
and change it to percent of total
so that on hover we can see
the population
and
the percentage of population that it
contributes
so for this pie chart we're just going
to
show asia versus everybody else so we
need to make a group and what we'll do
is
select all of these
and we're going to right click and click
group
so now we have
all those things we selected and we have
other let's edit our group right click
edit group
we're going to
rename this group
asia because that's all that's in there
and we're going to rename this group
the rest of the world
okay
so now we have our group we can drag it
onto label and we can see asia and rest
of the world and now see how it's
breaking it up into those different
sections that's because we still have
region on
our
detail right here so we pull region off
now it's just split asia rest of the
world we can change our colors
make it a little bit more
visually interesting
now we can still see our percentages
and now let's rename it and then we'll
put it all together on a dashboard
great so let's make our dashboard we
have this new dashboard button down here
and you can choose what sizes you want
so we have a fixed size where you just
select the width and height we have
automatic which will just fill your
screen
and
we have a range which has a minimum size
and a maximum size
some of the
good things about fixed is that once you
have it you can have it always look that
way so no matter where they're looking
at it you know that it's going to be
laid out the way that you expected
however if somebody's looking out on a
screen that is bigger or smaller than
yours then it doesn't fill up the screen
or it will fill the screen too much and
they'll have to scroll up and down and
left and right
if you have automatic then it will fit
the screen that it's displayed on
however the things that you've placed
might get squished too close together
and then the range gives you a minimum
size and a maximum size meaning if the
screen is too big
it still won't fill up the screen but it
can get closer and then as they get
smaller and smaller screens
you at least know that it will never
make it get smaller than this particular
size so there's some benefits to that as
well where you still have a little bit
of control of what it will look like at
the end
great let's bring on our worksheets
and you can see that where you hover
it fills up that space and that's where
it's going to show up you can also
adjust the lines in between different
visualizations for things that need more
space or less space
another important thing to recognize is
that when you click on a visualization
like this one up here it will tell you
how it's viewing that visualization
within that space so if you click
standard then it will do a standard fit
versus if you have
entire view where it will
make it fit into inside the box over
here we could have fit width
or fit height on some of the
visualizations it doesn't make as much
of a difference however when you have a
visualization that maybe has a lot of
text in it and they need to be able to
scroll you'll want to have it fit width
but you don't want it to fit height
because then it will shove all of that
information
into the box and not allow you to scroll
up and down
so as you saw as we drag these on it
took these
legends and added it to the left here
we can modify that
and make them floating
and drag them next to the visualizations
that they are relevant to
and
this particular one
has a couple of things wrong with it we
might not want the title of this to be
region group
so we could come in and we could edit
the title and then
maybe just call it region
however i don't think we need this
legend at all because it's very clearly
marked on the visualization there so you
could also just remove it from the
dashboard
and this one
is telling you how big of a circle
it would need to be before it gets to
that population number so
it belongs to this circle as well but
again
is unnecessary potentially because we
have our two population numbers
showing up right as we hover
so we remove that as well so at this
point we have a visualization or three
visualizations all on the same page
which is the basics of a dashboard
however we might want to be able to
interact with them a little bit more
than just hovering
and so this is where we should look into
adding filters so we have information
over time we have information by country
and we have some information by region
here
one of the quickest things you can do to
add functionality to the dashboard is by
clicking this uses filter button so if
we click this that means whatever
country we click on here
will filter the other visualization
and then you can unselect it
to go back
now
that
uses filter button
actually creates an action here
filter one generated that it's made on
its own now you can see that when we
click on
china
it doesn't make a lot of sense to have
this pie chart update based on that
china click because it's just going to
show
duplicated information so it shows the
twenty percent or the twenty percent
here and the seventeen
billion
and then here it does the same thing
except for it shows a hundred percent
because it's filtered everything else
out of the chart so it now makes up 100
of the circle so that doesn't make a lot
of sense
so there are ways to
format your visualization or your
actions
modify your actions so that they only
affect the things that make sense so we
can come here and click edit
we're going to call this country
action
and we want it to
use the population by country sheet and
then modify
only the trend
so now when we click on
china
we see china's trend over time
and it doesn't affect our pie
because that doesn't make sense for it
to affect our pie
we might want to select on our pie
asia or rest of the world and have that
affect the other visualization so we can
click use this filter here and click
asia
and now it zooms into asia on our map
and shows us just the asia world
population trend and here's rest of the
world and we can see that asia is grayed
out
and there's the rest of the world and
here's the rest of the world population
trend
we might also want to be able to use
this to filter to a certain year
so if we click use filter
then we click on
2011
you can see these numbers are slightly
updating so this is 19
and we come here 19.5 percent
come down here and we can see that the
pie updates a little bit
although it hasn't been anything
dramatic
you can kind of see it over time
so that's one way
to add filters to your visualization
another way is to use actual filtering
instead of just actions so if we come
back here to our trend
we could take the year we're going to
control click and drag it onto filters
and now we have a year filter so we
could have it the actual year number so
just look at one year at a time or a
range of dates
so if we click range of dates that makes
this slider
from 2000 to 2012. so if we hit ok
we'll right click and we'll click show
filter we can see it here and as we drag
this
it updates
but kind of messes with our forecast
so let's not do a year filter
in this case
so we clicked remove filter there
but maybe we want a filter just on this
for the different years
so let's drag year onto the filters
we're just going to do the year number
next and here's all the years we're
going to let all of them be selected for
now
and then we're going to show the filter
and here's all of our years
and we can change the way that our quick
filter shows up
and we can make it like a drop down so
they can still select multiples but it's
a drop down or maybe we want this
visualization to be just one year at a
time so we can choose single value in a
list and it lists out all the years or
in a drop down
and we want it to be 2012
and
then we want this to show up on our
dashboard so we come to the dashboard
and we click more options here hover
over filters and we can see the filters
available and we can click year of year
and now our formatting hasn't passed on
so that's one thing to remember that
formatting it just on the workbook
doesn't necessarily mean that the
formatting will pass over to the
dashboard so i tend to not do any
formatting on the workbooks and just
format it on the dashboard because the
dashboards are what i publish
so we're going to single value drop down
we're going to
[Music]
add it we're going to move it to the top
so now how we do that
let's talk a little bit about what each
of these sections are come here to
layout
and you can see we have this layout here
item hierarchy so tiled is the whole
screen and inside of that we have a
horizontal
container
and inside this horizontal container
we have another horizontal container and
when you click on something in this view
it shows you where it exists so we can
see this horizontal container is
outlined now and then we change it to
vertical and it outlines this now a
horizontal container allows things to be
side by side
and a vertical container allows things
to be a one on top of the other and so
in our vertical container we see all
this extra space for extra things to be
on top of each other but if we wanted to
have it at the top
we would maybe want things to be able to
be side by side so if we go back to the
dashboard and we grab horizontal and
drag it to the top
it adds a horizontal container up here
and now you can see everything that's
floating kind of stays in the place that
it was
even though all the other things shifted
so that's one of the disadvantages of
floating is that you're kind of just
manually choosing
where it will stand
using your x and y position
and it's not dynamic
so let's give us a little bit less space
up here
we can add a text box into
our horizontal container
and we will say
population dashboard
we can format it
now we have our title up here and then
we can add our filter
we're going to drag it to be on
inside of our horizontal container but
on the
side here
we can give it more or less space
let's bring
our legends down to places where they
make sense again
perfect
and so now
we have this
that will affect this
only
and show you just 2012 2011 2010. so we
don't want it to affect the trend
because we want the trend to show
all of time and just looking at one year
for this trend that is only at a yearly
part and forecasts into the future
doesn't make any sense but we maybe
wanted to also affect this worksheet so
that these two are in sync
and so the dashboard is basically for
2012 except for the trend which shows
you the past in the future so one way
that you can do that is clicking apply
to worksheets here
and you can choose selected worksheets
and it will show you all the worksheets
in this visualization
or in this dashboard
and you can click show all worksheets in
workbook and then if there were other
worksheets it would show them so we
wanted to do asia versus rest of the
world and population contribution by
country
okay and that's another way we can
change what year they show so it's only
going to show one year at a time
unless we select all
and then this visualization isn't
affected by it
if we don't want
to
click on a country and have it
make the change if we instead want to
have a filter for country we can do that
by taking country and dragging it onto
filters
we'll have it show all for now
and then when we go back to our
dashboard and we come to this
visualization we can go filters and at
country
and it's just added it side by side
where we had our other filter so that's
a nice
feature of tableau where it can kind of
guess where you might want things we're
going to do multiple value drop down
and right now
it only affects that visualization and
we can just look at one country at a
time
and we might not want it to affect this
visualization because it doesn't do us
any good to just look at one region in a
pie chart
but maybe we wanted to affect the world
population trend so we can do the same
thing we did before
and we wanted to affect these two
we'll click ok
and so now
we could look at
all these countries
and that would update both these
visualizations
another thing i like to do
on a filter
is customize and click show apply button
and this means we can make all these
changes in here
see i've selected none however these
visualizations aren't updating and then
i wanted to look at turkey so i found
turkey and then i hit apply and that's
when they update
perfect so now we have a dashboard
complete with filters and
actions
we also have a title on our dashboard we
can give it a little bit less space and
some legends
we have titles on each of these pieces
however if we didn't want a title here
we can click hide title and it will just
show our visualization there and this is
dashboard number one
here's what it looks like in full screen
mode full screen mode is a good
opportunity for you to test it to see
what it will look like to the end user i
press escape and get back out
and it doesn't give you these highlights
when you hover over things that are
dashboard formatting related
you can see that all those extra lines
went away
and it just gives you the opportunity to
test out your dashboard in a more real
way
and see how they will use it
instead of giving you the dashboard
editing options
next we're going to make a dashboard
revolving around health information
so first we're going to make
a map
about birth rates so we're going to call
it
birth
rate rank
and to make a map we're going to double
click on country
and
we're going to change it to a map type
so we have a filled map here and then
we're going to bring birth rate on to
color
so let's define our colors a little bit
by clicking on this color part of the
marks card we'll click edit colors and
we're going to change it
to
red and gold
and the idea here is that the red is for
a higher birth rate which is
more associated with countries that have
poor health so we'll hit apply
and now we have our higher birth rate
countries highlighted in red
next we're going to create
a class so we're going to duplicate
birth rate
and let's edit that field
we're going to call it birth rate class
and so we're going to say that anything
that is in the top 50 countries
with the highest birth rate is
categorized as having
an alarming birth rate so we will
first do the average
birth rate
and then we're going to
do a rank
on that
do you see sometimes
when you're auto-completing your
statements
it will replace
one of these functions that you have
with the one that you pressed tab for so
if i type if or i start to type if and
then i come here and click on if it
replaced my rank with if so keep an eye
out for that if you're like where did my
thing go it's because i was typing it
right next to it so if i put a space and
then i start to type if and i click if
it will not delete rank so we're going
to say if
the rank of average is
less than or equal to
50 so if it's in the top 50
then
alarming
birth rate
else if
and we could take this again
is greater than 50
then
normal or three
and
always make sure you put on the end also
we didn't necessarily have to have this
else if statement
so if we had just done else normal birth
rate that would have covered all of our
bases
so with these if statements just make
sure that you're always getting all the
different options
that you want but in this case
we defined both however we didn't have
to define the second calculation because
if it is not in the top 50 then it's
obviously in the bottom the rest
so we're going to hit ok
and then we're going to put birth rate
class onto label
and it's gone around and labeled
everything
and i am seeing alarming birth rate on
everything so let's see what the problem
is
so if we open this back up by right
clicking and clicking edit you can see
it says results are computed a long
table across
so we're going to click default table
calculation here and instead of compute
using automatic we're going to change it
to compute using
country we'll hit ok
and hit apply
and that didn't seem to fix it so this
is the first place i would look if it's
not doing what you would expect
so
we'll put it back to automatic okay
the second place i would look is inside
of the table calculation that is created
so when we defined rank here
we put a table calculation on it so when
we right click here we get edit table
calculation
and we're going to choose that we want
to do the rate based on
the specific dimension of country
so now we can see
using the logic
the calculation assistance that
we no longer have just alarming birth
rate we have normal birth rate and
alarming birth rate on our screen so we
can close this
and
we are done here one thing you could do
is
when we have allow labels to overlap
other marks selected then it will make
sure that
every label shows up but it gets super
crazy in there so there are some times
where the labels may overlap a little
bit and so you'll want to select this
option in our case we don't want that
and now we have a visualization
showing
birth rate map based on rank our next
visualization
is going to be about
average life expectancy
male versus female
so we're going to do
a chart across time so we're going to
click year and bring it on to columns
and we're going to change it to
this
year
in the continuous section so now we have
an axis
and
we're going to
double click on female life expectancy
up
there we go double click on female
expectancy and then double click on male
life expectancy so what that did was
made us two charts
one on top of the other but we don't
want that so we'll take this off and
we're going to drag male life expectancy
right onto this axis for the female life
expectancy
and what this has done is made what's
called a blended axis chart so it's not
a dual axis chart where we have another
axis over here
for the second visualization this one is
a blended axis chart so they necessarily
use the same axis and they necessarily
have the same kinds of marks so we'll
take a look and see what the difference
is there so if i were to change this to
a bar chart we would have
bar chart for both of them and i can't
define one separately from the other
change it back to a line chart
and they're both a line chart now if we
go back to
when we just had female life expectancy
and we drag
male on next to it and we have two
charts
now we can change it to a dual axis and
we have one on top of the other however
our axes don't line up we can see at the
top here is 15k and over here it's 14k
so we're going to synchronize the axis
and you can see
one on top of the other
we have two marks cards so we could have
this one be a bar chart and that would
be a line chart
so that's some of the differences of
those two we're going to do a blended
access chart so i'm going to take mail
and drag it here
and we have our blended access chart and
now you can see the our scale here
is really strange so what it's doing is
it's adding up all of the life
expectancies for all the different
countries instead of averaging it so
we're going to change that by right
clicking on the measure down in this
measure values card hovering over
measure sum and we're going to change it
to average
since i only changed one of them and
they share the same axes it's really
spread out now and it almost looks like
a straight line down there and then
let's change the other
and it should get everything a little
bit more
in sync there we go so now we can see
the average life expectancy over time
which for both of them seems to be going
up
however
it seems to be higher
for females
now let's take a look at our analytics
and let's
drag on forecast
so it's forecasted out the next two
years for both line
and we'll bring on trend
onto linear
and let's change it
to a square so now we see
each individual point for the life
expectancy for females and males and we
can see what they're expected to be in
the future
and our trends
and our next visualization
is going to be a heat map
about
multiple different
measures so we'll just call it a heat
map for now
and for our heat map we're going to look
at the different countries so we'll
bring country onto rows and we're going
to look at
their
birth rate
so i just double clicked on birth rate
and brought it on
we're going to look at
their health
percentage on gdp so how much they spend
on
gdp
so when i double clicked on it it did
what we did before where we have a
measures value card and so now whenever
we put measures on here that determines
what goes here because we have our
measuring names on columns so every
measure in here their name is going to
define the name of the column and the
values
define
what's in the text right here
great we're also going to bring on
infant mortality rate
and
the life expectancy for females
okay
so now it has
changed these to not have decimal points
after them which is not as helpful so
we're going to
format those
and you can format it field by field so
for birth rate
we definitely want to have
decimals afterwards as a matter of fact
the birth rate is a percentage so
instead of doing a number standard we'll
just go to percentage
and now we don't need to have those
decimals afterwards we can just look at
the birth rate as a rate
and
for
percent of gdp for health expenditures
we can come click there and do the same
thing
and for infant mortality rate
okay
and to make this make a little bit more
sense we again need to change it from a
sum
to an average
and for some of these
we could
change it from a sum to an average right
inside of
the
for all of these we could change it from
a sum to an average in the default
properties
under aggregation
so it will automatically average it
whenever we bring it out
default is sum but if we make it
automatically average then we won't have
to do that again
for any other visualizations
i won't do that at this time because i
get a little bit confused sometimes when
i don't have my sum on there by default
because that's what i'm so used to
seeing by default great so we now have
a matrix
by country and by our different metrics
here and so we can
take our measure values
and drag it onto color
and we'll make our marks from automatic
to square
and it will make our heat map
now what happens with a heat map
is it colors darkly
the higher the number it is in this case
and
right now it's doing it for the whole
area so one percent is obviously much
much smaller than 82 but if we wanted to
be able to look at birth rate
independently from life expectancy we
can right click on the measure values on
the color and click use separate legends
and so now we have a legend
for each one of these let's change the
colors on those legends so that we can
see them separately a little bit more
clearly
so we'll change the colors by coming
over here to each of the legends
and we'll leave one the same
but we'll change this one
and if we click edit colors you can see
our different palettes
you can see some of them just have one
color others have one color to another
color we used the
red gold before
so now you can see that one is changed
we could use
another one that goes from
green to blue
great
you can also define your own
so you can make a custom one that could
go from
light to dark and then you can choose
what color you want as your dark color
so we could pick
a lighter blue
and then we see that last one
and now with these separate color
palettes you can quickly see the
difference with birth rate and
spending on health
and that is our heat map
with separate legends so let's build
this all into a dashboard now
we're going to call it our health
dashboard
and for simplicity we're going to make
it automatic so it fills our screen
and then we're going to first bring on
our map
we're going to bring on our health
related map with birth rates
then we're going to bring on our
heat map
and we'll bring on our life expectancy
lines
now as we brought on all of our charts
it brought in our legends here
and we're going to move our legends up
to the top so let's add a horizontal
container
and then let's put
our legends
into the horizontal container
and um let's put these ones in order so
life expectancy
oh
so birth rate is going to be over here
great now
one thing we can do is make these
smaller
well that's actually just making that
one bigger huh okay
so it would make them smaller
by making something else bigger or by
adding in a blank space
which would then
help you adjust the size
by taking up the space that you're not
using
another thing to pay attention to is
this fixed width so once you start to
drag the size on something it no longer
is dynamic
so if we unfix that width
so that it's only taking up whatever
space is left oh and that one is not
fixed with
and then we can edit the width on this
to be
even
bigger then it will squish things over
to where we would like them to be so
that's one of the ways you can add space
or make things the size you would like
them to be
now let's take a look at filters oh
before we take a look at filters i want
to look at this map one more time
because i think that it would be useful
for our colors to be
a little bit more
distinct
so
one quick way to navigate to your
worksheet from your dashboard is to
click this go to sheet button
and while we're here i'm going to click
on color
edit colors and we did red and gold and
we're going to change it from this
sequence to a stepped color
and we're going to change it to three
colors so it's going to either be
this color this color this color and
when i hit ok
you can kind of see it's a little bit
more dramatic
in our differences and it's put
everything into the three categories we
defined so let's go back to our
dashboard
and we can see the difference there
and now we're going to take a look at
our filters so we want to be able to
filter by country
so let's bring country onto filters
now we're going to allow it to use all
and we're going to
here you can click apply to worksheets
and you can click selected worksheets
and it's going to pop up with all the
worksheets
in the whole workbook
and so one disadvantage of doing it on
the worksheet is that you can see all of
the worksheets in the workbook and you
have to differentiate between which ones
are on the dashboard which ones aren't
and these are the three on this
dashboard so we're gonna hit ok
and we're also going to do it by year so
when we drag the year onto filters
we're going to
allow them to
choose years so we're going to do
the distinct number of years we'll click
use all
okay
and we're going to apply to the
worksheets
this one with the birth rate and the
average life expectancy male versus
female we're not going to filter down
our line chart by year
because we want to be able to see it
over time and if we filter down the time
then we don't get as much context so
we'll hit ok
let's go back to our dashboard
if i click on more options here and
hover over filters you can see that year
filter and that country filter
you should also be able to see both of
those filters on the heat map
because i told it to apply to that one
as well so here's the country oh
i made a mistake let's go back to this
visualization
and
apply to worksheets selected worksheets
see i wanted it to be on the birth rate
and the heat map not the line chart and
i clicked the wrong one
so that was a good test
so when we go here to the heat map
and click down
you can see now
we get the year of year as well so we'll
click year of year let's put it over
here
and we're gonna make it
a multiple values drop down and we'll
bring it over
to the middle
and let's also
get the countries filter
great so now that we have these in here
we don't need this to be so big so let's
edit the width
and make it
300
even smaller
200
great and let's change our country
to be
a single value drop down
so you can pick one at a time and let's
also change it
or this year of year since we can select
multiples let's change it so that
on customize that you show the apply
button so here since they can only
select one
we don't have the apply button because
it will just automatically apply
and here since they can select multiples
we'll let them unselect all and pick
their years and then hit apply and then
you'll see the changes
and you can see that even though i've
selected only 2011 and 2012 you still
see all the years on this line chart as
expected
and there
is our health dashboard
our next dashboard is going to have to
do with economy our first sheet is going
to be
another map that is going to have to do
with
overall gdp
and
as we usually begin with maps by double
clicking on country and changing it to a
map mark type
and this time we're going to bring on
gdp onto color
and change it to average
and we can edit the colors
let's this time do
a custom diverging so you get to pick
both colors
and let's pick
a little bit lighter
hmm
okay red for there and then we want to
do maybe like a deeper
green
and that way
you can see
who has the highest gdp which is green
we hit apply
okay and then it will
eventually get lighter and lighter until
it goes to gray which then it will lead
to green
okay
and next we're going to make
scatter plot
which we will call
gdp versus gdp per capita
so
gdp or gross domestic product versus
gross domestic product per capita or per
person
and to make a scatter plot
you have
one
measure on one axis
and then another measure which is going
to be
gdp per capita which we will now create
on the other
axis so let's start with gdp and we'll
hit duplicate
and let's edit that
and we're going to call it
gdp
per capita
and we're going to take
sum
of gdp
and divided by the sum
of the total
population
total
what is my error
opening parenthesis
there we go
and then we have gdp per capita so let's
what this will do is
sum up the gdp
across whatever measures we have in
place go across whatever dimensions we
have in place and then sum up the
population for those same dimensions and
then divide it instead of dividing it
per row
and then
doing an aggregation on it okay
so now we're going to bring on gdp per
capita on the rows
and we have the sum of gdp and the gdp
per capita and to make it more than just
one
little mark on our scatter plot we will
drag on country to detail and now we
have one mark per country
and you can see some countries have
a high gdp per capita
and some countries have a high
gdp overall but not as high of a gdp per
capita
and so on we have some middle of the
road people here so we can change this
from automatic
to circles and now they're dots like you
might see on scatter plot
and
you can
drag region
onto
color
and now we can see our different regions
and see we see a lot of reds here
and
it's quick to see
what region things belong in also you
can click to highlight and you can see
all of the americas highlighted in
context
the next visualization we're going to
make
is going to be
showing
how much countries spend on health care
as a part of their gdp so
we're going to rename it
to be gdp on health care
and we're going to look at each of our
countries
and we're going to make a bar chart
that shows
the health expense gdp
and we're going to change this to
average
and we're also going to show
the health expense per capita
over here it shows how much is spent per
person on health
and this
is showing how much
is spent on health
based on gdp
click at the top and click sort and it's
sorting by this first one
and you can see which countries spend
the most of their gdp on health
we can again bring region onto color
so we can see the different
regions
highlighted
and
let's bring on labels so
for our different marks cards
we're going to want to control click
this
and drag it onto the labels
and we can see that it's a percentage
but it's coming up as a number so
we can right click and click
format right there
and
we're going to change the number to
percentage
maybe just do one decimal place
and then for this one
we're going to control
and drag
that onto labels
and maybe we'll change this one to
currency however if you don't want to
change it to currency
since we aren't sure
necessarily what currency this data set
is in um it's worth checking out
what currency it is in
so for now we'll just have it as a
number
and now we're going to
customize our tool tip
so we're going to go to the overall
marks card
and we'll click on tool tip and we want
it to tell us the country in the top so
erase region
and we're going to
erase country label and center country
and then we're going to
put
this country
spends
this percentage
on
health care
and if you want to preview it you can
hover or click here on preview and it
will show you an example marshall island
spends 2.1 on healthcare we'll hit enter
and then when we hover
it tells you the country and it has our
custom tool tip on both visualizations
or on both
of the different axes
so
let's build our dashboard
we'll bring on our map
we'll bring on our
healthcare
visualization
and our gdp versus gdp per capita
and we'll move our legends to the top
again
by adding a horizontal container to the
top
and bringing them up here
one thing we can do also
is to give this more space
we can have it go all the way to the top
and these legends are just side by side
just above the map
and the gdp per capita
scatter type plot
an interesting thing you can do in
tableau is you can see this outlier of
the united states is making it difficult
to see the rest of the information or to
visualize if there's any trend there
so you could right click on it and click
exclude
and then it will exclude it from your
data set very quickly
and then you'll just click this back
button to get it back
great now let's take a look at filters
we are going to do a single filter
so let's go to this visualization and
we'll bring on country we'll click use
all
okay
now we're going to apply it to
worksheets so i showed you how we can
apply it to worksheets here
you can also apply to worksheets once
it's on the dashboard so if we come here
and look at filters we can see the
countries on the filters for this
visualization but if we come down here
and look at filters
we still see country because it's in the
details of the information so
either way when we add country
since i added it from this visualization
it only affects this visualization
okay
but we want it to affect all on the
worksheet
so we're going to apply to worksheets
and we can click selected worksheets and
we can click all on dashboard
okay
let's bring this over here we're going
to allow them to see all at once and be
able to scroll and select the ones they
want and now
when we select different ones it affects
all three worksheets
we're also going to add an action
for a url action add action go to url
and when we click on a country on the
overall gdp map we want it to take us to
the wikipedia page that talks about the
economy for that country
so that is
this url and it's going to say
wikipedia for economy of
and we're going to add our country to
the end
so we hit ok
we have it running on menu so let's
change it to run on select and as soon
as you click it it will take you there
okay so now let's try it
and we can click on
canada
and it will take us to the wikipedia
page for the economy of canada
great we click on brazil
same thing
so if we unselect on brazil then it will
make our map highlighted normally again
we can also use this one to filter the
other visualizations
and so we could click use this filter
here and then when we click on france
it will filter these two other
visualizations to france
you can see that when we filter this
visualization
to a particular country
so if we look at
germany
germany wasn't green before on our map
but now it is that happens because our
scale has changed just for the ones
selected
so if we control click france and
germany and switzerland
and austria we now have a scale that
reflects only these countries and the
biggest is going to be the darkest green
or the highest gdp is the darkest green
and the lowest is the lightest pink
and there is our economy dashboard you
can see that we have some nulls on these
visualizations that occurs when we don't
have all of the data
for every point
you can ignore those and they won't show
up on the final visualization when you
publish it to server or you can deal
with those by clicking on them and
filtering that data out or showing that
data at the default position which is
showing the null values at zero our
final dashboard is going to be about the
ease of doing business in a country so
our first visualization is going to be a
bar chart which we will call days to
start
business
so how many days it takes to start a
business is important to know when
you're trying to start a business in a
country and also can be an indicator of
how easy it will be to do business in
that country so
let's make a bar chart that includes
every country and then we're going to
bring on days to start a business
and we will sort it smallest to biggest
and we have some days
or some countries that don't have
any days so let's filter out those
countries
and we're going to
filter it to only those that have a good
market
we're going to make a calculated field
we're going to define business friendly
market
well
we're going to define our market based
on how easy it is to start a business
and how many days it takes so if it
takes less than 25 days to start a
business we'll consider that a good
market
and so we're going to do
if
the days to start a business is less
than or equal to 25
then
elsif
days to start a business
is
greater than
25
then
business
might or might not
work
doing less than or equal to 25 or
greater than 25
allows us to be able to define these two
different markets so we'll hit
apply there
and we're going to filter it
just to a good market
and we're going to look at
just one year
look at 2012
our most recent year
and we're going to color it based on
region
and we can see
which regions tend to have
the shorter days to start a business
and we're going to
move on and build our next visualization
which is also a bar chart
which we will call ease of business
so we have this ease of business field
and we could bring on the country and we
can bring on ease of business
and we want to
make it
a measure so the ease of business is at
this point looking at it like it's
a string
and we can change that in our default
properties and convert it to a measure
or use it up here and change it to a
measure
when we try to change it to a measure
here it wants to treat it like a string
so it wants to take the minimum or the
maximum
but if we here convert it to a measure
then it also automatically made it a
count
so the first thing to do
would be to change the data type to a
number
and now
we can change it to a measure and
aggregate it so we could do
like the sum of ease of business
in our use case we're actually going to
do the
average of ease of business and then we
want to have the smallest on the top we
do have some that don't have ease of
business ratings
so we're going to filter that data out
and again we want the year to be 2012
but how we're going to do that is by
coming to this visualization
and by applying this particular year of
2012 so we'll do it on select workbooks
and select ease of business okay
and now this one also has
the year of 2012 there
and
we're going to
segment
this by creating another header
we're going to call that
business
friendly
and we're going to say
that if the ease of business
is
so i guess this is a nice thing to know
so if if we start typing in
what we want to see then we can select
it from a list here but you can also
interact outside of this box so you
could just grab ease of business and
drag it into the dialog box here and
that's really nice so we're going to say
if it is greater than or equal to 1
and less than or equal to
three
then
we're going to say it has the most
business
friendly
regulations
give us a little more room to look at
okay and this statement won't work
because it's saying and what is less
than or equal to three so you have to
have ease of business in both places
and then this should say then and not
the great so now we're just getting an
error because we don't have an end
so if that's all we wanted to do then
that's what we would do but then we'll
just do another else if
and it's already taken this
if statement goes through
one condition at a time so it's already
classified everything that's between
these two numbers and so
now we can just say
if ease of business is
less than or equal to 10
then
we'll call it very
very business friendly regulations
and we'll keep going
else if ease of business is
less than or equal to 50
then
we're going to call it
moderate
and we're just going to say moderate
business
regulations
copy that for later use
less than equal to 150
then
strict
so
the reason that this doesn't grab
everything that is less than or equal to
150 is because
these sections 1 to 3
and then 3 or well 4 to 10
and then 11 to 50 have all been
classified up to this point so it's just
getting everything else
and we're going to
finally
say else everything else
is going to be called
not preferred for
business
and see if we get any errors calculation
is valid let's see if this works as we
expect so we'll hit apply
and we'll bring business friendly onto
our rows
and now it categorizes everything
based on what we said so
we want to define what order these go in
so we're going to click sort
and we want the
most business friendly at the top
then we want moderate then strict then
not preferred okay
so we have our top three that are the
most business friendly and then we've
got four through ten which are very then
we've got our moderate
our strict
and our
not preferred
so let's bring region again onto color
and we can see which regions are the
most business friendly
and we have our year of 2012 there
and now we're going to make this even
more useful by adding the business tax
rate onto the label
so that you can see that business
friendly
is like singapore but they have a pretty
high tax rate of 27
whereas if you get down to some of these
that are not preferred
some of them have really low tax rates
so let's make sure that we're getting
okay the right tax rate
so
you can see that
27 is definitely not the highest tax
rate that we have for business
but you can also see that there are
places that have
even lower tax rates
like saudi
arabia and
we have
eight percent here
it looks like we don't ever go to
that second decimal place so let's
quickly
format this
oh
business tax rate is also text
so if we could convert
our data type to
decimal
and then we will
format it
to be
a
percentage and we just need the one
decimal place
okay
now let's make
some annotations so we could come and
click here on this mark
and then we can annotate that mark which
will make this dialog box and it's
already filled in here
and so we could
use some of this information
so i'm going to copy that
and i'll put some hard returns there
so we're going to say
that this country
is the most
business friendly
but has a
business tax rate
of and let's grab the tax rate
and then we'll erase this
and we'll hit okay
and
i've made a typo so singapore is the
most business friend is not what i meant
to say
so i can click edit
business friendly
but has a tax rate of and you can move
this around draws the line to singapore
which is the mark
that we wanted to annotate so that is an
annotation on a mark if we wanted to
just make an annotation
for the area
then we could
point out that
more business friendly
countries
often have
high
business taxes
i could change that size make everything
fit
now we have this second note
where our user can come in and see some
more information about what's being
presented here
great and now we're going to make one
more visualization
and it's going to be
about phone and internet usage
because you may want to know about the
phone and internet
trends when you're looking to start a
business
so we're going to do this one over time
so it does not need to have that year
filter on it
and we're doing our continuous our axis
and we're going to
look at mobile phone usage so i double
clicked it shows mobile phone usage over
time
and we're going to change it to average
so that it's averaging it across the
countries
and then we're going to bring on
internet usage so we'll bring it on side
by side so we have two visualizations
and we're going to
also make that average
now we might not want these to share an
axis because they are measured a little
bit differently
and so we can make it a dual axis
but allow them to keep their independent
axes
or you can synchronize the axes
and see them at their
rates however
the uses is just a little bit
of a different measurement we can have
one of them be
a bar chart and the other one be a line
let's have this one be the bar chart
okay and then the line is in the front
you can also change which one's in the
front by
coming and clicking
on the axis itself
and you can click move marks to front
and that move that one to the front okay
and now it's made each of these wide and
there's like a star point and end point
on the axis for the bar
and that comes here under size
where they're all fixed
or you could have it be manual where we
can define the size of the bars so we're
gonna make those bars like
this now we can see them going up over
time
we can also change the width of the line
itself
make it thicker or thinner
and
we can change the colors here
so let's change it to
orange
since red might apply that it's bad
in some cultures
and now we can see our internet usage
and our phone usage over time and how
it's trending
and so this will all come together on
our new dashboard
which is about
ease of business
you can see that i have a sheet called
these as a business and a dashboard that
i've called ease of business but it
won't let you create a dashboard with
the same name
as your worksheet so
ease of business dashboard
let's have it fit the screen
and
we're going to bring on
our days to start business visual
our ease of business visual
and our
phone and internet visual
let's
put our legends at the top again
so we'll make
our horizontal
container
and we'll bring our region legend into
there and then our
measure names for internet versus
mobile phone
and we have a filter that already is
pre-applied to two of the visualizations
called year of year
and it's selected 2012 and if we select
2011
it's only changing this one it's
filtering out all the information for
this visualization and changing this one
to 2011
so let's see why that's happening if we
go to this visualization
and click the go to sheet
we can see year of 2012 is here let's
click show
filter and if we change the filter
to 2011 okay it's not showing up here
and the only filter i can see that could
be removing it is this averages of
business
that is removing anything that is null
so if i pull that off you can see that
we don't seem to have any information
for 2011 for ease of business
and the more years i select
i'm not seeing any
ease of business information
so
we're going to want to set this
to
2012 only because that seems to be the
only information that is useful for this
visualization
so
let's go back until we're back to the
state
we were in
when we started
okay so here we are
now we're going to want to remove this
filter
and we're going to give it its own
filter
that only selects 2012
that is not connected to the other
filter
so now when we change year of year it
only changes this visualization
sometimes that's useful to note
sometimes it's useful to put
let's do a single value
drop down sometimes it's useful to put
this
right next to the visualization it
affects
so if we could change it to floating
and just put it like
here
that makes it clear that
it's just changing this chart
so that people don't get confused
another thing that we can do that we
should do on all of our visualizations
is
change the titles so that they're more
business or user friendly
great
and
so we have our filter
and let's use this as a filter
and that way we can click on new zealand
and we can see it's the most business
friendly regulations and we can see its
internet
and phone usage over time
we can click on
a lot of different countries to see
those changes
you can see that
some countries have a steeper
change so some of them have
adopted phone and internet usage and
have stayed pretty similar whereas other
ones have only
really adopted it in the last couple of
years
also if we wanted to filter to just one
country
we could do what we did before and
create a country filter
here's another way to go to the sheet
you can click this down arrow and click
go to sheet or you can come over here
you can see that it's highlighting a
visualization over here or a sheet and
whatever sheet i click on is highlighted
over here
and there's this little pop-out arrow
here that also takes you to the sheet
and we can bring country on
use them all
go back to our dashboard
we'll go to filters and select country
we'll make it a multiple value drop down
we're going to add the apply button and
now we're going to make it apply to all
the visualizations by
clicking apply to workbooks selected
worksheets all on dashboard okay
now we can see that if we just want to
look at afghanistan
okay we can see
how many days it takes to start a
business there it's not preferred for
business and it's internet and phone
usage over time
and those are our
four dashboards so as a review we have
made
a dashboard on population
we made one about health
we made one that had to do with our
economy
and one that had to do with our ease of
doing business
business intelligence is a set of
processes and techniques to analyze raw
data and extract information that helps
drive business decisions it helps you
keep track of business data and draw
valuable insights there are several
tools that play a key role in business
intelligence some of the popular tools
are power bi tableau and click view hi
guys welcome to this tutorial on what is
power bi in this video you will learn
why power bi is needed what is power bi
the various features of power bi and the
different components of power bi later
you will look at the architecture of
power bi what power bi services and how
to create a power bi dashboard finally
you will understand a case study on myer
and do a demo using power bi now let's
understand why power bi is needed first
power bi has the ability to access vast
volumes of data from multiple sources it
allows you to view analyze and visualize
huge quantities of data that cannot be
opened in excel some of the important
data sources available in power bi are
xl csv xml json pdf etc second power bi
provides an easy to use drag and drop
tool with features and functionalities
that allow you to copy all formatting
across similar visualizations power bi
has exceptional integration with excel
it helps you gather analyze publish and
share excel business data power bi helps
to accelerate big data preparation with
azure using power bi with azure allows
you to analyze and share vast volumes of
data as your data lake can reduce the
time it takes to get insights and
increase collaboration between business
analysts data engineers and data
scientists power bi allows you to get
insights from data and turn insights
into actions to take data-driven
business decisions finally power bi
allows you to perform real-time stream
analytics it fetches data from multiple
sensors and social media sources to get
access to real-time analytics so you are
always ready to make business decisions
now let's see what power behavior is
power bi is a business analytics service
provided by microsoft that lets you
visualize your data and share insights
it converts data from different sources
to build interactive dashboards and bi
reports as you can see we have an excel
data about sales
using this data power bi helps you build
different charts and graphs to visualize
the data now that we have understood
what power bi is let us look at the
important features of power bi first is
power via desktop power bi desktop is a
free software that you can download and
it allows you to build reports by
accessing data easily for using power bi
desktop you do not need advanced report
designing or query skills to build a
report second as already discussed power
bi supports stream analytics from
factory sensors to social media sources
power bi assists in real-time analytics
to make timely decisions third support
for multiple data sources is one of the
major features of power bi you can
access various sources of data such as
excel csv sql server web files etc to
create interactive visualizations and
finally custom visualization custom
visualization is another vital feature
of power bi while dealing with complex
data power bi's default standard might
not be enough in some cases in that case
you can access the custom library of
visualization that meets your needs
let us jump into discussing the various
components of power bi as you can see
there are six major components of power
bi now let's discuss them one by one
first is power query power query is the
data transformation and match up engine
it enables you to discover connect
combine and refine data sources to meet
your analysis need it can be downloaded
as an add-in for excel or can be used as
part of power bi desktop second we have
powerpivot powerpivot is a data modeling
technology that lets you create data
models it also allows you to establish
relationships and create calculations it
uses data analysis expression language
or dax to model simple and complex data
third we have power view power view is a
technology that is available in excel
sharepoint sql server and power bi it
lets you create interactive charts
graphs maps and other visuals that
brings your data to life next we have
power map microsoft's power map for
excel and power bi is a 3d data
visualization tool that lets you map
your data and plot more than a million
rows of data visually on bing maps in 3d
format from an excel table or data model
in excel
then we have power via desktop power bi
desktop is a development tool for power
query power pivot and power view with
power bi desktop you have everything
under the same solution and it is easier
to develop bin data analysis experience
finally we have power q and a the q and
a feature in power bi lets you explore
your data in your own words it is the
fastest way to get an answer from your
data using natural language an example
could be what was the total sales last
year once you have built your data model
and deployed that into power bi website
then you can ask questions and get
answers easily
now let's see what power bi service is
power bi service is the software as a
service part of power bi it is also
referred as power bi online to access
power bi service you need to log in to
app.powerbi.com
now let me show you that i'll go to
google
open a new tab and search for
app.powerbi.com
loading
but this is how the home page of power
bi service looks like i have created
some dashboards on it first you need to
log into app.power bi service
you can see i'm logged in
now under my workspace if i go to
dashboard
here i have created
a finance dashboard you can see the
different charts and graphs i have
prepared and pinned it to the dashboard
so power bi service allows you to
connect to your data create reports and
dashboards and you can also ask
questions to your data
as you can see in this dashboard we have
created some charts and graphs so this
is a tree map there's a pie chart
there's a bar graph below you can see
the line charts and donor charts it
tells you the total sales that were made
the total number of units sold the sales
by product sales by country sales by
segment and lots more one of the key
features of power bi is creating
dashboards from multiple reports and
data sets power bi dashboard is a single
page visualization to tell a story the
visualizations on a dashboard are
generated from multiple reports and each
report is based on one data set a single
page dashboard is known as a canvas the
visualizations you see on the dashboard
are called tiles
these styles are pinned to the dashboard
by report designers
now let me go back to my dashboard so
this is called a canvas
and each of these
are called tiles so on the top you can
see we have three tiles now let's
understand how to create and publish
reports in power bi dashboards power bi
allows you to create different reports
on power bi desktop these reports can be
published on the power bi dashboard
using power bi service here you can see
there is a power bi report created on
power via desktop if you click on
publish
it will take you to the power bi service
where you can build a dashboard here is
the button for power bi publish once you
click on power bi publish it will take
you to the dashboard so this is a single
page power bi dashboard on power bi
service now let's understand the power
bi architecture power bi architecture is
a service built on top of azure there
are multiple data sources that power bi
can connect to power bi desktop allows
you to create reports and data
visualizations on the data set power bi
gateway is connected to on-premise data
sources to get continuous data for
reporting and analytics power bi
services are basically the cloud
services that are used to publish power
bi reports and data visualizations
using power bi mobile apps you can stay
connected to their data from anywhere
power bi apps are available for windows
ios and android platforms now let's look
at a case study on how mayer which is
one of united states largest supermarket
chains used power bi to solve its
business problems initially mayer had
become dependent on its it organization
to extract insights from its data it was
time consuming and inefficient as you
had to wait for it to build every report
meyer was unable to perform ad hoc and
real-time analysis easily so what maya
did was it connected power bi to an
on-premises sql server analysis services
cube this allowed them to refresh 20
billion rows of data in near real time
with power bi teams can now pull in the
data faster and perform real time
analysis to derive insights from data a
bakery department inside mayer used
power bi to compare its sales with
regional performance they analyzed where
meyer was behind the regional trends
focused on the problem and created a
solution with power bi they can now
drill down into hourly sales and send
out a sales flash to 800 maya business
leaders so power bi enabled them to
standardize data sources and empower
store directors and team leaders to
develop and track that data to ensure
what they can improve now let's do some
practical hands-on demo with power bi so
this is how the power bi desktop
interface looks like on the left you
have the report view the data view and
the model view the report view is where
you visualize your data with different
charts and graphs to build reports the
data view allows you to view the whole
data while the model view is where you
check if there are any relationship
between the tables
on the right you can see the different
visualizations that you can build we'll
quickly run through all of these in our
demo
so here you can see there's a finance
sample data that will help you draw
insights about the sale of products in
different countries we will create a
report to visualize different charts and
graphs and analyze those sales so let me
go to my power bi desktop first we'll
import our data so let me go to our get
data tab and choose excel as my data
source i click on excel so here is our
finance sample data
we'll select sheet1 you can see the data
here click on it and then select load
this might take some time to load the
data now if i go to my data tab you can
see the entire data set it has fields
such as segment country in which the
sales was made the name of the product
the units sold and the sales price and
many more let's start building our
report now i'll go to my report view so
first let me create a text box
let me resize it
let me name it as
finance dashboard will increase the size
of the text we'll use font consoles
center it will also add a background to
this use blue color change it to white
and
increase the size
now let me first show you how you can
create a matrix i'll go to
visualizations and click on matrix let
me resize it
from the datasheet tab i'll select sales
and drag onto values
so you can see the total number of sales
that were made now let me do some
formatting so i'll go to the format tab
click on column headers let's add a
background color and let me increase the
text size to
20.
similarly under values will increase the
size of the text
to 20 as well
we can also click on
border and choose the color of the
border we take as
let it be black so this is a simple
matrix that we created which shows the
total number of sales that were made
similarly let me choose matrix once
again now we'll drag on the units sold
onto values we'll continue with the same
drill under column headers we'll add a
background this time let's choose some
other color and under values let's
increase the size of the text to 20.
even for the column headers let's
increase the size of the text to 20.
again we'll switch on
border we resize a bit
so here we have two matrix created for
our report
the first matrix shows us the total
sales that were made the second matrix
shows you the total units that were sold
now let's move ahead and create a simple
bar chart so under visualization i click
on clustered column chart
under this we'll drag the date column on
to access and the sales onto value
let me expand it so it shows you the
sales per year this is the sales that
were made in 2013 and this shows you the
sales that were made in 2014.
now there's a drill down option which
gives you more granularity
this depicts the sales by quarter
if i drill down further you can see this
shows you the sales by month also you
have some options like sort buy and sort
by sales so you can see october month
made the highest number of sales
moving ahead let me now create a pie
chart where we will see the sales by
different segments
under visualization i'll click on pie
chart let me first resize it
here
i'll drag the segment column onto the
legend
and the sales column on to the values as
you can see we have the sales made by
different segments
government segment made the highest
number of sales with 44.22
now let me add a border to both the
visualization i'll click on the pie
chart and go to the format tab
i'll switch on the border similarly for
the clustered column chart i'll go to
the format tab and click on border and
let me resize a bit all right next we'll
create a very simple table that will
depict the total sales made by each
product so under visualizations i click
on table let me bring this below
so from the data sheet i'll first drag
product onto values
you can see the different products and
then sales just below it
so this depicts the total sales that
were made by each product and finally it
displays the total value of the sales
that were made this is same as the one
shown here
now let's do some formatting under
format tab i'll go to values and
increase the text size to 15
and expand it
also under column headers i'll increase
the text size to 15.
then let me go and add a border
now let me create a map that will show
you the sales that were made by each
country so first let me create a new
page and under visualization i'll click
on map now i'll drag the country column
onto location
so you can see we have our map ready and
we'll drag sales
onto size
you can see the different countries and
the sales that they made if i move the
map you can see the sales made in the
europe region
let me resize it i'll add a border to
this
now let me go ahead and create a donut
chart that will show you the profit by
each segment
under visualizations i'll click on donut
chart
and move this to the top
now from the data sheet i'll add profit
onto the values
and
segment onto the legend
if i expand this you can see government
segment made the highest amount of
profit with 65.04 percent
let me resize this and we'll add a
border
okay in the final visualization i'll
show you how to create a tree map this
tree map will tell you the total amount
of sales made by each product so under
visualizations i'll click on the tree
map let me expand it
i'll drag sales onto values and product
onto group so here you can see our tree
map and the sales made by each product
you can see now we have our report ready
we have created two separate canvas to
visualize our data
now if you want to change the color of
this bars then simply go to the format
tab and under data colors you can choose
whichever color you want in power bi
desktop you have an option to switch
your theme
this will make your dashboard or the
report look more attractive so now we
are under the default mode let's try out
different themes
that's frontier
temperature
solar which is a little yellowish the
one which i like is tidal
i hope this was helpful in making you
understand the basics of power bi and
how it works you learned the various
features and the components of power bi
and looked at the architecture of power
bi finally you saw a demo to create a
report using finance data set in our
previous video on what is power bi we
had learnt the basics of power bi its
features and components the architecture
of power bi followed by a demo in this
video we will learn what power bi
dashboard is we'll understand how to
create different reports in power bi
desktop then you will publish a
dashboard onto power bi service and
finally you'll derive insights from the
dashboard now let's understand what
power bi dashboard is power bi dashboard
is a single page visualization to tell a
story here on the screen you can see
there's a dashboard which has been
published on power bi service there are
multiple charts and graphs that you can
see the visualizations on a dashboard
are generated from reports and each
report is based on one data set a single
page dashboard is known as a canvas the
visualizations you see on the dashboard
are called tiles and each of these
styles are pinned to the dashboard by
report designers today we'll be covering
the following dashboard that you see on
the screen it will be a three page
report where we will be analyzing the
superstore sample data as you can see
there are three tabs now let me move
over to our data set so our super store
sample data set is in the form of an
excel file you can see there are
multiple columns you can see there's
order date shipment date the mode of
segment customers first name and last
name the segment to which the customer
belong to country of the customer the
city state and if you go towards the end
you can see that the different product
names the sales quantity sold discount
and the profit so the report that you
see here and the one which we are going
to create might vary a little in terms
of the color formatting and the spacing
so you need not worry about that now let
me go ahead and bring up a new workspace
so i'll go to file click on new this
will take some time to bring up our new
workspace now it will ask you for trying
the free version or if you want you can
go ahead and sign in i'll just close
this so here is our new workspace before
creating the dashboard we need to make
some changes to our super store data set
using the features of power bi desktop
first we'll extract the year month and
quarter values from the order date
column i'll go to get data tab click on
excel as my source i locate my file it's
on desktop click on open this might take
some time to load the data set i'll
select the orders sheet you can see the
preview of our data here i'll go ahead
and click on load this will take some
time to load the data set on to power bi
desktop i think we have successfully
loaded our data set you can check that
by going to the data tab so here is our
data set first let's make some changes
in the format of the order date and the
shipment date i'll click on the order
date under the modeling tab
we have this data type and the format
i'll click on the drill down option
and the date and time now let's choose
the first one which is in the format of
ddm yyyy
i'll click on it
as you can see our order date column has
been changed to that particular format
similarly i'll select the ship date
column
go to the format option under date and
time i'll click on the first one
here you can see even the ship date
column has been changed to that
particular format now let's extract the
month values from the order date column
to do that right click on the order date
column
select new column
so this will create a new column if you
go to the end
so there's a new column
rename this column as month and since we
want the month value from the ordered
date column i'll search for order date
dot since i want the month i'll select
month if i hit enter
it will give me the month values from
the order date column
similarly if you want to get the quarter
values from the order date
right click select new column
the column as quarter
[Music]
then choose the order date column
followed by the quarter
name hit enter
so you can see you have a quarter column
and it has all the values of the quarter
to which the date belongs to now let me
go ahead and create one more column
this time we'll create a new column for
the order year this time we'll extract
the order year values so let me rename
it as year we'll continue with the same
procedure i'll look for the order date
and then select the year
hit enter
so it gives you only the year values on
which the order was placed
now let's find which day of the week was
the order placed so we need to use the
weekday function and give the order date
as parameter followed by which day you
want the week to start with i'll show
you how to do that so i'll click on
order date
then
select new column
let's rename this column as day of week
i'll use the weekday function of power
bi and hit tab to finish i look for my
order date column
comma
i'll choose 2 here since i want my week
to start with monday and end on a sunday
hit enter
so you can see we have the day of the
week column
so the idea to create this day of week
column is to find out if the order was
placed on a weekday or a weekend now let
me go ahead and create one more new
column
let's name this column as
weekday
or a weekend
i'll use an if clause
and pass in my parameters for logical
test i'll use the day of the week column
so i'll search for orders
and then look for day of week if this
day of the week is equal to 6 which
means if it's a saturday or i'm using
the or operator
if the day of week is a sunday that is 7
then
it's a weekend
else it's a big day
close the bracket
hit enter so you can see we have our big
day and weekend column so moving ahead
another thing we can do is we can find
the total number of days it took for the
shipment of the product this can be done
using the dative function of power bi so
let me show you how you can do that i'll
click on any column right click go to
new column let's rename the column as
days
for
shipment then i'll use the datedif
function
i'll give my starting date which is the
order date so i'll search for
order date
followed by the second date will be our
shipment date which is ship date and the
day
i'll hit enter
so you can see here it gives us the
total number of days it took for the
shipment of the product
now let's create a full name column
where we will concatenate the first name
and the last name of the customer let me
go ahead and do that
i'll create a new column
let me rename the column as full name
then i'll take the first name
from the orders table
use the amber send
followed by a space using inverted
commas followed by another ampersand and
the last name
i hit enter
you can see we have a full name column
if you go back so there were two columns
in the name of first name and last name
now we have merged both the columns into
a single column named full name and you
can see the first name space and the
last name now let me give the sales
column
a currency value so i'll select the
sales column
here
under general
if i go to currency i can see there are
multiple currency symbols
choose whatever you want for this video
i'll take dollar english united states
you can see our sales column is now
represented by a dollar value similarly
let me make some changes to the profit
column as you can see there are multiple
decimal values for each profit so let's
standardize it
so i'll select the profit column
and this is where you can standardize it
now it's auto so let me
make it two decimal places
so our data is ready now let's go to the
report view and start building our
reports
before that
under the model view
you can see the new columns that we had
created you can see there's weekday
weekend this year
this quarter column month column
the same
you can see under the report view as
well
under fields
you can see these are the columns that
we created days of shipment day of week
quarter
month weekday or weekend and year now we
are under the report view first let me
go ahead and create a text box so under
the home tab you have the text box
i'll select that
let me stretch it a bit
we'll give a title
sales
dashboard
i'll select this and increase the size
to
let's say 28 we make it bold
and
center align it also
under the visualizations tab
under background
we'll add a background color to this
text box let me select this blue color
and let me make
the font as white
so now we have our title ready
so under general you can decrease the
height of the text box let me make it as
70.
first let us create a new card from the
visualizations panel so under
visualizations there is an option to
create new card i'll click on it
let me resize
i'll move it to the top
we'll see the total amount of sales or
the total revenue that was generated
from the sales
after selecting the card i'll choose
sales onto fields
so here you can see it gives you the
total sales that were made so which is
nearly 2.3 million dollars
if i go to the format tab under data
label
let me switch on the border
under title
you can give a new title for
example total
revenue hit enter
now you can
increase the text size to say 15
and center line it
you can also change the color of the
sales value so under data label
under colors you can choose whichever
color you want
similarly let's create one more card to
find the total number of units that were
sold i'll copy the same card
ctrl c ctrl v
i'll move it a little below
now i'll remove the sales column
from the fields and add
the quantity column
onto fields
again
under title
i'll edit this title as
total
quantity sold
let me create one more card
where we will see the total amount of
profit that were made
i'll select this
i'll remove the quantity column
and add profit
under the format tab
under title
i'll make this as
total
profit
hit enter
stretch it a bit so that you can see the
total amount of profit that were made
now
let me add a slicer
wherein
we'll have the order date column
so i'll add the order date column on to
fields
so you can see here we have the order
date column
and
under slicer header
let me increase the text size
to 15
and
let's switch on the border
you can also give a title to the slicer
so under the format tab
go to title
switch it on
and we'll give a title text as
slicer
by
order
date
scroll down
i'll center align it and
increase the text size to 15.
now if you want you can also change the
date colors
to blue so under date inputs then go to
font color and select any blue color
now let's create a line and stack column
chart to visualize sales and profit by
each year each month and each quarter
so from the visualizations tab
let me select line and stack column
chart
i'll resize this
after that let me add the order date
column onto the shared axis
we'll drag the sales onto column values
and under line values i'll take the
profit column
so here you can see we have the sales
and profit by each year
the bars represent the sales and this
line represents the profit it made for
each year
let me go to the format tab
and
make some changes to the data colors let
the color of the profit remain the same
but the bars i'll choose a custom color
give a hexadecimal value like
196273
hit enter
so we have successfully changed the
color of the bars
power bi has an interesting feature
where you can drill down the sales by
each year each month each quarter or by
days so let me show you so on the top it
shows you go to the next level in the
hierarchy
so if i click on this
here you can see the sales and the
profit that were made for each quarter
in every year
quarter 4 for every year made the
highest amount of sales and the profit
similarly if i drill down further you
can see let me expand it you can see by
month
this is
for each month
over all the years how much sales were
made
you can check november month gave us the
highest amount of sales and
december month gave us the highest
amount of profit
similarly you can still go to the next
hierarchy here you can see
the sales and the profit made for each
day
over all the years so days 17 made the
highest amount of sales
and day 23 gave us the highest amount of
profit if you see the lowest sales and
the profit you can see order date 25
gave us the lowest amount of profit
and similarly you can see day 29 gave us
the lowest amount of sales
now you can also go to the format tab
and switch on the data labels
so you can see here
in 2014
we got nearly 49.5 k profit and nearly
0.48 million dollar sales similarly in
2015 we had nearly 61.6 k profit and
0.47 million sales and so on
now let me go ahead to the format tab
and
switch on the border let me now create a
clustered column chart for sales by year
and quarter so from the visualizations
let's select clustered column chart let
me resize this a bit
and
under access
will add the year column
so i'll drag here on to access under
legend i'll take
the quarter column
and under values i'll choose sales
so you can see here the sales that were
made under each quarter for each year
this picture clearly says quarter 4 for
every year made the highest amount of
sales and quarter one
made the lowest
let me go to the format tab
and
i'll go to the data colors let's change
the colors for each of these quarters
we'll be using hexadecimal values so
under custom colors for quarter one
let me select hexadecimal value as
follows for example pf
d6
d9
similarly for quarter 2
i'll select
6d line
basics
for quarter 3
and finally for quarter 4
i choose a little darker color
so here is how our clustered column
chart looks like and we can see the
sales by year and quarter
now let me go ahead and
let's add a border now
we'll analyze the seals by each state so
for that
we'll use field map so i'll click on
field map
let me resize it
now let me add the state column onto
location
and the tool tips i'll
add the sales column
let me expand it so you can see here we
have the map which shows the sales by
each state
now let's do some color formatting to
this
i'll go to the format tab
click on add colors
and blue is the default color there is
an additional option
where you can use conditional formatting
so i'll use that so it gives you the
option to choose your color between
maximum value and the minimum value you
can also choose this diverging option
where you get a center value or a mid
value as well now for the minimum value
i'll choose a color again i'll use a
custom color
it will be similar to a green color
hit okay
then
let's use
some orange color for the mid value
range for example
eb
and similarly for the maximum value
we'll use a little darker color which
looks similar to red
click enter so now we have defined our
color scheme
let's click on ok
let's zoom out so you can see the states
which are in green color make the lowest
amount of sales while those which are in
orange or in red made the highest amount
of sales so in this example you can see
california had the highest amount of
sales similarly new york is next is just
below california with the amount of
sales followed by texas we'll go back
let me
also
add a border to this similarly
you can also select the profit column or
the unit sold column to see the units or
the profit that were sold by each state
so let me now go ahead and create a
donor chart in that donor chart we'll
analyze the sales and profit by each
segment
so under visualizations i click on donut
chart
so under legend i'll add the segment
column
under values i'll take the sales column
and
we also want the profit so i'll take
the profit column on to tooltips
so you can see we have our donor chart
prepared and you can see the sales and
profit by each segment
let me expand this the donut chart
indicates consumer segment made the
highest amount of sales and profit
while home office segment made the
lowest
i'll go back
let me go to the format tab
and we'll make some formatting to our
data
let's change the color of all the
segments
choose custom color
let's give a color
coding as
1558c
similarly we'll change
the color for corporate segment as well
let's take a gray color
and finally we'll change the color for
home office as well
i'll also switch on the border
so we have our donut chart prepared now
let's move ahead and create a pie chart
to analyze the profit and sales by each
category of products so under
visualizations i'll select pie chart
i'll drag the category column on to
legend
under values i'll take the profit column
and under tool tips i'll take the sales
column
so you can see we have a simple pie
chart that tells you the profit and the
sales that were made by each category
as its evident category technology made
the highest amount of sales and profit
while furniture category made the lowest
amount of profit and sales
i'll go back
under format
i'll change the data colors
let's go ahead and do that
i'll use custom colors and give
hexadecimal color value
similarly for office supplies
i'll take another hexadecimal value
and finally we'll change the color of
the furniture category
also
let's give a border
so we have a pie chart prepared that
tells you the profit and sales by each
category of products
now we are done with our first sales
dashboard so i can go ahead
and rename
this tab as
overall
sales
next we are going to analyze the sales
profit quantity sold and all of these
by taking region and the state as
filters so we'll continue with the same
drill first i'll create a text box
so under home menu i'll go to text box
i'll stretch
this i'll give a title to this page for
example
region
and
state
level analysis
let me make it bold
and
i'll increase the size to 28
make it center aligned
we'll make the text
as white
and
under visualizations
let's give a background color
i'll choose this blue color
so let me go ahead and create three
slicers a region slicer a state slicer
and a ear slicer
so under visualizations i'll click on
slicer
let me resize
move it on top
and
for region slicer i need to add region
onto fields
so you can see
we have a region filter now
let's do some formatting to this
under slicer header
let me make the font color
white
and
let's give a background
let's say blue
and let me increase the text size to
say 15.
you can also choose a font family
let's go for calibri
and
you can increase the size
of the items
let's increase the text size
to
say 15
and
let's give a border
so now you have the region slicer ready
let me copy paste this
next
we'll create the state slicer so i'll
remove region from here and add
state onto the field
you can see we have the state slicer
ready similarly
you can also go ahead
and create
a year slicer
where you can analyze the sales and
profit or quantity by year
i'll remove state from here
and
i'll drag the year column on to field
you can see we have all the four years
from 2014 to 2017. now sometimes it
might be difficult for you to scroll
through all the values present in a
slicer for example
in the state slicer
you can see there are multiple states
and if you want to filter your report by
a particular state
you have to always scroll down or scroll
up and check manually where the state is
so power bi gives you this feature where
you can use the search option
so
if i click on this
you can see there's a search option
select that so now
in the search bar you can search for any
state you are looking for for example if
you want to search for california state
you can just type on california so i've
just typed cal and it shows me
california that's an important feature
that power bi gives you
so let me now go ahead and create a
simple table where we will see the
quantity and the profit made in each
city so under visualizations i'll select
tables
let me resize this
so under values first i'll add the city
column
followed by
the quantity column
and
the profit column
let's do some formatting
so under column headers
let me change the font color to white
and let's add a background
let me increase the
text size also
let's make it 15.
similarly if you scroll down under
values
let's increase the text size
to 15 as well
and
let's choose the font family
let's take consoles
so here
you can see all the cities
the quantity
sold in each city and the profit that
was made in each of these cities
now let me add a border to this
so now you can filter each of the cities
by region or by state
for example if i choose central
as my region
it will give you all the cities that lie
in the central region
similarly
you can also search for any state for
example
i am taking minnesota
so under minnesota
you can see all the cities
and the quantity as well as the profit
that made
let me now uncheck the filters
now let me go ahead and filter this
table
in terms of profit so i'll sort by
profit
you can see
we have our cities sorted in terms of
profit
so new york city made the highest amount
of profit followed by los angeles and
seattle below you can see the total
units that were sold and the total
profit that was made from all the cities
so you can also filter down the quantity
sold and the profit made by each year as
well as by region and state
so let's see
suppose i am choosing
east as the region
so under east it tells you the states
that are present
let's
go for delaware
and let's select 2016 as my year
so you can see
the cities
that lie under delaware state
and the quantity as well as the profit
they made in 2016. similarly let's
select
massachusetts as the state and let's
go for another year for example 2017
you can see
all the cities that are present under
massachusetts the quantity sold and the
profit that was made below you can see
the total quantity and the profit
let me uncheck all these
now moving ahead
let's analyze the sales by each state
and the category of product for this
we'll create a clustered bar chart so
under visualizations i'll select
clustered bar chart let me resize a bit
under access
i'll take the state column
i'll take category on to legend
and under values
i'll put the sales column
so you can see here
we have the sales for each category
under each state
for example california state made the
highest amount of sales under technology
category and it made the lowest amount
of sales under office supplies
if i scroll down you can see all the
states
and the sales they made
for each category
i'll go back to the report
now let's use some filters
you can filter here for example if i
want to check
the sales by each state and category for
2015 i can just
click on 2015
and it will tell you the sales that were
made
now
let's do some formatting to this bar
chart
we'll change the colors for each of the
categories
similarly we change the color for office
supplies
and finally for the technology
so now we have our bar chart ready
moving on now let me add a border to
this bar chart
okay
so now that we have seen our sales by
state and category let's now check the
profit by year and category for that
we'll create an area chart
i'll resize this chart
now
under axis
i'll take the year column
under legend i'll take the category
column
and
under values
i'll take profit
so we have an area chart that depicts
the profit by each year and the category
to which the product belong to
i'll go to the format tab
and under data colors
i'll choose some colors
let's change furniture to this blue
color
i'll take office supplies
red color
and technology i'll use a green color
so now you can use the filters
for example you can check the profit
that was made by each year and category
under east region
so you can see here
in 2017 technology made the highest
amount of profit while furniture
at the lowest
similarly
let's
check for south region
you can see in south region in 2016
technology made the highest amount of
profit
and
furniture made the lowest in 2017
office supplies made the highest amount
of profit and furniture was the lowest
i'll uncheck this south region filter
similarly you can also see the sales by
each state so under state slicer you can
choose whichever state you want and
check the profit it made by that year or
category
for example i'll choose connecticut
so you can see the profit connected cut
state made in each of these years
i'll uncheck it
let us move ahead and now let's see
profit that was made and the quantity
that was sold by each category and
subcategory of the product so for this
i'll choose the line and cluster column
chart so i'll select from the
visualizations now
under shared access
i'll select the category column under
column series i'll take the sub category
column
under column values
i'll choose profit
and
i'll choose quantity
under the tooltips
so now you can see
the profit that was made under each
category and the sub category
for technology category
copiers sub category made the highest
amount of profit the quantity sold was
234
similarly
if you check for furniture category
we didn't make any profit for table sub
category
and as well as for book cases
under office supplies paper subcategory
made the highest amount of profit
now let me go ahead
and add a border to this
fine
moving ahead now we will see the seals
by each segment for that
let's create a funnel so from
visualizations i'll take the
funnel
and
i'll drag
segment onto group
and the sales column onto values
so you can see here
the sales that were made by each segment
this picture clearly depicts that
consumer segment made the highest amount
of sales
next was corporate and then home office
now
let's do some color formatting so the
default color is this blue
i'll click on so all
now we'll give individual colors to each
of the segments
using custom color
let's give a hexadecimal value
similarly we change the color for the
corporate segment
and finally for the home office segment
now let me go ahead and give a border to
it
so if you want to analyze the sales
by segment and for
a particular region or state or any
particular year you can do that so let's
select
for east region
and
let's take
new jersey as the state
for year 2014 suppose
so you can see here
corporate segment made the highest
amount of sales followed by consumer and
home office
let me uncheck
these filters
so our second report is ready where we
analyzed the sales quantity profit at
region level state level and by year so
i can rename this
as
region and state
next we will analyze the sales quantity
profit
in terms of categories and sub-category
of products so let me first copy this
text box
and
create a new
tab i'll paste that text box here and
change the title to
say
category
and
sub category level analysis
first
we'll create a
slicer
where we'll take
the category as filter
so
if i want i can directly copy it
from my previous tab
and change the fields so let me copy
this
and paste it here
i'll sync it
and let me remove the region field and
add
category onto the field
so you can see
we have the three categories here
let me copy paste this again
and
let me take the sub category now
so i'll select this
and
i'll drag subcategory onto the field so
here you can see we have all the sub
categories
and above we have the categories
let me resize this a bit
with that now let's analyze the sales
and profit by region and segment
to do this we'll use a tree map
so let's see how you can build a tree
map under visualizations i have tree map
let me select it
and move it to the top
and expand it a bit
now
under group
i'll select region column
under details i'll take
segment
i'll take the sales column under values
and
let's take profit
on two tooltips
so if i expand this
you can see the sales and profit by each
region and segment for example in the
west region you have
consumer corporate and home office
as the segments and you can see
consumer segment made the highest amount
of sales and profit
while home office made the lowest amount
of sales and profit
similarly you can check for the other
regions as well
now
let's give a border to this tree map and
under data colors let me change the
color of the regions
scroll down
custom color
let me choose my own color
let's take this as a gray color
and finally
for the west region
so now you can select individual
categories and sub categories to check
the sales and profit by region and
segment for example
if i select
furniture as my category
you can see the changes that were made
to the tree map
you can also select office supplies and
see
how the sales and profit changes
similarly you can also go ahead
and select whatever sub categories you
want
and then check the sales and profit by
region and segment with that let me now
create a pie chart
to see the quantity and the sales by
each segment
so i'll go and select a pie chart
let me resize this
if you want you can increase the size of
this tree map also
so let me go ahead
and select segment onto the legend
under values i'll take
quantity
and
sales under tooltips
so this pie chart
depicts the quantity and the sales that
were made by each segment as you can see
consumer segment made the highest amount
of sales and had the highest quantity
sold
while home office had the least number
of quantity sold and the least number of
sales
let's add a border
and change the data colors
similarly i'll change the color for the
corporate segment let's make this
gray
and home office
i'll take the following color
move this a little to the right
now let's build a scatter plot to
analyze the sales quantity and profit by
each sub category
so under visualizations
i'll select scatter plot i'll resize
this
so i'll add
subcategory
onto legend
then i'll add sales onto the
x-axis
quantity sold onto the y-axis
and under size
will take the profit column
if i expand this
you can see the sales quantity and the
profit that was made for each
subcategory of products you can see here
subcategory phone has given us a
significant amount of sales with less
number of quantities sold and it has
given us a good amount of profit also
similarly sub category chairs has also
given us good amount of sales with close
to
2356 quantities sold and a good amount
of profit if you see this one which is
sub category paper it gave us less
amount of sales with more quantities
sold
while it gave us good amount of profit
though so you may promote phones or for
example chairs to sell more since it
gives you more amount of profit with
less quantity sold
let's add a border to this
you can use the category filter suppose
if i choose for furniture
and expand this
you can see
under furniture subcategory furnacings
gave us the lowest amount of sales with
the highest number of quantities sold
but it gave us a decent amount of profit
sub category tables gave us a decent
amount of sales with lesser number of
quantities sold but didn't give us any
profit
subcategory chairs gave us the highest
amount of sales and also the profit
i'll uncheck this
let's now create a line chart where we
can see the profit by each year and
quarter
so under visualizations
i'll select line chart
let me resize this
so under access
i'll take year
under legend
i'll take the quarter column
and under values
i'll take the profit column
so now you can see
the profit that was made
each year
and
the lines depict each quarter
so if you check for 2014
quarter four meet the highest amount of
profit while quarter two made the lowest
amount of profit while quarter one made
the lowest amount of profit similarly if
you see for 2016 you can see
quarter four made the highest amount of
profit
while quarter one made the lowest
if you check for 2017 you see quarter
three and quarter four almost made the
same amount of profit while
quarter two made the lowest amount of
profit
i go back now you can filter these by
categories also suppose if i see for
technology
you can check the amount of profit that
was made in each year and in each
quarter for technology category
let's add a border to this
likewise we'll now create another line
chart that will depict the sales by each
year and quarter
so let me copy paste this
i'll drag this to the right
now i'll remove
profit from values and add sales
let me uncheck this also
so here you can see we have the sales by
each year and quarter
now if you see for 2014 again quarter
four made the highest amount of sales
and quarter one in 2014 made the lowest
you see for 2016 you can see 2016 also
quite a four made the highest amount of
sales and quarter one made the lowest
go back
so our final report is ready where we
analyzed the sales quantity sold the
profit at category and subcategory level
i can go ahead and rename this as
category
and
subcategory
let me save this now if you want
you can also filter it by sub categories
for example if i select
chairs as my subcategory
so for chairs you can see the sales that
was made by each year and quarter
so in 2017 quarter four made the highest
amount of sales
while quarter one made the lowest amount
of sales for chairs
similarly
you can select other sub categories also
for example
let me take
some other category like
machines
let's see the profit now
so for machine sub category you can see
in 2014 quarter four made the highest
amount of profit while
quarter three
made the lowest amount of profit
now if you check for 2015 you can see
quarter three made the highest amount of
profit in chairs while quarter one made
the lowest amount of profit
let's uncheck this
so now we are almost done building our
report using the superstore sample data
set
so we have our three reports ready you
can see the first one was overall sales
the second report we created
by taking region state and the year as
filters so we had a region and state
level analysis and finally we analyzed
the sales quantity and the profit sold
by category and subcategory so i have
arranged all these graphs and charts so
that it looks little better now
let me go to this publish option on the
top so that we can publish this report
onto the power bi dashboard
so i'll click on publish
save it
you can select the destination here i
have only one destination which is my
workspace so i'll choose it
and select
so there you go publishing to power bi
it was successful
i'll close it
and
let me move to
my power bi service
i'll refresh it for once
so under
my workspace
you can see
we have
the dashboard report
so below you can see there are three
tabs that we created the first one is
overall sales
the second one is sales by region and
the third one is by category and
subcategory
now
to put this reports onto the dashboard i
need to pin each one of these
visualizations
so
let me pin one by one
so it asks where would you want to pin
it to i'll select the existing dashboard
or better let's create a new dashboard
let's say
power bi
dashboard
spin it
i'll close this
similarly let's spin the remaining ones
i'll select power bi dashboard again pin
it
let's spin everything
so this slicer you can't pin it
let's do the remaining ones
same will do for
the donut chart
as well as
for the pie chart
now
now if i go to
my dashboards
and select power bi dashboard
you can see
we have a one page
dashboard
here
you can resize
all the charts and graphs
let me resize it
and move it to the top
so we have our first canvas here
which tells you the overall sales the
profit and the units that were sold over
different states different segments
and by categories
so one of the important feature that
power bi service gives you is that you
can ask questions about your data and it
will tell you what the exact solution is
for example you can see here you have a
field where you can ask questions so for
example if i type
total sales
and hit enter
so it tells you the total amount of
sales that were made which is 2.3
million dollars similarly if i want to
find out the total
profit i can search for it here
hit enter
it will give you the exact amount of
profit that was made
let's do something else for example if
you want
total
profit
by
say year
and hit enter it gives you a nice line
chart where you can see the total profit
that was made over all the four years
next
suppose i search for total
quantity
sold
by
segment
see it gives me a bar chart where you
can see the total quantity that was sold
and
it gives you a list of options where you
can find out the total quantity that was
sold by city state order id first name
last name and many others so consumer
segment had the highest quantity sold
let's see for something else for example
if you want
the total
sales
by
say subcategory
i'll choose the first one
see you have all the sub categories and
the total sales that they made so it's a
very interesting feature that power bi
gives you
go back
now if you want
you can go to the report menu
and if you want you can pin
the other visualizations as well
so another important feature about power
bi dashboard is that you can derive
insights from the visualization for
example
if i click on these dots
there's an option you find view insights
i'll select it
so on the right you can see power bi has
itself given us some insights from the
data and the visualizations we have made
you can see sales by year and quarter
the sales by day of week and quarter
sales by shipment mode where you can see
the standard classic mode made the
highest amount of sales
you can also see the sales and count of
city by year
and many more
in this video we'll be creating two
dashboards using a sample sales dataset
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email ids
in the comments section of the video our
team will share the files via email now
let's begin by understanding what is a
dashboard in excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards
an advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding
let's jump into our demo
for creating our dashboards we'll be
using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo
so this data set was actually generated
using a simulator and is completely
random
it was not validated though we have
applied certain transformations to the
data using power query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly
if i go on top you can see
this data set has
17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have middle east and
north africa there's north america
asia
sub-saharan africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits etc
then we have the representative's name
or you can see this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales channel column so
there are basically two channels
whether the item was sold offline or
online
next we have the order priority column
now here c stands for critical
then we have h which is for high
priority orders then we have m for
medium priority orders and finally we
have l which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column
then we have the order id the ship date
next we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column
this is the price at which
each product was sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column
now the total cost column is actually
the product of units sold and the unit
cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally
we have created two more columns that is
order year and then we have
order month now these two columns were
actually generated using the power query
features
so we use the order date column which is
this column and extracted order year and
order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for revenue by order
year revenue by year and region revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate pivot tables and
pure charts and format them to make them
look more interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this
i'll click on a cell in my data set
and then i'll go to the insert tab
here we have the option to select the
pivot table
i click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next i want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on ok
there you go
so we have a new sheet where i can place
my pivot table
so first
i need to find the total revenue
generated by each year so what i'll do
is
i'll drag my order year column
under rows
and then
i'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see i have my pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order year from 2010
to 2017.
now
based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so i'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts i
click on this
now actually i want a line chart so i'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go
so we have successfully created our
first pivot chart
now
let me show you how you can format this
chart to make it more readable
so first
let me delete
these so i'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the
buttons present on the chart
now
let me go ahead and
edit the chart title
so the title i want is total revenue
i'll type it down
by year
all right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if i click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines legend and others
okay
so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total legend is gone
now let me
add access titles so we label our x axis
and y axis
so here under x axis
i can
write it as
year similarly on the y-axis i'll put
revenue
okay now you can move
a bit
all right
now
let me select this chart style option
and go to colors first
here i'll select
yellow color
okay
and then let me go back to style
let's select a new style from this list
i want
this style
okay
now
you can also add
data labels so i'll just click on data
labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all
so we'll format this a bit
if i click on this arrow here i have
more options
if i scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
i'll expand this
and under category
i'll select custom
now here
we'll give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so i'll write if my revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
99 000
let me make sure there are 6
nines here so one two three four five
and six okay we are good to go
i'll close the bracket
i'll give a hash
give two commas
so if the revenue is greater than
9 lakhs 99 000
i'll put it in the format of millions so
within double quotes i'll write m
i'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be
0 million
let me click on add
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data
and you see here we have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and
adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up
i'll delete this
now if you notice this line chart you
can make a few conclusions
for example if you see here in 2010
the total revenue generated was nearly
175 million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011
then the revenue constantly grew from
2011 till 2014
it reached 195 million
and after
2014 it again came down to
180 million
and the revenue dropped significantly
between 2016 and 2017.
in 2017 the revenue was just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet
so i'll write it as
revenue
by
year
all right
now
let's analyze the revenue generated each
year in different regions so for this
we'll create another pivot table
let me close this
i'll click on any cell
go to insert and select pivot table
i just click ok so that my pivot table
is placed on a new sheet all right
now this time we want the revenue
by each year and region
so first of all
let's drag
region to
columns
then
let's drag the order year column under
rows
and then
i'll select total revenue on to values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready
so for 2010 you can see in asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly
if you see for 2013
this was the total revenue generated in
europe
and
we have for other years as well
now let's
create a line chart based on this pivot
table so i'll select any cell in the
pivot table i'll go to insert
and i'll click on recommended charts
from this list i'll select my line chart
and click on ok
there you go
so we have our next
pivot chart ready
so
on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the regions we have
so in total we have
seven regions
and each of the regions have been
represented in different colors
so if you notice this graph
for the
sub-saharan african region
in 2012
sub-saharan africa made the
highest amount of sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue for north america has
been significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see
for
europe
this was the revenue trend between 2010
and 2017.
so if you see here in 2011 the sales
were at this level then it significantly
dropped in 2012
then in 2013
there was a huge spike and then and
again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these
line charts
now let's
format this chart so first of all let's
delete the
field buttons present on the chart
and we'll also
delete the legend
all right now
let me just reduce the size of the chart
next
we'll
add a chart title
so
we'll
give the title as
revenue
by
year end
region
okay
you can also format the y-axis in terms
of millions
so i'll right click on this axis
and i'll select format axis
i'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down
let me scroll again
under category i'll select custom
and
we'll use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can
reduce the font size or increase the
font size let me just show you suppose
you want to increase the font size of
the chart title so you just select it
and from here you can either reduce or
you can increase you can see now it's 12
if you want you can make it 16.
similarly you can also edit the
access labels also
by selecting the chart title you can
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as well for the
time being let me just keep it to the
left
all right
now
we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region and we'll create a combo
chart for this
so let me show you how to do it
i'll go to my data sheet
i have my cell selected
go to insert and click on pivot table
let me just click on ok
alright
so for this
i'll select
my region onto rows
and then
i'll have
two columns under values the first one
is
going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column
all right so here we have the pivot
table ready now based on this pivot
table
let's create our pivot chart so i'll go
to recommended charts and if you see
below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the
preview of the combo chart
all right now let me just click on ok
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is
the bars represent the total revenue
which is this column
now
the line represents
the total cost
so
let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right
and let's also remove the legend from
here
next
we'll add
data labels so i'll click on data labels
here okay so these are the
data labels for
the bars or
the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so i'll click on this arrow go
to more options
if i scroll down
i have number
from here i'll select custom and
i'll choose my type that is in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our
data
next thing we'll add
a chart title
so here i'll write as
revenue
by
region
it's actually
revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well i'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly sheet3 also i am going to
rename it as
revenue
by
year
and region
so this
makes your sheet more readable
all right
now moving ahead
next
we are interested to get the revenue
generated by order priority
and for this we are going to create a
pie chart
so let's go to the data sheet
and create our pivot table first
i click on ok
now
i'll select order priority under rows
and under values i'll select
total revenue
so this is a
very simple pivot table so you have your
order priority so c is for critical h is
for high l is for low and m is for
medium
now based on this
let's create a pie chart
so i'll go to recommended charts and
here you have
pie chart
i want to select
this 3d type of pie chart
and i'll click on ok
alright so we have our pie chart ready
let me just resize it
and from here i'll remove the field
buttons
and i also don't need the legend so i'll
delete this as well all right
now let's give a chart title so this is
going to be
revenue by
order
priority
now let's add
our data labels
i'll
check this option
okay
now let's again format this in terms of
millions
so here
i'll click on the last option i'll go to
numbers under category i'll select
custom
and
my type is going to be in terms of
millions there you go
let me close this
i will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you want you can change the color
of the text as well
so let's have it in
white color and see how it looks okay so
this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue
by
i'll just put op which stands for order
priority
all right
now
let's create our horizontal bar chart
i'll go to insert
click on pivot table
and select ok
so i want my revenue based on different
countries so i'll select country
and put it under rows
and then
i'll choose total revenue and place it
under values
so here you have the different country
names we have afghanistan this albania
let me scroll down you have bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have czech
republic there's estonia france gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have india there's jamaica italy
and all the way to the bottom if we go
we have new zealand this netherlands
philippines portugal
we also have
singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the uae united states of america
zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
so based on this pivot table let's
create our pivot chart
so i will go to insert
and select recommended charts
from here
i am going to select the column chart
you can see the preview here and let me
click on ok
all right
so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and
the revenue for each of the countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart
so first of all i'll delete
the field buttons okay
and let me also remove the legend
here i'll write
revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my
chart title
okay
let's format this chart a little more
so i'll click on this option and we'll
select a new style let's say
i'll select
style 6
okay
and
let me now go under colors and we'll
select the color of the bars so
let's choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue by
countries
and hit enter
ok
and finally
we create another report which is going
to be part of our revenue dashboard and
this is
revenue by items so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have cosmetics
vegetables cereal fruits this cloth
snacks households and other products as
well
so let's check the revenue for each of
these items
so we'll continue the same drill i'll
create my pivot table on a new worksheet
and this time i'm going to drag
item type under rows
and
will have the total revenue under values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different
item names and then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
short this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so
you can see here office supplies made
the highest amount of revenue
followed by household then cosmetics
and fruits
made the lowest amount of revenue
i'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts
this time i'm going to create a bar
chart so this is how my bar chart is
going to look like
i'll select ok
alright
now let's format this chart a bit
i'll delete the field buttons
and i'll delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
revenue
by
items
cool
we also want to
change the
color of the bars so i've selected all
the bars i'll go to my home tab
and here let's say i want to select
green color
all right
i've edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
14
and i'll remove the bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
i'll create a new sheet
and first thing i'm going to do is
i'll click on the view tab and
uncheck grid lines so this will remove
the gridlines present in the worksheet
next
i'm going to insert an image
so we'll have a background image
on our dashboard
so the way to do is i'll go to the
insert tab and under illustrations
i have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so i'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
i'll go to desktop and here i have a
folder called
excel dashboard files
and i'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so i'll hit shift and i'll drag it
all right
so you can see i have successfully
added a background image if you want you
can still
expand this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so i'll click
on insert and here
i have the option to select
a text box
so
i'll click on a text box and
i'm going to place a text box in the
middle
and i'm going to name this text box as
excel
revenue dashboard
on
sales
i'll
centralize it
let's do some more formatting so i'll
select this text box on the top you can
see shape format
here
i'm going to expand this
shape fill
and i'll select no fill
so
my text box is transparent now and i'll
also remove
the outline
all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and i'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to
britannica bold
and i'll increase the size to let's say
30
all right
i'll just
drag the
text box
i'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so i'll go to
insert and i'll click on illustrations
again
and select
pictures
i'm going to add
this two pictures which is of a store
and a cart
to make it look
visually appealing
so i'll
place the icons
here and similarly let me just copy it
and i'll place the
cart and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so i'll
hit
ctrl v to paste it and we'll resize this
as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see i have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts our
column charts the combo charts this pie
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and
format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered
so let's adjust the
labels let me bring this down
similarly i'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right
this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the
white background from each of the charts
and make it transparent so let me show
you how to do it so i'll select this
chart
then i'll right click
and go to
format chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called no fill so if i select no
fill you can see the white background
is gone now
similarly let me also remove the grid
lines so i'll select the gridlines and
hit delete so you have also removed the
grid lines from here
now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so i'll select this chart
go to format
and here
i'll go to shape outline and i'll select
no outline
you see this
so we have our total revenue by year
which is a line chart and this is
completely transparent now now what i'm
going to do is
i'll place this chart over a box
so i'll go to insert and in insert we
have the option to create a shape
so i'll
click on illustrations and here i'll
choose a shape and let me select
a rectangle
so i'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now
what i'll do is
i'll select this and bring this to front
i'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and i'll place this
shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first i'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color
and
and let me increase the transparency so
i'll
right click and go to format shape
here i'll increase the transparency
let's keep it to
25 percent
or let's say
20 percent
all right
next thing we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the access labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better
now we'll just
adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so i'll go to shape
outline and i'll select no outline
you see
we have now formatted our chart
let's just
pull this a little up
all right
now we'll add
this blue background to all the other
charts so we'll first add the background
make it transparent and then we'll
convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible
so
for the time being i'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens
we have nicely formatted our dashboard
so i've added a few logos for
each of the
charts you can see the logos here so for
revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the
labels in terms of millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year and region are all
formatted in terms of millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by revenue in terms of
millions
so the way to do is you can select this
graph
right click and go to format access
here if i scroll down
you have numbers
and
under category i'll select custom
then i'll select my type as
this format
which is in millions
and
you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to our
dashboard
now slicers are used to format your data
based on a particular column suppose if
you want to see revenue by certain items
you can add item as a slicer and you can
view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add
date columns so if you want to see what
was the amount of sales or revenue
generated on a particular year or a
particular month you can do that using a
timeline and here you can see under
filters we have slices and timeline or
if you go to the
pivot chart analyze tab
here also you have
insert slicer and timeline option
so i'll select insert slicer here first
now it's giving me the list of
fields present in the
data set
so i'll select
country
region
and let's say
we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers i'll click on ok
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values under region we have asia
this europe north america and others
similarly we have the different country
names for country slicers
and then for item type also we have all
the items that were present in our data
set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slicers to a dashboard so what
i'll do is
i'll right click
on this option
and i'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to
select all the pivot tables
so let me check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on ok
alright now that we have connected
one of our slicers we'll now connect the
other
remaining slicers
so i'll right click on this go to report
connections
and i'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on ok
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer
i'll go to report connections
and let me select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have
the item type so i'll right click
go to report connections and then i'll
select
all my pivot tables and let's hit ok
all right now let me just
organize this a bit so i'll
place my pivot tables
to the right
i'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
i'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
i'll add my final slicer that is sales
channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be
the profit dashboard i'll show you how
to add a timeline
all right
now i have arranged all my slicers
so let's say you want to find the
revenue that was generated for
an item type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
so the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for beverages
only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for
beverages item type
if i scroll down
now this chart represents the
revenue that was generated in each of
the countries only for item type
beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
india
so i have selected india here
and now you can see
my graph has changed only for
country india
you can see here it is showing only for
india now
now similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to
know the revenue generated
based on sales channels so we have two
sales channel that is offline and online
suppose you want to know the revenue
generated offline so i'll just
select
offline you can see
the values have changed so these were
the revenues generated for each of the
items only for offline
if you
see here now these were all the
offline seals for the different regions
so
this is
our entire
excel revenue dashboard on sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied
different formatting we added
different icons then we formatted the
labels also
next we added
slicers and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this
sheet as
revenue dashboard i'll write rev
dashboard
okay
now
we'll move to our data sheet and
start creating our pivot tables and
pivot charts for the profit dashboard
alright so let me go ahead and create my
first pivot table
so
i'll create
a new worksheet
this time i am going to create a line
chart
to visualize the profit for each year
so i will drag my
total profit column
to values
and
my order year to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data
to
get an idea
as to
which year had the highest profit and
which year had the lowest profit so from
this pivot table
you can see
since i have sorted this data in
descending order so 2014
had the maximum amount of profit
and 2017 had the least amount of profit
i'll just do control z to undo it all
right now based on this pivot table let
me go ahead and create my po chart so
i'll go to recommended charts and click
on a line chart so this is the preview
of the chart
i'll click on ok
let me close this
similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first i'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart
and i'll
rename the chart title as
total
profit
by year
next i'm going to remove the legend so
i'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
i'll go to style
and
this time
i'm going to select
my style type okay
and if you want you can
choose the colors as well for the time
being let's have
this yellow color
next let me add the
data labels
so again if you see here this is not
formatted properly
so let's go ahead and format the
data labels
so i'll click on number
and i'll select custom here
and the type i'm going to select is in
millions
and i'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next
we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this i'm going to create a map so let me
first create my pivot table
so i'll go to insert and i'll click on
pivot table
let me click on ok
since i want the country names so i'll
select country under rows and then i
have
my total profit under values
the next thing i'm going to do is i'll
just rename the row labels as
countries
and then
i'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom
so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so i
am going to select this pivot table
go to the design tab
here we have subtotals and grand totals
i'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again i'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right
now
we want to create a map out of this the
way to do is
i'm going to select my data
copy it
i'll go on top
and i'll paste it here
using this data i can create my field
map now so i'll go to insert
here we have the option to create a
field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
i can expand this
as you can see
our map has a color scale which comes
from light gray color to dark blue color
so the countries that are in gray or you
can say light blue
have the lowest amount of profit
while the regions or the countries that
have been shaded in
dark color a dark blue color have
highest amount of profit
i will go ahead and delete this
scale
okay
next
we need to connect this
map to the original data source so what
i'll do is
i'll right click on this map and i'll go
to select data
here instead of the previous range i'll
give my
new range now so
my new range
will be my original pivot table that i
had created
i'll go on top and click on ok
so we have our
map ready now
now if you want you can change the
color of the shade so i'll just go to
colors
and let's say we'll keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
are the countries that made
least amount of profit
okay
now moving on
next
we want to create
a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales channel
so for this we are going to create
another line chart
so i'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so i'll select
new worksheet
here
since i want to know the profit by year
first of all i'll drag my order year
column to rows
and then
i'll choose my total profit column under
values
next i'm going to select my sales
channel under columns
there you go so we have our pivot table
here
now based on this pivot table let me
create my pivot chart so i'll go to
recommended charts
and i'm going to create a line chart
close this
you see here
based on this
chart you can tell
the profit generated with
online
sales were actually
lower than that of offline so here the
blue line represents offline profit and
the orange line represents online profit
if you mark clearly
in year 2012 the online profit was
actually higher than the offline profit
so
let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so we'll delete the field buttons
i'll also delete the legend for now
let me go ahead and
add
a chart title so i'll write
profit
by
year
and
sales
channel
okay
so this is my
second report
before moving ahead let me just
rename this sheet so i'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say sc for sales channel
okay
moving ahead
now i want to
create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
the profit by sales channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
i'll first
go to insert click on pivot table and
click on ok
so i'll drag my sales channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table now
let's create our pivot chart which is
going to be a pie chart
let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so i'm going to select a donut
chart here i click on ok
let's
edit this chart i'll remove the field
buttons
let me now remove the legend as well
i'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again
i'm going to
format this label
i'll select the category as custom
and my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
i'll write
profit
by
let's say sc which stands for sales
channel
cool
finally
i'm going to create a report that will
show the revenue and profit by items
so i'll go ahead and create my
pivot table first
this time i'll choose my
total profit under values
and we'll also have
the revenue column
so i'll put my revenue at the top then
i am going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table
let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the orange line represents
the total profit
i'll click on ok
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title
i'll name it as
revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use
for our profit dashboard
next let's create a new sheet
and we'll get started with building a
dashboard
so i'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
we'll continue with the previous drill
so
first of all let's go to
the view tab and remove the grid lines
now
we'll
insert a background image
like we did for our revenue dashboard so
i'll go to insert
under illustrations i'll click on
pictures and select this device
i'm going to have the same background
i'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization
let's just
drag this
a bit to the right
will adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard
so here you can see i have brought my
revenue dashboard
and i'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
i'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right
the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
excel
profit dashboard instead of revenue
now
we'll copy each of the charts that we
just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had
profit by sales channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard
so let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
copy this as well
similarly i'll bring the other three
charts on to my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard i have added all the
charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
i have also
made some formatting for example i have
reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so i'll
select the first chart i'll right click
and i'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill i'll select no fill
next i'm going to remove the grid lines
so i'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so i'll go to design
actually format and i'll remove the
outline
next i'm going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and i'm
going to paste it here
okay
let me just select
the chart and i'll bring this to front
and i'll move this
to the back
next i'm going to change the font color
all to white
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
i'll do it for the x-axis as well okay
so here
i have my first
chart ready
the same i am going to do for the rest
of the charts
okay so now you can see here
i have formatted all my charts i have
also added
a blue background
you see here i have also formatted the
y labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit
similarly here i have added the data
labels this is for revenue
some of the charts also have the data
legends so here you can see the blue
color represents
offline and the red represents online
similarly here
you have the legends
i've also formatted the
map as well
okay now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our
slicers as well as timeline
first let me show you how to add a
timeline
so i'll
select one of the charts
and i'll go to insert
under insert i have the option to create
a timeline
so i'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so excel has only
shown us two columns so i'm going to
create my timeline based on order date
so i'll select my order date column and
i'll click on ok
you can see here this is called a
timeline i can expand this
now this timeline is based on months now
if i
scroll this timeline you can see here i
have
my
order year 2010 and i have all the 12
months similarly we have for 2011 then
we have for 2012
all the way till 2017.
now you can filter this in terms of
years quarters months or days let me
just select year now
so i have
years from 2010 till 2017
let me just squeeze this
and i'll place it somewhere here
on the right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slicers for my profit dashboard so i
have selected one of the charts
under insert i'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which
i want to create slicers so i'll create
a region
let me also select
country
let's say i want
the representative's name or the
customer's name
and i'll click on ok so here i have
created three slicers
let me
first
resize it and
i'll place it
on the right
similarly i'll place the
country column also
then we have
the region slicer
i'll
resize this and i'll bring it here
okay
the next thing we need to do is
i have to
connect all the slicers and the timeline
to
the pivot tables
for the profit dashboard so i'm going to
click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here
i'm going to select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here i have selected four and i need
one more which is
view table number 10 right click on ok
similarly let's create or connect my
region filter to all the pivot tables so
i right click
go to report connections
here i'll
choose all my pivot tables which are
based on profit
i'll click on ok
let's do it for the country slicer as
well
click on ok and similarly i'll connect
my
timeline as well i'll go to report
connections
and i'll select
all the pivot tables related to profit
then i'll click on ok
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so i am
selecting one of the pivot charts
i'll go to insert click on slicer
and i'll select
sales channel and hit ok
so i have my sales channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot
tables that are based on profit
click on ok
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing i want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 to 2017
now suppose
we want to know the profit that was
generated in the year 2012 so i'll just
click on
this range and now you can see our
charts only so information for 2012 so
this dot represents there was 51 million
profit in the year 2012. similarly you
can see here
the profit by sales channel for 2012.
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit each of these countries made in
2012.
if i scroll down you can see
the revenue and profit by items
now
if i select
another year let's say 2013 i can just
drag this to the right and
now you can see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it
went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
excel has prompted
all right so this is how you can use a
timeline
now as i said
we checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
i'll
send it back to the place where it was
and i'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose
you want to check the profit made by
different representatives you can select
them one by one
let's say adam churchill
this is the
profit generated by
adam churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
now suppose you want to see the profit
by different countries so you can use
the country slicer
let me just bring this to the middle
and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart i'll
just
bring this to the front so that you can
see it clearly
okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say united kingdom you can
select united kingdom so this is the map
of united kingdom and it tells you the
total profit that was generated in
united kingdom
and
below you can see the revenue and profit
for all the items that was sold in
united kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly
office supplies item made the highest
amount of profit in
united kingdom
now you can also select
multiple countries let's say
i want to know for france as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now i
have
united kingdom and france selected and
the other charts present
in my dashboard change accordingly
now i have my
country selected as india you can see
the map of india here
and these were the respective profit
values
now one thing to note here is this is
actually
not millions that should be in k that is
thousands so please mark this as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually k and not
million
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is
on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables in
pivot charts and then we formatted our
pivot charts based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing
you can also change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes
so here you can select different themes
currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select
another theme let's say face it
you see
the colors have changed and it looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out another
theme let's say organic
you see
our chart has changed let me just delete
this okay so now once you change the
theme the
text also change a bit you can see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore one more theme let's say
this time i am going to choose
depth
and
this is more
of a
green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my revenue
dashboard and see how it looks
there you go
so since we changed our theme even our
revenue dashboard is also impacted
so this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and
play with different themes colors fonts
and effects
all right
so in this demo we saw
how to create a revenue dashboard so we
created
line charts this combo chart pie chart
horizontal and vertical
bar charts and then we learnt how to add
slicers and connected to different pivot
tables
and we filtered our data to see
revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales channel
we learnt how to create
a map
and lots more and with that we have
reached the end of day 4 of our data
science week
on day 5 we are going to learn about
machine learning for data science thank
you all for watching today's live
session i hope it was useful and
informative see you tomorrow thanks
again and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you